Hallo Wolfgang, hallo Stefan.
Sollte es in der Oper auch eine Kisscam geben?
Ich denke nein.
Warum nicht? Das ist doch schade.
Man will doch für sich sein oder mit jemanden für sich sein und will nicht noch ständig irgendwo groß gesehen werden. Denn das ist ja auch quasi etwas intimes Musik wahrzunehmen, auch wenn man es in einer Gruppe tut, auch wenn man quasi in der Öffentlichkeit ist. Es ist doch eigentlich so eine Semiöffentlichkeit. Und es gab etwas Interessantes. Ich war mit Ole im Ballett in Wien und dieses Stück begann damit, dass eine Kamera ins Publikum blendete. Und dann suchte sie die erste Reihe ab, in der wir saßen. Und dann blendete sie genau auf mich. Und ich war plötzlich im Mittelpunkt riesengroß. Und ich dachte gleich, vielleicht hat Ole was ausgehackt und jetzt kommt Verstehen Sie Spaß oder so. Aber nein, das war es nicht. Es gehörte einfach zum Stück und dann verschwand ich auch wieder. Und ich dachte gut, zum Anfang ist das okay. Und das hatte ja auch mit der Choreografie zu tun. Und es gab auch Sinn, das so zu machen. Aber sonst, glaube ich, finde ich das sehr unangenehm. Und ja, das ist amüsant, was da jetzt passiert ist bei diesem Konzert, dass der CEO dort ist. Aber ich finde es an sich dann amüsant ist quasi, wie die Bilder, die produziert worden, die Sache an sich, finde ich katastrophal, wenn man sich ansieht, welcher Moralismus damit einhergeht jetzt. Also wie Leute ihr Liebesleben gestalten, muss ihnen überlassen sein. Und das müssen sie mit ihren Partnern und allen Anhängseln klären. Aber das hat in der Öffentlichkeit und vor allem hat das im Beruflichen nichts zu suchen, was für mich bedeutet, dass die jetzt zurücktreten mussten. Also sowohl er als der CEO, als auch da seine Mitarbeiterin. Sie war ja jetzt nicht die 19-jährige Praktikantin, sondern sie war auch in einer leitenden Funktion, erwachsene Frauen, die können auch machen, was sie wollen da. Dass das problematisiert wird und dass das zu solchen Dingen führt, wie Rücktritten jetzt, nur weil die eine Affäre haben und das nicht gemeldet haben dem Unternehmen. Was sollen die dem Unternehmen sagen? Also hören Sie, ich bin zwar verheiratet, aber ich habe jetzt gerade eine Affäre. Wir wissen noch nicht, ob es eine richtige Beziehung wird, aber die Affäre haben wir schon mal. Ich teile es Ihnen schon mal mit. Da sieht man eigentlich einen neuen Moralismus und dass das so wenig als Problem markiert wurde, sondern dass das viel bei vielen noch eine Schadenfreude ausgelöst hat, so da hat er es mal, da bist du ja selber schon, wenn du das machst. Das finde ich ist wirklich eine bedenkliche, bedenkliche Ebene, die wir da erleben, dass die Bilder selbst, die dabei entstanden sind, wie die sich da wegducken, okay, dass die Meme-Potenzial haben und lustig sind, geschenkt.
Ich finde, da ist ein Unterschied zwischen einem Kampf jetzt zum Beispiel zwischen uns beiden und zwischen einem Länderkampf. Bei einem Länderkampf sagt der Politiker, das sind eure Feinde. Wir haben ja persönlich nichts gegen die Menschen.
Sie ist wirklich klasse, Birai, oder wie sie heißt.
Weil zwei Mächte oben sagen, ihr müsst jetzt gegen die kämpfen, heißt das ja nicht, dass wir das machen müssen.
Wenn ihr gemerkt habt, hey, wir sind uns hier gerade einer Meinung, dann geht jetzt einen Schritt nach vorne. Und sie gehen wieder einen Schritt nach vorne, aber sie sind doch gar nicht einer Meinung. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das für ein Konzept ist. Ihr seid jetzt alle einen Schritt nach vorne gegangen. Was hat dich überzeugt?
Also ich bin einen Schritt nach vorne gegangen. Da wir langsam auf ein Ende kommen, dass wir auch gerne was für ihr Land tun würden.
Ja, Rekrutierung, tu was für dein Land.
Im Sinne von, ihr kommt mir jetzt entgegen und kämpft mit. Also gehe ich auch einfach mal einen Schritt nach vorne.
Und dann kämpfen wir alle für unser Land. Was immer das dann sein mag. Wir nähern uns dem Finale. Findet ihr, es ist im Jahr 2025 noch in Ordnung, dass man sagt, Jungs müssen, aber die Mädchen nicht? Nein. Man hat ja jetzt fast schon alles geklärt.
Das müssen nur noch die Frauen rekrutieren.
Aber wir kommen jetzt schon in brenzlige Gebiete. Also, sowohl der Kriegseinsatz ist in der Verfassung nicht vorgesehen, so wie Frauen auch nicht. Also dafür braucht man zwei Drittel Mehrheiten. Da müsste man jetzt hier direkt eine Anschlussdiskussion führen zum Thema, wie linksradikal ist jetzt die Linke? Sollte die CDU mit der mal reden oder nicht und so?
Oder eine schöne zwei Drittel Mehrheit mit der AfD.
Oder das, ja.
Wie fühlst du dich dabei, dass man sagt, ja die Mädchen, ach komm, die müssen es nicht. Aber die Jungs, die müssen es.
Also ich finde es unfair, weil viele Mädchen können auch so viel wie die Jungs oder sogar besser. Und deswegen sollte es für beide gleich sein. Merle.
Dass sie beide den Zettel ausfüllen, ich finde das sonst einfach auch irgendwie ungerecht.
Wie findet ihr denn die Idee, dass man sagt, wir gucken erstmal, ob es genug Freiwillige gibt?
Ich finde es gut, weil dann wird nicht jeder direkt gezwungen, sondern jeder kann für sich selber entscheiden, habe ich Lust darauf.
Ja, ich finde es auch gut, dass man nicht gezwungen werden muss dazu.
Was machen wir, wenn es nicht genug Freiwillige gibt?
Einfach die Leute, die dann körperlich fit genug dafür sind, dass man die dann einlädt. Und wenn sie dann immer noch nein sagen und das im Notfall ist, muss man die halt dazu zwingen.
Aber ist es einfach zwingen? Ist es nicht irgendwie unfair, dass so jemand wie du, der fit ist, der wird verpflichtet, so jemand wie ich, der eben nicht so wirklich fit ist, gesagt wird, oh komm, der Scherief, der kann zu Hause bleiben?
So ist das Leben halt einfach.
Die, die nicht fitten, gibt es ja auch zum Beispiel Bereiche in IT, vielleicht wären die darin gut und eine Bereicherung.
Jetzt mal kurz Hand hoch. Auch schon interessant jetzt also, der von der eigentlichen Gegenposition, der nicht kämpfen will, macht jetzt auch schon konstruktive Vorschläge, wo dann die nicht allzu fitten, doch noch für die Bundeswehr dienlich sein können. Ist ja auch immer wieder eine große Diskussion in Deutschland. Gab es ja früher schon mal die Wehrpflicht. Gibt es in anderen Ländern ja auch. Wer von euch wäre dafür, dass man diese Pflicht, erstmal zur Bundeswehr quasi zu gehen, komplett wieder einführt so? Nervt es? Zwei sind dafür. Macht es euch Sorgen, macht es euch Angst, dass jetzt gerade irgendwie sehr oft über solche Themen wie Krieg, Militär, Bundeswehr gesprochen wird?
Es hat immer so einen bösen Hintergedanken, da ich jetzt erst fertig mit der Schule bin und nicht mal mit zwei in meinem Leben stehe, hat mein Leben noch nicht mal richtig angefangen und direkt über sowas nachdenken muss, weil ich nicht viel lange noch hier in Frieden leben kann.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus, Veray?
Also mir macht das Thema natürlich auch ein bisschen Angst, weil mein ganzes Leben steht ja noch vor mir und ich hab noch viele Träume und Ziele, die ich erreichen will, die ich vielleicht durch Krieg nicht mehr erreichen kann.
Jetzt wird nach einem Kompromiss gefragt. Was ist etwas, womit jeweils andere Seite und auch wir selbst leben? Also auch interessant, der das Krieg dann kommt, der kommt und dann muss man damit leben. Es wird nicht über eine Strategie diskutiert, wie eigentlich ein Krieg zu verhindern wäre oder wie man sich dem entzieht. Das wäre ja eigentlich das, was jetzt das interessante Thema wäre, aber das kommt dann wie so ein Naturereignis. Können, in Sachen, Wehrpflicht, Bundeswehr und Co.
Unser Kompromissverschlag ist, dass wenn man mit beiden Beinen schon im Leben steht, also Schule fertig hat und sein Studium oder seine Ausbildung schon gemacht hat, dass man dann so ein Fragebunge bekommt.
Ob man halt freiwillig dahingehen will oder nicht. Es wird auch geprüft, ob man halt an der Front sein will oder nicht.
Und der Rest, der keine Lust darauf hat, muss einen Ersatzdienst leisten, damit das Pfeffel alle bleibt.
Das Gegenlager, das noch sagte, wir wollen nicht kämpfen, ist jetzt so weit nach vorne gegangen, dass sie sagen, wir machen jetzt eine Dienstpflicht, manche gehen zum Militär, und andere müssen sich dann woanders engagieren. Das hat man jetzt hier mit so einer Sendung produziert. Wie lautet euer Kompromissvorschlag?
Also, dass man in der Schule so eine Projektwoche hat, wo man aufgeklärt wird, was das Militär eigentlich ist, oder die Bundeswehr und was man da alles machen kann.
Ja, und dass man dann entscheiden darf, ob man das also nach der Schule direkt macht, vor seiner Ausbildung oder Studium. Aber das ist halt eine Pflicht. Nur, ob man das davor oder danach macht, ist halt selbst entschieden. Und die körperlich nicht fit sind, die machen dann einen Sozialdienst.
Ich merke schon, es gibt ziemlich große Gemeinsamkeiten bei euren Vorschlägen. Im Großen und Ganzen seid ihr euch alle einig, dass jeder in diesem Land etwas zurückgeben sollte, sei es in militärischer oder nicht-militärischer Form. Sind sich alle einig?
Ja. Okay, dann kommt zu mir ins Kompromissfeld.
Das gibt es doch alles nicht.
Ja, also das ist ja alles ganz schräg. Diese Idee, dass man überhaupt erst dann seinem Land was Gutes tut, wenn man Krieg für ist, führt, ist ja schon mal absurd. Zweitens, was ja unausgesprochen bleibt, ist ja, dass das alles nur getriggert wird durch den Ukrainekrieg. Der Ukrainekrieg, da lebten 40 Millionen Menschen. Es sind sehr viel mehr geflüchtet, als an die Front geschickt worden. An der Front kämpfen ungefähr so zwei Prozent der Männer, also ein Prozent der Bevölkerung. Das ist verschwindend. Und man fragt sich ja die ganze Zeit, also wir auch, warum eskaliert dieser Krieg nicht? Aber warum hört er auch nicht auf? Warum ist das so ein komischer Schwebezustand? Und ich habe nun über Jahre jede heute Journal- und Tagesthemsendung dazu gesehen. Ich verfolge seit bestimmt mindestens einem Jahr diesen, was nun Herr General, wo so ein ehemaliger NATO-General mit 45 Jahren Diensterfahrung, wie er jetzt erst wieder sagte, mehrfach die Woche mehrere Stunden einfach darüber redet, was in der Ukraine los ist. Und man denkt sich so, eigentlich gar nichts so. Also es ist einfach der Normalszustand Krieg. Und dann sieht man so ein paar Dokus, wie Leute in so einem Schützengraben liegen. Der Schützengraben ist aber nicht an der Front, sondern der ist so weit weg, dass man die Drohne gerade noch zur Front fliegen lassen kann. Und da sitzt keinesfalls der durchtrainierteste Typ, sondern da sitzt einfach der super Hacker Tecky, allerdings mit 30 Kilo Übergewicht drin. Und um den scharen sich zehn Leute, um den zu beschützen, weil der einfach mit der Drohne und so einen guten Umgang hat. Also diese ganze Idee von junge Leute, die auf ihrem Fitness-Top-Level sind, Brute-Forcen jetzt, das deutsche Schicksal irgendwo, ist sowieso schon mal völlig daneben. Dann möchte ich hier empfehlen, es gibt bei Arte eine Doku, der heißt die Nuklearfalle. Die geht 90 Minuten. Wenn man die gesehen hat, denkt man über alles anders nach. In Deutschland gibt es keine Atomkraft mehr. In Europa gibt es aber noch 111 Atomkraftwerke und die Hälfte davon steht in Frankreich. So, Amerika möchte jetzt gerade diese komische KI-Wende machen. Es wird ein Datencenter gebaut, die sind so groß wie Manhattan, heißt es dann immer und so. Irgendwie, ja, Stromverbrauch, 5 Gigawatt pro Einrichtung. Amerika möchte gerne 200 Atomkraftwerke bauen. America hat, ich nenne jetzt die Zahl an Uranaufbereitungsanlagen, 0. 60 Prozent des Weltmarkts wird abgedeckt über Rossatom. Das ist eine Firma, die quasi direkt Putin gehört. Jedes Mal, wenn ich jetzt Nachrichten höre mit, Macron hat mal wieder bei Putin angerufen, oder Trump hat irgendein Ultimatum gestellt, denke ich mir, klar, absolut. Ihr macht einfach alle nur ihr, euren, das ist, also man will es nicht zu übertreiben, aber ich sag euch, nach einer, nach dem anderthalb Stunden Nuklearfalle denkt man erstmal, das ganze Ding muss man komplett unter diesem Weltmarkturan sehen. Das, was China mit seltenen Erden macht, nämlich zu sagen, wir bleiben hier standfest, wir buddeln das weiter aus, egal, wie wir die Umwelt zerstören, egal, wie wenig uns das bringt. In 20 Jahren werden wir feststellen, niemand sonst als wir hat sowohl Zugang zu dieser Schlüsseltechnologie, das aufzubereiten, oder halt überhaupt die Möglichkeit, den Markt zu beliefern. So, und jetzt hängt die ganze KI-Wende inhaltlich über diese Chips davon ab, dass aus China diese seltenen Erden kommen. So, und die Energie dafür kommt aus Russland.
Und es wird hier aber darüber gesprochen, als seien wir 1870 und gehen ins Gefecht.
Das ist, also diese Idee von Krieg, die da da hinten drin steckt, ja, ist einfach völlig absurd. Die hält mit nichts Stand. Also die hält nicht fünf Minuten Stand in so einer Argumentation.
Wenn der Russe hier auf der Straße steht, würdest du mich dann verteidigen.
Völlig absurd. Also es geht hier um so andere Sachen und überhaupt.
Aber was man hier natürlich einimpfen kann damit, und ich glaube darum geht es ja dann über das militärische Rekrutieren und so hinaus, und das macht mich auch so besonders wütend ist, dass man von jungen Leuten jetzt fordert, dass sie sich unterwerfen der herrschenden Politik. Dass sie bereit sind Opfer zu bringen, dass sie sagen, ja stimmt, mir steht das auch eigentlich so, alles gar nicht zu. Ach so, ich soll noch dafür was geben, ich soll noch ein Lebensjahr dafür spenden. Okay, dann mache ich das natürlich. Darum soll es eigentlich gehen. Es soll nicht darum gehen, was ja eigentlich eine Sendung wie Logo, die sich an Jugendliche und Kinderrichtet ja tun sollte, nämlich die Anliegen der Kinder zu vertreten, sondern die Kinder und Jugendlichen sollen jetzt schon die Anliegen der Alten Republik früh lernen, damit sie sich diesen unterwerfen.
Ich will mal drei Clips spielen zum Thema. Das sind jetzt junge Leute, Setting ist natürlich eine Turnhalle, ist ja klar, man malt da Linien auf dem Boden, aber lässt das Tor hinten noch stehen und baut auch so einen Stufenbaren dahin, damit das alles, das ist hier, sind ja Optimität der Kinder. Diese Kinder starten jetzt in eine Gesellschaft, in der folgende Kennziffern gelten.
Die Chance nach einer Ausbildung übernommen zu werden, war in Deutschland noch nie so hoch wie im vergangenen Jahr. Laut einer Studie des Instituts für Arbeitmarkt- und Berufsforschung lag die Übernahmequote bei 79 Prozent und erreichte damit einen Höchstwert. Im Finanz- und Versicherungswesen der öffentlichen Verwaltung und der Energie- und Wasserversorgung wurden sogar rund 90 Prozent der Azubis übernommen. Am niedrigsten war die Quote in der Land- und Forstwirtschaft.
So, Energie- und Wasserversorgung, öffentliche Verwaltung, Finanz- und Versicherungswesen, das ist grundlegende Infrastruktur, wird mittlerweile so händeringend gesucht, dass nur noch jeder Zehnte in den Ausbildungsprogrammen aussortiert wird. Ja. Alle anderen werden auf Biegen und Brechen dort übernommen. Ja. So, diese Jugendlichen werden nicht vor die Wahl gestellt, möchtest du gern für dein Land sterben, sondern da kommt einer aus der Finanzverwaltung, einer aus der Versicherungswesen, einer aus der öffentlichen Verwaltung und einer von der Energie und einer von der Wasserversorgung und fragt, könntest du bitte bei mir arbeiten? Und dann sagt der andere, nee doch, bei mir, bei mir, bei mir. Und dann, was kriege ich Einstiegsgehalt? Kriege ich einen Handshake-Bonus gleich mal und so? Ja, das ist die Entscheidung für diese Jugendlichen. Aber sie werden davon wenig haben, denn dieses Geld, das sie hier so ein bisschen rauspressen können, weil sie einfach so wenige sind und so knapp, wird aufgefressen werden durch folgende zwei Kennziffern.
Die Pflege im Heim wird für Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner immer teurer. Die Zuzahlung im ersten Jahr liegt erstmals durchschnittlich bei über 3000 Euro pro Monat. Das ergab eine Auswertung des Verbandes der Ersatzkassen.
So, 3000 Leute im Monat. Und jetzt multiplizieren wir das mal. 3000 Euro im Monat für einen Pflegeplatz. Also, diese jungen Menschen haben Boomer-Eltern, die nicht sehr gesund alt werden. Das kann man flächendeckend über diese Generation, die einmal durch das Privatwernsehen wurde erfunden. Könntet ihr bitte ganz viel rauchen, Zucker essen und so weiter? Also, die sind ja einmal durch diese Nudel durch. Jetzt haben wir ja wieder so eine Fitnesswelle, die so ein bisschen, nee, du bist vielleicht doch selbst schuld. Aber wir haben jetzt eine Generation, die in die Pflege kommt, die nicht daran selbst schuld ist, dass sie einfach drei Tonnen Zucker zu viel gegessen hat, brauner Arse.
Und wir haben natürlich Menschen, die Einzelkinder sind oder einen Bruder, eine Schwester haben.
Das kommt noch dazu, die Boomer haben ja noch ein Kind.
Das heißt, diese 3.100 Euro, die da anfallen, die können nicht mal gerade durch sieben geteilt werden.
Nein, genau, genau. Wir rechnen das gleich mal durch. Also, wir merken uns jetzt 3000 mal grob als Monatsbeitrag und jetzt den Multiplikator.
Mussten Sie schon mal einen Pflegeplatz im Heim organisieren für Ihre Eltern oder Ihren Partner? Tja, im besten Fall bleibt uns das erspart. Allerdings bei mehr als fünfeinhalb Millionen Pflegebedürftigen im vergangenen Jahr und einer alternden Gesellschaft könnte es für jeden von uns dann doch zum Thema werden.
So, pass auf, fünfeinhalb Millionen mal dreitausend, 16,5... Warte mal, ich muss nochmal... Wir machen das jetzt mal mit GBT, damit ihr das auch hört.
Ich will nur sagen, diese 3100 Euro im Monat, das ist schon ein Drittel mehr als das Mediangehalt, das man aufbringen muss.
Genau, also wir rechnen das jetzt mal volkswirtschaftlich durch. Hey, GBT, hörst du mich?
Ja, ich höre dich laut und deutlich.
Pass auf, wir haben eine Frage. Du multiplizierst uns jetzt mal den volkswirtschaftlichen Ertrag, der hier notwendig ist, raus. Also 3000 Euro kostet ein Pflegeplatz pro Monat. 5,5 Millionen Menschen bräuchten ein. Wie viel ergibt das dann auf 12 Monate, also in Jahressumme volkswirtschaftlich?
Okay, dann rechnen wir das mal kurz durch. Also 3000 Euro pro Monat multipliziert mit 5,5 Millionen Menschen ergibt schon mal den Monatsbetrag. Und wenn wir das dann noch mit 12 multiplizieren, haben wir den Jahresbetrag. Das sind also insgesamt 198 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr. Eine ganz schöne Summe.
Eine ganz schöne Summe. So, 200 Milliarden im Jahr.
Die hat aber eine erotische Stimme.
Ja, kann man sich aussuchen. Also 200 Milliarden im Jahr, das sind bei 4 Billionen, wir sind hier schon im mehr, also nicht nur im 0, % Bereich volkswirtschaftlichen Beitrag. Also wir sind relativ nah an so 5% Diskussion zum Thema Werb-Tings und so, ja. Und das ist einfach absurd. Also alle Diskussionen zum Thema sind einfach völlig absurd. Wir können solche Themen wie hier, und mit denen sind diese, also alles, was wir jetzt gehört haben, die Diskussion, ist virtuell. Falls der Russe mal angreift, würdest du dann, wenn da eine Waffe auf dem Boden liegt und so weiter, dann vielleicht zielen und schließen, so irgendwie, wenn deine Schwester im Lebenraum noch bedroht ist, so blablabla. So, dieses Pflegeding ist einfach super konkret.
Aber es geht hier tatsächlich darum, den jungen Leuten was aufzuoktouieren. Sie sollen gar nicht rebellieren, sondern sie sollen verstehen, aber diese Ressourcen sind nicht da.
Das ist so virtuell.
Aber wenn du jetzt hier die Vorschläge ansiehst, im Neuen Deutschland hat Eva Roth einen Artikel geschrieben, ich empfehle den sehr höhere Kosten für Pflegebedürftige, notfalls das Haus verkaufen, so heißt der. Der beschäftigt sich mit einer Studie des Arbeitgeberverbands. Da gibt es jetzt so einen Vorschlag, was eigentlich zu tun wäre, um genau dies aufzufangen und die sagen nämlich, der Staat gibt ja noch viel zu viel aus. Was hat jetzt nun diese AG, die sich da gegründet hat, von Arbeitgebervertretern erarbeitet? Folgendes, sie schlagen vor, im ersten Jahr der Pflegebedürftigkeit soll die Pflegeversicherung, gestaffelt nach Pflegegraden, noch keine Leistungen erbringen. In dieser Karenzzeit sollen die Menschen ihre Pflege selbst bezahlen.
Was einfach nur bedeutet, dass sich alle wünschen, dass die Oma bald stirbt.
Dazu kommen wir gleich zu genau diesem Thema. Dann, Hilfebedürftige, die in einem Pflegeheim leben, müssen derzeit im Durchschnitt rund 3.100 Euro pro Monat aus eigener Tasche bezahlen. Darin enthalten sind rund 1.580 Euro für die Pflege. Künftig sollen sie nach dem Willen der BDA noch höhere Kosten übernehmen. Der Leistungszuschlag der Pflegeversicherung soll auf Personen konzentriert werden, die seit mehr als zwei Jahren im Heim leben. Also anfangs nicht. Ob diese Zuschuss in den ersten beiden Jahren ganz wegfallen oder gekürzt werden soll, das ist noch nicht klar. Man möchte außerdem, dass die Pflegenden, die familiär pflegen, so gehalten werden, dass sie knapp über dem Existenzminimum sind, damit für die nicht extra noch mal Sozialhilfe anfällt. Aber sonst soll es kein Schonvermögen mehr geben. Also das Schonvermögen, was also alles für die Pflege aufgebraucht werden soll, soll nur noch bei 10.000 Euro pro Person liegen.
Willst du mehr Erbe? Das ist ja eigentlich interessant, dass man jetzt plötzlich so eine Erbendiskussion hat.
Absolut, wir haben die ganze Zeit, wenn irgendjemand von der Linken sagt, wir brauchen drei Prozent Erbschaftssteuer, sofort Omas kleinen Häuschen. Omas kleinen Häuschen wird hier gerade enteignet. Und zwar fließt das in die Pflege hinein und hier gibt es noch weitere Vorschläge. Und zwar auch für die direkten Angehörigen von Pflegenden.
Wolfgang, frage dich nicht, was dein Land für dich tun kann, sondern frage dich nur noch, was du für dein Land tun.
Das heißt, wenn deine Partnerin jetzt da plötzlich gepflegt werden muss, dann kann sein, dass alles für dich draufgeht und du wirst knapp über einem Existenzminimum gehalten, damit du nicht Sozialhilfeempfänger wirst. Das ist hier der Vorschlag, der gemacht wird. Deswegen hier, wir sind ja nicht autorisiert, um Steuerberatung zu geben. Ich rate jedem Menschen, der Eltern hat und die Eltern vielleicht dann über 60 sind, sich jetzt mit, und da ist vielleicht irgendwie eine Eigentumswohnung oder ein Reihenhaus, sich jetzt mit den Eltern mal zusammenzusetzen und da mal ein Notar aufzusuchen. Es ist kein Verbrechen, mal mit den Eltern anzusprechen, was hier eigentlich passiert, damit man nicht nachher in etwas reingerät, was eine große Enteignungswelle ist. Du hast schon angesprochen, hier ist doch interessant, so das erste Jahr soll gar nichts mehr übernommen werden. Ich empfehle den ganzen Artikel, es geht noch viel weiter. Dann lese ich im Juli in der New York Times ein Artikel, The Perverse Economics of Assisted Suicide, von Louise Perry. Und die schreibt, dass man gerade in Großbritannien jetzt die Sterbehilfe sehr stark gelockert hat.
Ja, wie das kanadische Modell daraus ist ja damals.
Darauf geht sie auch rein, genau. Sie sagt, die Befürworter der Legalisierung der Sterbehilfe haben die schlechte Angewohnheit, mit einer Motte and Bailey Argumentation zu arbeiten. Von ihrer leicht zu verteidigen Motte aus bestehen sie darauf, dass ein unheilbar Kranker, der einen schmerzhaften und würdelosen Tod fürchtet, medizinische Hilfe und die Begleitung seiner Angehörigen in Anspruch nehmen können sollte, wenn er sich für einen vorzeigen Austritt aus dem Leben entscheidet. Sie sagte aber, das Bailey-Ding ist viel relevanter. Nämlich, wenn man sich ansieht, dass in den Niederlanden im Prinzip jetzt fünf Prozent der Gesamtzahl der Todesfälle auf Sterbehilfe zurückgeht. Wenn man sieht, wie in Kanada das so sehr gelockert wurde, dass es darum geht, auch Leute, die belastend sind für das Krankensystem, ihnen zumindest schon mal die Option nahe zu legen, dass es auch anders geht. Sie schreibt hier, Roger Foley, ein 49-Jähriger, der mit einer schweren neurodegenerativen Erkrankung geboren wurde, sagte 2020 vor dem kanadischen Parlament aus, dass er das Gefühl habe, das Krankenhauspersonal habe versucht, ihn zum assistierten Suizid zu zwingen, indem es mir mit einer Gebühr von 1.800 Dollar pro Tag drohte oder mich ohne die für mein Leben notwendige Pflege aus dem Krankenhaus zu entlasten drohte. Sie schreibt jetzt weiter hier in diesem Artikel. Die Regierungen scheinen sich durchaus bewusst zu sein, was da passiert. Sie schreibt, sie ist Britin, ein Freund, der früher im britischen Finanzministerium gearbeitet hat, sagte mir einmal in einem Moment der Offenheit, dass das einzige Problem mit dem Programm der Sterbehilfe aus finanzieller Sicht darin besteht, dass dieses bei jungen Menschen zu beliebt und bei Alten nicht beliebt genug ist. Ich empfehle den Artikel sehr.
Das sind die Tötungsdiskussionen für die jungen Leute, die man jetzt in Deutschland mal führen sollte. Und nicht hier ob der Rusche irgendwie ist.
Sterben für das Land im Sinne von, bin ich jetzt plötzlich, werde ich als Belastung wahrgenommen und würde ich meinen Angehörigen plötzlich auf, weil die Pflegeversicherung schlichen wird, dass die jetzt beim Existenzminimum angekommen sind. Das ist wirklich jetzt eine Form der Menschenverachtung, die in diesen ganzen Vorschlägen liegt. Über die müsste man diskutieren. Deswegen habe ich ja eingangs gesagt, so ein Kompromissformat könnte eben in zwei Richtungen gehen. Einmal könnte man den dreien, die da kämpfen wollten, sagen, ja, aber wisst ihr eigentlich mit der Pflege und wisst ihr eigentlich mit den Ausbildungsplätzen und so weiter. Und dann hätte man die vielleicht auch mal davon abbekommen. Aber du siehst einfach, wo die jetzt gerade alle hinführen. Und ich finde das so beschämend. Und ich bin ja auch jemand, der immer wieder auch den öffentlich-rechtlichen, ja, ich sage jetzt nicht gelobt hat, aber ich bin jemand, der immer ihn als System verteidigt hat.
Ich lobe nur noch Arte.
Ich komme wirklich in meine Zweifel und würde, also ich bin befassungslos darüber, dass ein Moderator sowas macht. Es ist wirklich im höchsten Maße schändlich. Und die haben also diese ganze Logo-Redaktion, die ja schon vorher so Sprechende Panzer und sowas macht, die haben meine ganze Verachtung. Ich will noch einen letzten Punkt machen zum Thema Zeit, Lebenszeit. Scott Galloway hat ja viele Podcasts, hat wenig Zeit. Und das war halb, man nimmt ja manchmal Ed Elson oder beziehungsweise Ed Elson ist die meiste Zeit da und ruft dann nur Scott Galloway so zwischendurch an.
Das ist ein geiles Podcastkonzept.
Es ist ein gutes Podcastkonzept. ProfG Markets. Da geht es um eine neue Investition von LVMH.
L.Catterton, eine private-equity-Firmae, die von LVMH geteilt werden, beträgt 20% an Steig in der privaten Jet-Kompanie Flexjet. Die 800 Millionen Dollar Investition, die die Firma an 4 Billionen Dollar wert, ist die größte Fundraise in der privaten Aviationindustrie.
Der Konzern von Bernard Hano steigt also jetzt in Privatflüge, ein Privatschatz. Was ist da los? Nun, es ist ja so, wir entmaterialisieren uns einzelne Produkte, die wir zu Hause so lagern können, sind vielleicht gar nicht mehr so wichtig. Aber das Erlebnis ist jetzt das, was den neuen Luxus herstellt. Aber Scott Galloway spricht noch etwas anderes an.
The other trend is psychographic. And that is COVID, I think, it hit a lot of people in between the eyes, the kind of the finite nature of lives. They're usually old. And what do old people have in common who are wealthy. They come to the recognition that they have more money than time. And if you, I've said for a while when we sat on this podcast, if you want to build a trillion dollar company, you have to build a time machine. Amazon saves you time. Netflix saves you time.
Es geht also um das Zeitsparen. Weiter sagt er?
If I can fly private in and out of these speaking gigs in remote areas and not wait in line at TSA and not miss flights, which I do a lot, I calculated it every year since I joined FlexJet. I save between 13 and 18 days. In other words, I can get home from Kohler, Wisconsin that afternoon, instead of leaving the next morning and connecting to Atlanta. And if you think about over 10 years, you're talking about six months with your family. And at the end of your life, granted you have to have the money, but as you know, I'm not a billionaire, but I'm wealthy. And I've decided to spend a disproportionate amount of my income on private jet travel, because at the end of my life, I don't think I'm gonna want the money back. I think I'm gonna want another six months with my family.
Das ist eine sehr merkwürdige Logik. Erstmal, denn man könnte auch sagen, musst du so viele Termine noch annehmen? Du hast so viel Geld.
Genau, machst du in diesen Remote Locations. Dein Wort kommt übers Podcasten. Ob du da nochmal 2000 Leute besingen, ist doch ein...
Brauchst du nochmal 100.000 Euro Honorar von irgendeiner Hotelkette, die dich eingeladen hat, um einen Vortrag genau darüber zu halten?
Ich glaube auch, da gibt es einen Sweetspot, wo Skategallaway weit drüber ist.
Ja, aber das Interessante ist jetzt, dass er hier immer wieder betont, ja, die Zeit ersparen, man will Zeit mit der Familie verbringen. Und diese Leute haben alle wahnsinnig viel Geld. Nur, dass mit der Zeit ist das Problem. Und deswegen investieren sie ihr Geld jetzt in mehr Zeit. Er sagte auch.
Yeah, really big trends. And just the stat that Mia pulled together that really blew my mind was now that one in six flights tracked by the FAA are private planes.
Eine von sechs Flügen ist jetzt schon ein Privatflug geworden. Also wir sehen, wie sehr das expandiert. Ed Elson, der Co-Host, unterstreicht das nochmal.
And now let me just read you a quote from Ken Ricci, who's the chairman of FlexJet. And he's describing why El Katzen invested. He said, quote, El Katzen presented us some ideas about where they see the future of luxury. They basically see that the luxury of the future is time. And they see that in private travel, you can recoup your time.
Und solche Formate wie Logo sind dafür da, den jungen Menschen, die kein Geld haben, auch noch die Zeit zu stehlen. Ihnen auch noch zu sagen, ihr sollt noch ein Jahr arbeiten. Und dann gibt's noch die große Debatte gerade, wie lange willst du denn eigentlich leben? Willst du so lange im Altenheim sein? Und vor allem, wie lange willst du denn in Rente sein? Musst du nicht mal lieber länger arbeiten? Das heißt, denen Leuten, denen kein großes Kapital zur Verfügung steht, denen raubt man jetzt noch mehr Zeit, während die, die so viel Geld haben, dass sie gar nicht mehr wissen, wohin damit, sich sagen, wie könnte ich denn meinen Tag noch verlängern? Wie könnte ich denn meinen Lebensabend verlängern? Ach ja, ich kann mir ja Privatjet-Flüge leisten, dann bin ich überall schneller, muss nirgends mehr anstehen und brauche fünf Hotelnächte weniger. Das ist gerade der große Klassenkampf, der stattfindet um die Zeit. And what's happening with all these military-military debates and so on is actually an attack on the time of the people who have little.
Exposed by the people who have a lot of money and would like to have a little more time. Yes, there is this very good movie, we have mentioned it a few times, with Justin Timberlake. Yes, in time. Where the time, like a cassette number, is simply programmed in the arm. Da kann man sich das mal anschauen. Peter Thiel war in einem Podcast. Der wurde mir so oft empfohlen wie dir wahrscheinlich diese Sendung da gerade.
Der will ja auch Zeit sparen, der verjüngt sich ja.
Der verjüngt sich, das sah auch sehr jung aus. Wir hören aber nur die Audioversion. Es lief auf eine interessante Argumentation hinaus, die uns und das könnte man ja jetzt bei diesem Zeitthema auch sagen von eben. Leute entwickeln intuitiv so ein Ding ohne dass der ideologische Überbau des Zeitraubs direkt adressiert wird oder programmiert wird. Das ist so eine sozusagen eine analytische Beobachtung von uns jetzt. Und so ist das auch hier, dass wir deutsche Stimmen haben, wie zum Beispiel von Jan Fleischhauer oder Wolfram Weimer, die wir gar nicht dechiffriert bekommen, weil die selbst zu doof sind, um uns das Angebot zu machen aus ihren eigenen Sprechakten. Also gehen wir über Bande und holen uns das bei Peter Thiel. Peter Thiel ist also bei der New York Times im Interesting Times Podcast und redet mal über die globale Monopolisierung von Staatlichkeit, seine große Angst.
You have been giving talks recently about the concept of the Antichrist, which is a Christian concept, an apocalyptic concept. What does that mean to you? What is the Antichrist?
How much time do we have?
We've got as much time as you have to talk about the Antichrist.
All right, well, I could talk about it for a long time. But I think there's always a question, how do we articulate some of these existential risks, some of the challenges we have? And they're all framed as sort of runaway dystopian science texts. There's a risk of nuclear war. There's a risk of environmental disaster, maybe something specific like climate change, although there are lots of other ones we could come up with. There's a risk of bio weapons. You have all the different sci-fi scenarios. Obviously, there are certain types of risks with AI. But I always think that if we're gonna have this frame of talking about existential risks, perhaps we should also talk about the risk of another type of a bad singularity, which I would describe as the one world totalitarian state. Because I would say the default political solution people have for all these existential risks is one world governance.
So, wir entfalten das jetzt mal. Er wird angesprochen auf den Antichristen und macht dann plötzlich ein Bild auf von, wird auch gleich explizieren, Armageddon, Weltuntergangsszenarien. Der Atomkrieg, die KI, die alles übernimmt, die Biohacking, irgendwas, jemand greift in die Gene ein. Oder der Klimawandel. Die Welt muss sich dagegen stellen mit einer Stimme. So, er hat also diese Angst vor einer politischen Weltvergesellschaftung, die faktisch bei der Wirtschaft schon gegeben ist. Also niemand kommt jetzt auf die Ideen Konzern wirklich noch mal auf, das ist ein deutsches Unternehmen oder so runterzubrechen, sondern wir wissen alle, die agieren global, die sind auch überall an den Börsen gelistet und so weiter. Es ist also, finde ich, ganz einfach dechiffrierbar und auch kritisierbar, dass hier ein Milliardär sitzt, der sagt, ich in meiner Machtdomäne Geld mir liegt, die ganze Welt zu Füßen und die Politiker dürfen auf gar keinen Fall mit mir auf Augenhöhe kommen. Deswegen bitte 200 Staaten, besser werden 400. Weil dann kann ich nämlich einfach drüberfliegen und so. Also eigentlich ein ganz profanes, ganz einfaches Argument zu sagen, ne ne, ihr bleibt mal eine Etage tiefer. Primatwirtschaft. So. Aber er kann das natürlich nicht einfach so sagen, dass er hier ein Milliardär ist, der gerne grenzüberschreitend und so weiter, nicht von Steuerregimen, die weltweit koordiniert werden, die enge gedrängt werden möchte. Weshalb er hier mit so einer wahnsinnigen Idee von der Antichrist und das Armageddon kämpfen hier. Also, so das Dilemma ist Antichrist oder Armageddon, ja? Also er fiel das hier mal aus. Das ist wirklich, das ist haarsträubend.
That was a short film that was put out by the Federation of American Scientists in the late 40s. It starts with a nuclear bomb blowing up the world. And obviously you need a one world government to stop it. One world or none. And the Christian framing, which in some ways is the same question, is Antichrist or Armageddon. You have the one world state of the Antichrist or we're sleepwalking towards Armageddon. One world or none, Antichrist or Armageddon, on one level are the same question.
Das ist so irre. Also er hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Zero to One, für die wirtschaftliche Domäne.
Er sagt, einer soll regieren.
Eine Monopol, eine Branche, ein Unternehmen für alles.
Er sagt sogar, ihr allen Gründern, wenn ihr nicht glaubt, dass euer Unternehmen ein Monopol werden kann, dann lasst das gleich.
Aber für die Politik? Genau das nicht. Das ist seine größte Angst in der Politik, was in der Wirtschaft sein größter Wunsch ist, sein zentrales Desiderat für sich und so.
Wie kann es denn sein, dass er überhaupt diese Gefahr so stark sieht? Denn es ist ja noch eines zu beobachten. Es gibt ja mehr Länder denn je. Also dieses Nation Building ist ja das große Konzept, das wir bei Francis Fukuyama, der sich lange damit beschäftigt hat, nachvollziehen können, der das ja auch sehr unterstützt hat. Und wir sehen ja auch diese sehr vielen Autonomiebewegungen, bis hin jetzt zu der Frage, der Palästina, wer erkennt es als Staat an und so etwas, dass wir nur die Tendenz dazu haben, dass es mehr Staaten gibt. Es ist ja gar nicht so, dass wir diese eine Weltregierung bald haben, sondern es gibt ja auch Strömungen, die sagen, wir müssen noch viel föderaler wählen und noch mal da Abspaltungen und so etwas. Oder wir sehen ja auch im Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion, dass sich da wieder Einzelstaaten herausgebildet haben, die nur nationale Identität zu...
Du formulierst es jetzt so im Passiv. Ich würde ja sagen, dass in Amerika gerade alle Diskussionen laufen zum Thema Abtreibung zum Beispiel. Nee, das sollen die Bundesstaaten selber machen. Da halten wir uns raus. Also dieser Abbau von föderaler Bundesregierung, von Big Government, der in Amerika ja forciert wird, wird ja ganz aktiv von denen vorangetrieben. Also dass jetzt die Ostküste plötzlich in Kalifornien einfällt und da Marines stationiert. Und zwar mit dieser Semantik, wie damals in nach Bagdad gegangen wurden. Die tapferen Leute von Los Angeles müssen jetzt befreit werden und so. Ja, also lauter so ein Scheiß. Also es ist ja genau diese Zersplitterung der politischen Sphäre, damit man mit seiner ökonomischen Macht dann noch bessere Handhabe drüber hat und bloß keiner in die Quere kommt. Also in deren Sicht, die sind schon bereit, auch Amerika einfach wirklich zu zerstören und auf dem Weltmarkt sozusagen untauglich zu machen, so in der politischen Sphäre. Hauptsache sie haben zumindest mal ihr Ereignis Amerika so unter ihrer Fuchtel. Also, es ist schon extrem bescheuert. So, er fühlt es hier ein bisschen aus. Also, das ist jetzt das zentrale Dilemma, das auch das Denken treibt. Und er kommt auf eine Person zu sprechen, als dann auch so die Frage kommt, der Antichrist, wer ist denn das?
The way the Antichrist would take over the world is you talk about Armageddon nonstop. You talk about existential risk nonstop. And this is what you need to regulate. It's the opposite of the picture of...
Also immer wenn jemand kommt und sagt, Ich fürchte einen Atomkrieg. Wir sollten das mal in einem globalen und so weiter kann nicht die UN. Dann sieht er sofort den Antichristen, der durch diese Leute spricht. Also muss es ja eine Person geben, die, und wir kennen ja ein Thema, das gerade besonders global diskutiert wird.
Baconian science from the 17th, 18th century, where the Antichrist is like some evil tech genius, evil scientist who invents this machine to take over the world. People are way too scared for that. In our world, the thing that has political resonance is the opposite. The thing that has political resonance is we need to stop science. We need to just say stop to this. And this is where, yeah, I don't know, in the 17th century, I can imagine a Dr. Strange Love, Edward Teller type person taking over the world. In our world, it's far more likely to be Greta Thunberg.
So, Greta Thunberg. Will ja die ganze Welt unter einem Klimaregime retten, sagt sie. Dabei bedroht sie die Welt einfach nur mit einem Armageddon-Szenario, um sich selbst als Antichrist zu positionieren. Und als Antichrist ein politisches Monopol aufzubauen, das den wirtschaftlichen Monopol dann in der Quere steht.
Ja.
So.
Denn man weiß, die Nationalstaaten werden aus Einsicht und Angst dann ja ihre Souveränität aufgeben. Und alles Greta Thunberg in die Hände legen.
Es wird vor allem alles dem Klima untergeordnet. Und da sieht er ein Kontinent, der ihm besonders ein Dorn im Auge ist.
Greta Thunberg ist auf einem Boot in der Meditärerien. Sie protestiert Israel.
Also der Moderator Ross Duthedt macht sie auch ein bisschen lustig. Also Greta, die gerade auf einem Segelboot vor Gaza ist jetzt der Antichrist oder was?
I just don't see the promise of safety from AI, safety from tech, even safety from climate change right now as a powerful universal rallying cry, absent accelerating change and real fear of total catastrophe.
Man, these things are so hard to score, but I think environmentalism is pretty powerful. You know, I don't know if it's absolutely powerful enough to create a one-world totalitarian state. But man, it is...
I think it is not.
It is in its current form.
I want to say it's the only thing people still believe in in Europe.
So. Nach 2000 Jahren Katholizismus ist der letzte große Glaube, unter dem sich alle Europäer vereinigen und am besten eine Weltherrschaft anstreben wollen, um den Klimawandel abzuwenden. Das ist natürlich genau der Tenor, den wir hier in Europa haben.
Du hast es ja jetzt gerade noch mal gehört bei Lanz und Precht im Podcast mit Luisa Neubauer.
Genau, also ein Podcast für die Ewigkeit.
Das ist ja erstaunlich, dass er auch gar nicht erkennt, was zum Beispiel Adam Toos stark gemacht hat. Diese klimapolitischen Ambitionen, werden sie wirklich einmal umgesetzt, bedeuten ja eine wirkliche multipolare Weltordnung. Also Toos sagt ja genau das Gegenteil. Er sagt ja eben, es entsteht nicht der Superstaat. Und das ist ja gerade das Problem.
Es ist nicht Großatom, das in Amerika Energie ist, sondern jeder macht sein eigenes kleines.
Und das ist ein Problem für eine Weltpolizei USA, die dann plötzlich nicht mehr eine Handhabe darüber hat, weil die sich selbst unabhängig gemacht haben durch Windenergie, Solarenergie.
Ich meine, schon RWE hat keine Handhabe mehr über deine kleine Solarpalene auf dem Balkon, nachdem du sie einmal gekauft hast.
Und man könnte das ja noch viel regionaler, die ganze Energiewende gestalten. Also man könnte wirklich alles, was auch nur noch Superstaat riecht, vollkommen ausräumen, weil man es wirklich mit einzelnen Gemeinden organisieren könnte. Die Energie müsste also gar nicht mehr an der Staatlichkeit gebunden sein. Das ist ein völliges Fantast.
Du weißt ja, wie diskutiert wird. Also wir lesen diese Bücher dann von Palantir und sagen, das ist gefährlich und alle anderen schweben so leicht rüber und sagen, das ist so klug, da denken noch Leute nach. Also auch hier, ich muss es wirklich mal sagen, also sogenannte Gegenwart, schönes Podcastprojekt von Lars Weißbrot und so. Und die Joma Mangold. Aber die überhöhen sowas auch immer komplett. Also die sind immer total begeistert, dass dann auch jemand nachdenkt, dass die dann eine Philosophie haben und so. Als hätte nicht Daub völlig zurecht dieses Buch, ja was die Denken nennen, so geschrieben. Also es ist, hier muss man in den Text rein. Hier muss man in den Text rein und sagen, das ist alles doof. Und es ist auch wirklich profan und simpel.
Wir sollten ja nochmal gerade den Titel richtig sein, damit das alle wissen.
Technologische, also ja.
Was das Silicon Valley Denken nennt. Wir haben im Salon ausführlich darüber gesprochen. Und genauso muss man es begreifen. Und deine Ansatz war ja genau richtig. Der Milliardär will nicht von irgendwelchen Staaten eins auf den Deckel bekommen und will deswegen so eine Partikularisierung haben.
So eine Pole nur für die Wirtschaft, nicht für die Politik. Da haben wir die kleinen Staaten reif.
Aber so einen Aufwand noch mal so betreibt mit dem Antikristen, oder?
So und jetzt hören wir aber, das ist schon ziemlich pervers.
Wäre eigentlich auch mal ein schöner Einspruch für die Steuererklärung, wenn in der Steuerbescheid kommt, dass man dann schreibt, nein. Also das hier scheint mir eine Tat des Antichristen zu sein. Ich widerspreche.
Ja, genau. Ich sehe hier den Antichristen, der durch Sie spricht. Ich bin dagegen. Bitte stellen Sie erst kleinere Rechnungseinheiten in Ihrem Finanzamt an. So, das war die amerikanische Perversion. Jetzt kommt die deutsche. Wir hören zum einen Wolfram Weimer im Deutschlandfunk-Interview der Woche im Juli.
Aber die Grenzen zum Antisemitismus zu verstecken.
So, Antisemitismus ist natürlich sein Lieblingsding und so. Weil da weiß er unangreifbar, egal was die Leute kritisch über mich schreiben, sobald ich sage, ich kämpfe gegen den Antisemitismus, sind alle Schachmatt, die vor ihm sitzen im Deutschlandfunk in den Tagesthemen und so weiter. Er verschafft sich da aber Freiraum, wo er einfach so vor sich hin plappert. Glaubt unberührbar zu sein. Allerdings muss er nicht, dass wir uns das anhören. Also hören wir uns das mal an.
Wie zum Offenen, die spürt jeder ganz genau. Deswegen ist das in Wahrheit kein Widerspruch. Aber wo genau ist die Ganze?
Formulieren Sie es mal.
Was ist Antisemitismus und was wäre noch von der Kunstfreiheit gedeckt?
Na ja, wenn Greta Thunberg mit einer Krake auftritt und mein altes antisemitisches Motiv.
So, wenn Greta Thunberg mit einer Krake auftritt. Also sie hat dieses Video gemacht, wo dieses Tier, wir sprachen darüber, dass wirklich bei jedem Kind, das ich kenne, unter 10 als Kuscheltier zu Hause ist, weil das einfach so eine kleine Krake ist, die auf der einen Seite lächelt und auf der anderen Seite ein betrübtes Gesicht macht. Und wenn Kinder nicht reden wollen, dann können die Eltern einfach sagen, hier zeig mir die Krake. Das war ja auch schon ausgeräumt.
Selbst die, die ihr das zum Vorwurf gemacht hatten, haben ja schon dann zurückgerudert, als dann klar wurde, nein, es ging jetzt nicht darum zu sagen, Israel ist krakenhaft, sondern es war dort platziert, weil sie dieses Tier immer mit sich herumträgt. Und es hat nichts damit zu tun gehabt. Also dieser Vorwurf war ja einfach ausgeräumt.
Und er hat vor allem nichts in Kunst und Kultur und ich trete auf zu tun.
Ja, es war auch keine Kunstperformance. Sie hat irgendwas da, so ein Statement abgegeben.
Also die Straße des Antisemitismus-Vorwurfs ist für so einen politischen Rennwagen wie Wolfram Weimer einfach sehr breit, sehr lang. Da kann man drüber schlittern, da passiert einem gar nichts.
Das ist Antisemitismus und was wäre noch von der Kunstfreiheit gedeckt?
Na ja, wenn Greta Thunberg mit einer Krake auftritt, um ein altes antisemitisches Motiv aufzugreifen und die Welt verschwört.
Die Krake ist uns auch begegnet, als wir Rockefeller und der Hass auf Rockefeller. Und dann wurde Rockefeller als die Krake, Ölkrake, wegen Tinte und so, die ganze Amerika. Das ist auch......
die Führung des südischen Großkapitals zu anaucieren. Dann bedient sie offene antisemitische Stereotypen. Wissen Sie, die Lage ist so hart geworden, dass wir nicht mehr über diese weichen Grenzen, wo genau ist die Grenze der Kunstfreiheit und das Antisemitismus hinein, der ist so massiv brutal und aggressiv unterwegs, dass wir ihn auch genau adressieren können.
So, also der Antisemitismus ist so hart, brutal und überall unterwegs, dass wir die genaue Grenze, wo jetzt Kunstfreiheit ist, nicht mehr so weich durchgehen lassen dürfen. Also hier sind wir auch ganz nah an so Antichrist oder Armageddern. Ich brauche den möglichst großen Vorschlaghammer. Ich komme hier mit meinem Kulturstaatsbudget und so weiter. Jan Fleischhauer. Ich habe diesen Podcast, in dem wir jetzt reinhören, nicht gehört, sondern wir hören nur die ersten zehn Sekunden. Also wir haben ein Gespräch, das wir alle nicht kennen, ich auch nicht. Aber als Teaser wurden zehn Sekunden ausgewählt, die diesem Gespräch vorangestellt wurden. Kennen wir so mit Musikuntermalt und so. Diese 14 Sekunden hören wir jetzt.
Und Greta Thunberg ist glaube ich nochmal so ein Sonderfall. Die ist einfach nutcase.
Ich glaube, das ist so eine Liebe auch zum starken Mann.
Ich glaube, das ist ein sexueller Fetischer Mann.
Frei Heraus, der A21 Podcast für neue bürgerliche Politik.
Neue bürgerliche Politik.
Genau.
Also bei Wolfram Weimer ist Greta Thunberg Antisemitismus. Da wissen wir, das ist die deutsche Armageddon- oder Antichrist-Diskussion. Bei Jan Fleischhauer ist es die fundamentale sexuelle, reinkörperliche, biologistische Prinzipien, die da vor sich gehen. Da kann man gar nichts, da nützt eine Diskussion einfach nicht. So, das ist ein Fetisch. Da kann sie wahrscheinlich selber nichts dagegen tun. So, die arme Greta. Also Greta scheint hier wirklich bei diesen alten Männern...
Es scheint viel mit denen zu machen, ja.
Es hat die wirklich umgehauen. Da Jan Fleischhauer war hier von... Greta hat jetzt über den Fetisch irgendwas, großer, weißer, alter Mann oder starker Mann. Also, dass ich da so ein, so ein, und das ist ja diese Idee des Antichristen, der dann in der Lage ist, eine Weltgesellschaftung, der Politik herzustellen. Wir hören nur mal hier ganz kurz, es gab ja ein Supreme Court-Urteil in Amerika, das Trump ermöglicht hat, jetzt die ein oder andere Executive Order zu machen, ohne dass noch irgendwelche Richter dann wieder sagen, nee, da hat er irgendwie so overreached, sondern nein, nein, die Gerichte wurden da richtig ausgeschaltet vom Supreme Court. Und da gab es einen Streit zwischen den Supreme Court Justices, weil natürlich wieder die progressive Seite, die machen ja dann so Protokollnotizen oder und da scheint es wohl auch zum richtigen, also nicht nur ich hänge eine Anmerkung noch dran, sondern es gab richtig Wortwechsel. Also es gab so ungewöhnlichen Streit. Und dieses Urteil hat nun genau dazu geführt, dass es plötzlich, aber eben nicht auf Gretas Seite, sondern auf der anderen Seite, so einen starken Mann gibt. Und in welcher Drastik das dann auch bei der New York Times, The Daily, auf die wir auch gleich nochmal zurückkommen, besprochen wird, finde ich mittlerweile wirklich erstaunlich. Denn nochmal der Appell an deutsche Journalisten, wenn ihr mal nicht weiter wisst und denkt, oh krass, ist das wirklich so krass, wie ich jetzt denke? Na, ich traue mich nicht, das aufzuschreiben. Ich halte mal lieber den Ball flach und mach so eine Hypernormalisation aus Verlegenheit. Einfach kurz bei der New York Times nachlesen, wie krass die das formulieren und das dann übersetzen. Dann wäre schon sehr viel geholfen. Also New York Times kann man hier wirklich vorbildhaft nehmen. Hier zum Beispiel. Was bedeuten diese einzelnen Urteile?
So it sounds like Jackson is basically saying, we're in a new legal world here with this ruling. Lots of Americans will have their rights violated by the president. And the only way that they can fight it is if they sue the government, which most people just do not have the time or the resources to do. And they're going to be forced to do that, because these injunctions are no longer here to protect us against executive branch overreach. And so, effectively, with this ruling, all of a sudden, all of us here in the United States would have to become legal combatants, essentially, to protect basic rights enshrined in the Constitution.
Yeah, I mean, her language is just this side of apocalyptic.
Also, apokalyptische Sprache in den Protokollnotizen im Supreme Court. Zum Thema, wie viel Macht wird jetzt Trump zugeschüßt an?
He says the majority's complicity in the creation of a culture of disdain for lower courts, their rulings, and the law will surely hasten the downfall of our governing institutions, enabling our collective demise.
So clearly she's not mincing her words.
Indeed. And Justice Barrett did not appreciate that commentary. And here we saw really a quite unusual thing, where the two most junior members of the court were really going at each other, and in tones that were quite remarkable, Barrett, writing for the majority, says, We will not dwell on Justice Jackson's argument, which is at odds with more than two centuries' worth of precedent, not to mention the Constitution itself. We observe only this. Justice Jackson decries an imperial executive while embracing an imperial judiciary.
Can you just translate that for us, Adam?
Yeah, Barrett is saying that the majority ruling is modest. It wants to stop judges from being activists. It wants to keep everyone in their own lanes.
Also der Supreme Court selbst, wir haben es ja damals gehört, gilt ja dann als in, wer ist die Fernsehserie, die da im Mittelaltersspiel, die alle geguckt haben? Game of Thrones.
Game of Thrones.
Genau, als die Hand of the King, die für den König des Rechtswesen ausschaltet, damit er und die moderne Politik ist eben streng an Recht gebunden, eine neue Macht ausüben kann, die eben jenseits des Rechts und so. Das heißt, das was wir bei Peter Thiel gehört haben und was bei Jan Fleischhauer auf, die haben einen Fetisch auf der Suche nach einem starken Mann, der ihnen irgendwas regelt. Nein, nein, Peter Thiel ist derjenige, der sich den Typ installiert hat am Weißenhaus. Und alle haben die Angst, dass Donald Trump es dann doch mal irgendwie nicht schafft und so. Und dann plötzlich, und das ist dann der Antichrist sozusagen, JD Vans, da die Geschäfte führt. Ungewählt. Quasi auf Ticket da rein. Und vielleicht die zweiten zwei Amtsjahre da irgendwie vollmacht, wo es dann auch schon egal ist, wie die Mehrheiten im Kongress sind, weil man sich schon daran dann nicht mehr hält. Und dieses Phänomen gehen wir jetzt mal konkret durch, denn das hat ja auch Einfluss auf Deutschland. Wenn Amerika kein Rechtsstaat mehr ist im Sinne von, dass politische Macht an Recht zurückgebunden werden muss, sondern man da einfach macht, was man halt will, egal was die Gerichte sagen, dann ist das ja sehr entscheidend, gerade wenn es heißt, es wurde ein Deal gemacht. Weil Deal ist ja immer noch, auch wenn es ein bisschen vulgär klingt, ein Rechtsgefüge. Ja. Also das verweist eigentlich immer noch auf Vertrag und so. Und da hören wir mal zum einen, wie sich Trump einige Starboge geschaffen hat. Es gibt einen sehr langen Clip von Galloway, wo er das auch immer anmittelt, sehr viel KI-Hilfe, aber es ist ja deswegen nur umso fundierter. Durchgeht Mannstärke, Budgetaufgaben, die formuliert werden und so für die geheime Staatspolizei. Und wie das heute bei ICE formuliert wurde. Wir hören sozusagen nur eine kurze Version davon.
It's clear this isn't just an accident.
The American people have not been fooled here. They've decided this is what they want.
They want a certain level of harshness. They want a certain level of cruelty.
They've conflated that with leadership and masculinity.
I think that is what is most frightening and most disappointing here.
Also wir haben es mit, ISIS ist Gestapo und Trump ist Hitler. Und er will auch nicht von abrücken, sondern hier wiederholt sich einfach Geschichte, zumindest und das ist ja das Entscheidende. In dem Ansinnen der Person, also ob es jetzt wirklich dazu kommt, dass Trump mal wie Hitler Konzentrationslager aufbaut, das muss ich zeigen. Aber in dieser psychologischen Dimension, was will er? Hat er ja häufig genug Anmerkungen gemacht zum Thema. Er fand das schon ganz cool, wie das bei Hitler so lief. Und er hätte auch gerne so eine Armee und so eine Parade und der ganze Kram und so. Mark Cuban, einer dieser Milliardäre, der immer so ein bisschen auf das demokratische Spiel mitspielt, geht ja mal in Potsdamerika. Vielleicht haben wir nachher Zeit, noch andere Clips von ihm zu hören, wo er so den Demokraten Ratschläge gibt. Geht mal auf die Frage ein, wie man jetzt Trumps Eisspiel, also diesen Umgang mit so einer Armee, die so durch die Straßen zieht und Leute einsammelt.
Du musst glaube ich ein bisschen erklären für die Leute, die da jetzt noch nicht so drin sind, wie jetzt sich das gestaltet, also wie Trump da jetzt in seiner zweiten Amtszeit durch so eine Armee schafft. Denn es erinnert übrigens ja sehr stark auch an das, was Modi gemacht hat. Wir haben irgendwann mal drüber gesprochen. Der hat ja so eine Zusatzarmee quasi für die schmutzigen Aufgaben, die direkt ihm unterstellt ist.
Also es gibt in Amerika ICE, also ICE, die Immigration Enforcement und so weiter Polizei, die also landesweite Befugnis hat, eine föderale Einrichtung, die wie ansonsten im Film kennt man das so, wenn es FBI oder der Marshall Service irgendwie kommt, die dann auch die lokalen Behörden so ein bisschen übertrumpfen können, im Sinne von wir ziehen jetzt die Ermittlung an uns. So, typischerweise kennt man die nicht, weil die ein sehr enges Aufgabengebiet hat, nämlich Immigration Enforcement. So, jetzt gab es diesen Big Beautiful Bill, in dem einfach drinsteht, 2028 geht 80% allen Law Enforcement Budgets in ICE. Und die letzten 20% sind dann für FBI, Marshall Service und so weiter. Secret Service.
Also durch Finanzmittel entmachtet werden die einen, die anderen gestärkt.
Und die haben auch zig Milliarden, also zum Beispiel so 43 Milliarden in der Höhe für diese Camps, die sie jetzt bauen, wie das allererste Alligator Elcatraz. Und die dürfen aber die Mittel selbst hin und her schieben. Also ICE kriegt sowieso schon mal 50 Milliarden pro Jahr und dann nochmal 40 Milliarden für diesen Gefängnisbau. Und wenn sie aber mehr für sich brauchen oder mehr für den Gefängnisbau, können die selbst noch hin und her schieben. Also die haben einfach überbordend viel Geld jetzt einfach bekommen und dann frei verwalten. Was eben bedeutet, und sie unterstehen direkt den Präsidenten, ICE ist jetzt wie eine Privatarmee von Donald Trump anzusehen, da wir vom Supreme Court gehört haben, der Präsident ist immer im Amt, egal welche Befehle er gibt. So, und diese Clips hier laufen darauf hinaus, was für Befehle werden das denn und wie kriegt man das denn, wenn man dann beispielsweise in Kalifornien ist, wo ja der Gouverneur auch noch eine Handhabe über Polizei hat. Also der Bürgermeister über die LA. Police Department und der Gouverneur dann über, eigentlich wenn nicht der Präsident Notfallrechte dafür sich in Anspruch nimmt über die National Guard und so weiter. Es gibt auch Landespolizei. Und irgendwann wird es Konflikte geben. Also da werden die sich bewaffnet gegenüberstehen und die einen sagen wir haben ein Befehl des Präsidenten und der andere sagt wir haben ein Befehl des Bürgermeisters und die sind aber konträr. Also die gehen nicht auf. Und das möchte Trump wahrscheinlich forcieren. Und zwar über einen Weg, der wirklich abenteuerlich ist. Und den muss man hier in Deutschland auch wahrnehmen. Vorher aber nochmal, finde ich dann, wie wir haben jetzt von Scott Galloway gehört, das ist, also Trump agiert hier wie Hitler und stellt sich eine private Armee auf wie die Gestapo. Mark Cuban, weiß nicht, ich will es nur als Kontrast spielen, will man mal hören, wie sie nicht alle so ernst nehmen.
But the Democrats aren't responding in a way that has a visceral impact. What would that look like? So what that looks like is showing the families of every single person who's not a criminal has been deported. Instead, we had the one guy from Maryland. One guy from Maryland.
So, diesen one guy von Maryland, also Ambel Garcia, der Vorname lautet, na, komme ich näher drauf, der illegal abgeschoben wurde und mittlerweile wieder in Amerika zurück ist und wo ganz lange diskutiert wurde, ob er jetzt so ein Gangmember ist oder wie auch immer.
Is big the first week, but when there's just a nonstop progression and we see the videos of people getting pulled off the streets, it's horrific. Every single one of those families should be in front of a camera and we should be working to say, what's going on? They should be putting Tom Homan on blast saying, okay, the FBI has their top 10 most wanted list, right? Let's just get this right. Homan, don't, you know, do it right. List the top 100. Let's go after them. List the top 1000, you know, criminals that are here that need to be deported. We'll all help you. But the Democrats would never say something to the effect, we'll help you. They only have to do something that's the antithesis of what Trump says and does. You've never heard a Democrat say in the past seven months, yeah, okay, I don't like it, but this is a step in the right direction. We're going to help, because I think the better path is for the Democrats to bring attention to the bad things and the good things and say on the good things, we'll help you.
Ja, also Mark Cuban wünscht sich jetzt, dass die Demokraten einfach sagen, Ja, das sind zwar 90 Prozent, die so ein bisschen illegalerweise da festgehalten werden, wie auch immer. Gibt ja auch erste Theorien dazu, dass man den Niedriglohnsektor da rausholt, ins Gefängnis packt und denen dann sagt, ihr könnt ja übrigens einen Dollar am Tag verdienen, wenn ihr die Arbeit wieder macht, die ihr vorher gemacht habt. Also echt das Sklavenhandel wieder. Und er meint, ja, es ist zwar blöd, dass die so viele illegal, aber dass sie durch die Straßen ziehen, ist erstmal okay und die Leute finden sie auch gut. Und dann soll man halt sagen, nee, da habt ihr die Grenze überschritten, sucht doch mal diese. Und dann sollen die Demokraten noch die 1000 gefährlichsten Immigranten aussuchen, die dann Eis jagen sollen oder so. Also das ist der amerikanische Diskurs, der so ein bisschen in die falsche Richtung geht.
Naja, das, was wir hier ja auch immer wieder erleben, dass man dann sagt, ja, aber das ist sicherlich jetzt hart formuliert von Carsten Lindemann. Aber ihr müsst jetzt auch schon mal da mitarbeiten, dass wir die Illegalen hier auch zu fassen bekommen. Also das sind ja die Anforderungen, die dann gestellt werden und denen dann die Grünen oder die Sozialdemokraten gern nachkommen.
Naja, also dieses Maß für wohltemperierte Grausamkeit, wie Hörke das gefordert hat, das kann man schon mal auf 80 Grad drehen, wo wir vorher dachten, nee, das ist doch zu viel oder es ist zu warm, aber ne, da kann man Migrationspolitik immer recht weit drehen. So, bevor wir jetzt zu diesem Punkt kommen, auf den ich hinaus will, ein Clip noch von Taylor Lawrence. Sie hatte Jason Köppler zur Gast von 404 Media. Also 404 Media, sehr gutes Ding. Da wird das, was Taylor Lawrence gemacht, noch so ein bisschen politisch dringlicher und damit auch ein bisschen unattraktiver eigentlich dargestellt, aber sehr wichtig. Und wir kommen jetzt auf nochmal Coldplay zu sprechen. Denn es gibt ja diese technische Dimension. Die Leute machen diese Kisscam und da stehen 80.000 Leute oder so in dem Stadion und sehen dann, okay, die haben sich komisch verhalten. Angenommen, der Typ hätte sich jetzt nicht komisch verhalten. Sondern hätte dir ans Ohr geflüstert, bleib so stehen, bleib so stehen, mach nichts Auffälliges, in fünf Sekunden ist vorbei. Ja. Hätte das jemand außerhalb des Stadions als Story geteilt und hätten das dann Leute gesehen, oder wäre das sofort wieder weggespült worden? Aber, und das Problem hat ICE ja auch, man sieht so jemanden auf dem Bildschirm und fragt sich, wer ist denn das? Also gibt es Gesichtserkennung, und es gibt ja auch die Videos von ICE, wie sie so, bevor sie Fensterscheiben zerschlagen, schon mal mit dem Handy so durchfilmen. Und dann einfach das Gesicht sich einmal geben lassen, aus dem Computer. Und dieser Jason Köppler schreibt also sehr viel über dieses Gesichtserkennungszeug. Wir hatten das ja auch schon vor ein paar Jahren. Und er kann ja aus seiner publizistischen Geschichte mal erzählen, wie das war, als diese Coldplay-Story kam, die das bei ihrem 404 Media auch gemacht haben, und damit sein Text verdrängt wurde. Und er sagt jetzt mal die Faktoren der Attraktivität der Themen.
And then, with the rise of PIMEyes and Clearview and these other new facial recognition databases, cops buy access to these databases. And from their phone, they can point their phone at you and say like, hey, who is this? And look you up. And we have just done reporting where ICE has a brand new app that does exactly this. And the databases that it's tied to are like, the databases that, like when you enter the country, they're tied to like airline databases, because increasingly you board planes without using a boarding pass, you just use your face or you can go through TSA without giving them your ID, you just give them your face. And so these tools are getting like really, really powerful. And I do think that people are concerned about it in an ICE context or in a DHS type context.
But these things are like very serious and very boring to a lot of people. We literally published my article about Astronomer and the article about ICE's new technology on the same day. And I think 40 times more people read about the Astronomer CEO.
Also selbst bei deren Medienangebot, wo man wirklich hingeht, um die Sachen, was ICE jetzt mit der Gesichtserkennung macht, zu erfahren, wird der Text über, da war was beim Holdplay-Konzert, 40-mal häufiger angeklickt. Als, ja, du wirst einfach überall erkannt, wenn du irgendwas machst. Und du musst nicht mal was falsch machen. Also, du musst nur dein Gesicht zeigen. So, die New York Times hat einen spektakulären Podcast gemacht in ihrem The Daily. Das ist ja immer noch der reichweitenstärkste, wenn überhaupt zumindest in dem Nachrichtensegment ist. Also, ich finde, ich weiß nicht genau, warum es nicht wirklich eine Spiegelrubrik gibt, wo man das einfach mal abschreibt, was da so drin vorkommt. Aber wirklich sehr bezeichnend.
Gut, dass wir ja doch derbes eingeständen sind.
Ja, aber zurecht halt. Da würde ich sagen, kann man mal Spiegel lesen. Es gab einen Whistleblower aus dem State Department, der hier im Gespräch vorgestellt wird.
You were doing your job. You worked within the confines of what was legal. And that is what matters.
Yeah, that's right. I mean, the Trump administration promoted me and gave me three awards, if I recall correctly, during the first Trump administration for work I've done defending the very policies we're just talking about now, including the travel ban. So, I'm there to do my job as a government attorney. I may not personally agree or disagree with everything I'm defending, regardless of who's the president, but the job is to defend vigorously the administration's goals within the confines of the law.
So, wir haben also hier einen Beamten, der aus Leidenschaft zum State Department geht und sagt, ich verzichte auf einiges Geld und wie so immer, die amerikanische Geschichte, ich möchte für den Staat, für die Allgemeinheit arbeiten. Then comes Trump 2017 ins Amt und er wird der führende Beamte, der diesen Muslim banned, im Sinne von keine Muslime reisen mehr nach Amerika. Aller Europäer so, geht das so, was ist denn das für eine komische Idee? Also, ist ja völlig bescheuert. Und er war damals der führende Beamte, der das im State Department für Trump organisiert hat und dann noch drei Auszeichnungen dafür bekam. Also, wir haben schon jemanden, der sehr auf der Seite stand. Genau. Und der jetzt aber sagt, Sorry, aber das ging ja grad so weit, was hier als abläuft. Denn es gab jetzt neue politische Befehle, wie mit Gerichtsentscheidungen umzugangen ist. Und da wird jetzt dieser, wie heißt der denn? Garcia Vorname, ach ja, Abrego Garcia. Also der zwischenzeitlich da zu schnell abgeschoben wurde, bevor Sachen geklärt werden konnten.
Bovi, who again is leading the meeting, tells everyone in attendance that this invocation of the Alien Enemies Act to remove certain Venezuelan nationals is of the highest importance to the White House.
So, also das Weiße Haus macht ein Gesetz und sagt, abschieben, egal was kommt, das ist hier sehr wichtig. Also die werden richtig indoctriniert auf, das Weiße Haus hat hier gesagt, das ist jetzt von, also dieses ganze Stephen-Miller-Politik wird jetzt umgesetzt.
And after a pause, emphasizing to everyone again in the room, those planes have to take off, quote, no matter what. And then there's another pause there. And then this is the thing that sets the tone for the next three weeks. Bovi says, and if some court or to issue some order that prevents that from happening, we would have to consider telling that court, quote, fuck you.
Ja, dann gibt's eine Rückfrage von den Beamten, nachdem sie die Ansage vom Weißen Haus vermittelt bekommen haben. Ja, und was ist, wenn Gerichte sagen, dieser Apfelschiebeflug darf jetzt nicht starten, hier sind ungeklärte Sachen, dann gibt's eine fuck you an die Gerichteansage, also die soll durchgesetzt werden.
Ich meine, wir sind ja in Deutschland noch nicht so weit, dass wir dann fuck you sagen, aber wir haben ja auch schon darüber gesprochen, dass wir jetzt solche Rechtsunsicherheiten haben, bei denen man eigentlich weiß, das wird von Karlsruhe irgendwann wieder gebremst oder völlig untersagt, aber man führt das weiter aus, hofft darauf, dass nicht allzu viele Widerspruch einlegen und so kommt dann Dopin mit seiner Masche durch. Also was ich mich jetzt frage ist, bei all diesen Reden über Trump und jetzt nicht nur hier, sondern in den vielen Podcasts, die wir hören, wir haben Trump immer natürlich als eine besonders extreme Ausprägung dargestellt und das ist auch richtig, aber er ist ja schon auch eine Ausprägung dessen, was ohnehin der Fall ist. Und deshalb erleben wir ja immer mehr genau in diese Richtung gehend. Also und wir haben das ja auch im deutschen Diskurs ganz stark, wenn ich das gerade mal einfügen darf. Wir haben die ganze Zeit diese Warnung davor, es ist fünf vor Faschismus. Denn es könnte sein, dass die AfD 2029 mitregiert. Dann nicht mehr als Junior-Partner auch vielleicht, sondern wirklich den Kanzler stellt. Kanzler Alice, Max, wer auch immer. Ich glaube, es wäre ratsam, und das ist jetzt so ein Gedankenexperiment von mir. Ich glaube, es wäre ratsam, wenn wir uns jetzt einfach mal damit abfinden, womit ich jetzt nicht sagen will, ihr braucht nicht mehr weiter kämpfen oder so, sondern ich will einfach mal den Gedanken zulassen, zu sagen, 2029 wird auf jeden Fall die AfD mitregieren. Es wird dann eine schwarz-blaue Koalition oder blau-schwarze Koalition geben. Also wir können uns jetzt nicht mehr die Frage stellen, was tun wir, um das zu verhindern, dann sollen wir sagen, ja, das ist also schon geschehen. Wir machen jetzt das Tenet-Szenario, die Zukunft ist bereits eingetroffen und sie rast auf uns jetzt zu. Was bedeutet das dann eigentlich für die Politik jetzt? Denn was wir jetzt gerade machen, ist die ganze Zeit zu sagen, ah, die AfD, die macht dies und das und wir sind nicht die AfD. Aber wir machen ja die ganze Zeit, das haben wir hier schon häufiger betont, AfD-Politik. Und wenn ich sehe, dass man dabei ist, nicht nur eine Militarisierung der Zivilgesellschaft zu betreiben, Wehrpflicht einzufordern, aber die Überwachung auszuweiten. Man plötzlich alles als vielleicht antisemitisch deklariert, was einem in der Kunst nicht passt. Wenn man bereit ist, Shad-Kontrollen einzuführen. Wir haben über Trusted Flagger hier schon geredet. Wenn selbst die Grünen noch mal nachverhandeln bei diesem Deal mit dem Schuldenpaket, dass die Geheimdienste stärker ausgestattet werden. Wenn wir also diese ganzen repressive Maßnahmen sehen, wir Außengrenzen kontrollieren, Abschiebeflüge jetzt von der bürgerlichen Presse, und ich rede hier nicht nur von der Bildzeitung, beklatscht werden. Wenn wir ganz viele Rechtsbrüche schon wissen, die werden nur nicht geahndet, weil man sagt, wir machen erst mal so weiter, dann wäre doch viel klarer mal zu sagen, also wir können doch jetzt nicht nur darüber reden, wie verhindern wir 2029, sondern müssten eigentlich sagen, ja 2029, das kommt eh, aber was müssen wir eigentlich jetzt gerade angehen, damit dieser autoritäre Politikstil endet, und nicht nur der Stil, sondern wirklich diese autoritäre Politik. Denn wir machen jetzt, ich freue mich, wünsche. Nein, aber ich halte es für verlogen. Und das werfe ich eben auch denen vor, die die ganze Zeit nur vor Faschismus sagen. Und jetzt die AfD. Und dann wird alles ganz anders. Nee, es ist bereits ganz anders. Ohne, dass die AfD regiert. Und ich will damit nicht die AfD normalisieren. Aber in gewisser Weise sollte man sie in der Hinsicht normalisieren, dass man sagt, ja, wenn die kommen, die machen auch nicht von 0 auf 100 Faschismus in dem Sinne, dass dann alles hier abgeräumt wird und morgen wieder KZs errichtet werden. Das ist nicht zu erwarten. Sondern die werden das, was jetzt hier schon geschehen ist, dann weiter in diese Richtung fortsetzen. Und dadurch, dass sich eh alles in diese Richtung entwickelt hat, wird man es auch als normal ansehen. Und so eben wie die Äußerung, die du da vorgesehen hast, ja, vielleicht können die Demokraten da sich auch mal noch ein bisschen einbringen in die Sache. Ja, dann wird man auch noch einfordern, dass man sich konstruktiv mit der AfD ins Benehmen setzt, um dies und das umzusetzen. Weil man es bereits jetzt schon macht. Also ich halte es für viel besser, schon mal festzuhalten, die autoritäre Wende ist bereits vollzogen. Und dann kommt die AfD. Aber nicht zu sagen, die AfD kommt und dann ist Autoritarismus. Ich halte das für vollkommen falsch, für die falsche Strategie sowieso. Und vor allem, weil dann alles, was jetzt passiert, immer okay ist, weil es ja nicht die AfD tut.
Also ich habe ja nachher noch einen Blog zum Thema Paradoxie, Wirtschaft und Migrationspolitik. Wie passt das eigentlich zusammen? Antwort ist gar nicht. Denn in dem Maße, wie du Migrationspolitik machst, die die AfD will, sorgst du ja für einen wirtschaftlichen Einbruch, der danach die AfD befördert. Und wenn sie dann ins Amt kommt, findet sie eine Migrationspolitik vor. Bei der sie einfach sagen muss, seht ihr, also wir machen hier gar nichts Krasses. Wir regieren einfach nur weiter. So wie vorher das vorbereitet wurde. Das ist ja, so wie Lindemann und Dobrindt das immer sagen, wir müssen die ja bekämpfen, indem wir ihre Politik machen. Und wir hören nachher, wie Robin Alexander uns das erklärt. Seid mal gespannt. So, jetzt sind wir aber noch bei unserem Thema Gerichtsentscheidung zu ignorieren. Also da, wo die Amerikaner wirklich schon mal einen Punkt weiter sind. Dieser Befehl der Beamten, also es gibt diese FAQ-Doktrin, und man wird da schon auf Nachfrage hin, und was ist, wenn dann die Gerichte sagen, dann gibt's schon die Ansage, ja, ja, dann ist einfach, das wird dann ignoriert.
What were you thinking in that moment when he said that?
I felt like a grenade had gone off. Like, is he serious? It wasn't clear to me if it was just acting or bravado chest dumping. Like, it was crazy. And after a very long pause, my immediate supervisor says, well, if we get an order, we would advise our clients to follow the order.
So, also die Order aus dem Weißen Haus ist wichtiger als das Gerichtsurteil, dass ich auf diese Order bezieht und sei es durch Aussetzen oder wie auch immer. Das bedeutet jetzt praktische Politik, zum Beispiel im Gerichtssaal, wenn Sachen verhandelt werden. Also innerhalb dieser drei Wochen, wo es ihm dämmerte, okay, das geht ja nicht mehr so richtig weiter, hat er eine Erfahrung gemacht im Gerichtssaal.
I know that we're going to be spending our weekend defending this Alien Enemies Act operation, and we're going to be in court on Saturday. And there was a hearing set for 4 p.m. later that day, that hearing got moved to five, and then we appeared at that hearing. And by we, I mean Drew Ensign. Drew Ensign handled the argument for the government. And now, just to sidebar here for a second, Ensign was at the same meeting I was at, and he heard the same things that I heard from Mr. Bovey, including that planes are taking off over the weekend and that they need to take off no matter what, and this is the highest priority of the White House. So Boesberg asks him, are there any planes taking off? And he says, I don't know. I believe that to not be a plausible answer from someone in Mr. Ensign's position, since he was at the same meeting as me.
You think he lied?
I believe he lied. I don't see how he could have come away from that meeting with the impression that no planes were taking off over the next 24 to 48 hours. And that's sort of the first operationalization, if you will, of the FU. So here we have the political head of the immigration section telling the court, I don't know.
What was your reaction when you heard your colleague, as you put it, lying to a judge?
Oh shit, how can he say that? That's just not true.
Also, vor Gericht wird ein Abschüberflieger verhandelt. Und dann wird der Regierungsvertreter gefragt, wann gehen die denn? Und dann sagt er, weiß ich nicht. Obwohl er genau weiß, dass die gerade auf dem Rollfeld stehen. Und wenn das in diesem Metier gilt, gilt das für die amerikanische Regierung auf allen Feldern. Also, die ganze Idee von der größte Deal ever, weil Europa irgendein Zugeständnis gemacht hat. Und dann kommt so eine politische Diskussionsrunde auf und sagt, ob diese Investitionen wirklich stattfinden und so. Da sickert schon was ein. Ich meine, es hat jetzt auch niemand ein Vertragswerk gesehen, sondern die saßen halt einfach da und haben von einem Deal gesprochen und weiß noch gar nicht, ob der überhaupt unterzeichnet ist oder ob der noch ausformuliert werden muss und so weiter und so fort. Also, diese Art von Gesetze, Verträge, whatever. Wir sagen einfach, der Präsident sagt etwas und das ist dann Gesetz. Egal was vorher, nachher oder mit irgendwelchen Vertragswerken passiert. Das ist die neue Realität in Amerika und das gilt vor allem.
Die man ja auch nachlesen kann. Ich meine, wir beide haben The Art of the Deal gelesen.
Ich hab das nicht gelesen.
Das Trump Buch, also aus den 80ern, in denen er erzählt, wie er seine Deal sein will. Und das ist wirklich kein interessantes Buch. Aber was hier bemerkenswert ist, ist, dass er ja eigentlich sein ganzes Agieren so beschreibt. Also es ist, da war ein tough guy, mit dem hat er gesprochen, dann haben wir das so und so gemacht. Er erzählt, dass er sich lieber mit dem Taxifahrer fünfmal unterhält, als einmal so eine teure Consulting-Agentur zu beauftragen. Also alles, wo das institutionelle ist, da sind eher seine Feinde. Da muss er auch die Anwälte losschicken oder so. Dann kämpft er das auch durch mit den Steuern und und und. Ja, aber sonst sagt er immer, ja, ich habe das jetzt hier auf meine Weise geklärt und da sind ganz kurze Entscheidungen. Das ist am Ende das, was zählt. Und es geht eigentlich schildert er das Ganze so, weil das sind ja, ich meine, Immobilien, das ist wirklich ein sehr papierlastiges Thema. Übischerweise. Mir erzählte kürzlich ein Architekt, dass er eine Wohnung angemietet hat, um dort seine Ordner zu lagern, die sich dort, na ja, du musst zehn Jahre aufheben. Du hast viele Bauprojekte, dann hast du 750 Ordner, die müssen irgendwo hin. Also es ist sehr papierlastig. Also eigentlich ist das alles genau das nicht, was hier beschrieben wird. Und Donald Trump beschreibt aber diese ganze Immobilienwelt so, wie als würden wir uns heute Abend zum Bier verabreden. Und das ist das Interessante an diesem Buch, das ist immer so um Intuition und da, dies und das, dass es aber eigentlich ja diese Prozesse, die gestaltet werden müssen. Das ist so was bei Trump, wo er es einfach ausklammert. Und ich glaube, er versucht, eine Politik zu machen. Wo er sagt, ja, und den Papierkram, da soll sich dann irgendjemand noch drum kümmern. Also zum Beispiel bei einem Tolldeal. Oder jetzt auch bei diesen rechtlichen Fragen, welche Abschiebungen gehen eigentlich. Er will mit einem Telefonat, er sagt dann auch immer, also für ihn ist das wichtig, Telefonate führen. Das macht er ja da schon diesem Art of the Deal ganz klar. Und da will er eigentlich alles geregelt haben. Aber Telefonate sind ja wirklich nur zu zweit. Und vielleicht schreibt dann noch die Sekretärin mit oder so. Aber eigentlich ist alles, was mit Papier zu tun hat, kommt bei ihm gar nicht vor.
Das ist ja eigentlich witzig, dass er jetzt mit Putin so ein Gegenspieler hat, bei dem er dann feststellt, ja, der hält sich ja gar nicht an die Absprachen, die wir so mündlich getroffen haben.
Und das will er natürlich. Also er will jemand und wenn er jemandem vertrauen kann, wenn er mit jemandem befreundet ist, dann ist er auch ein Freund.
Er schreibt das halt nicht auf Papier, sondern direkt in unsere Augen. Also das muss einfach größtmögliches Mediengeschehen um Sachen geben, damit er sich dann nach drauf berufen kann. Wir haben doch den größten Deal aller Zeiten gemacht, Ursula, wo sind denn meine Energie-Importe und so, Export.
Und er ist beeindruckt, das kann man ja auch nochmal in die Art of the Deal sehen, wenn irgendjemand unglaublich forsch auftreten kann. Er beschreibt dann einen kleinen, dicken Mann, der für ihn die Mieten eintreibt und der hätte ein seuchloses Mundwerk, dass man sich das gar nicht vorstellen könne und dass er selbst einen zwei Meter großen Mann in die Flucht schlagen kann mit seinem Mundwerk. Das ist für ihn beeindruckend.
Ja, da war ja auch von Prinz Pilz, der jetzt König der Niederlande ist, sehr beeindruckt, als er vor Ort war.
Genau, und das ist aber auch wieder dieses Mundwerk zu loben. Alles, was außerhalb irgendeines rechtlichen Rahmens oder irgendwas ist, man trumpft auf, man schlägt so den Feind in die Flucht oder nimmt auf diese Weise die Migranten in Haft und das war's.
Ja, man regelt das Überzeugen schafft. Es waren doch alle dabei. Es gilt. So, was jetzt hier bedeutet bei ICE, die Beamten müssen einfach im Dungeln gelassen werden.
And that weekend, after this injunction issued, another flight took off, depositing 17 more individuals in Salvadoran custody at Seacock.
And you think, just to be clear here, you think that ICE was deliberately kept in the dark so that those flights could take off? So that they didn't know that they weren't supposed to do that?
100%. And this also allows someone who's a decision maker to stick their head in the sand and say, la, la, la, I don't know what's happening here. And so I didn't violate an order. I didn't know about it.
Also, das Modell muss man jetzt beobachten in Deutschland, die möglichst große Ansage von Trump, was jetzt politisch zu geschehen hat, und das an den Rand drängen, einfach nur in der medialen Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie von Gerichtsurteilen. Soweit, dass die Eisbeamten, typischerweise kriegen die das ja schriftlich und so, gar nicht im Bilde sind, was irgendwelche Gerichte entschieden haben. Allein weil dieser Trump-Befehl und die Ansagen alles so überladen, dass das einfach aufmerksamkeitsmäßig gar nicht verrechnet werden kann. So, und jetzt wird ja die ganze Zeit verhandelt hier, dieser Fall von Abrego Garcia. Also er saß in dem Flugzeug, als der Richter fragte, also finden grad Abschiebelflüge statt? Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Und er war dann schon in El Salvador als die Gerichtsanhörung, nur die Anhörung. Die Verhandlung kam ja später dann überhaupt zu Potte Calm. So, und jetzt hat man ja diesen Sonderfall, dass im Nachhinein mediale Aufmerksamkeit darauf gelegt wurde, dass er ja gar kein MSI oder wie er heißen Gangmember ist. Und jetzt sollte er nachträglich die juristische, also den Papierkrieg, der plötzlich notwendig wurde, den sollte er dann regeln.
So, I immediately raise red flags. And they take out the argument. And they move it to a different section of the...
Also, die haben ihm eine Beschlussvorlage gegeben, die er unterschreiben sollte, die er gar nicht erarbeitet hat, wo dann einfach drin stand, ja, er ist MSI Gang Member. Und er so, ne, das kann ich nicht unterschreiben. So, also haben die gesagt, ja, okay, wir schicken dir eine neue Version. Da stand es dann nicht mehr auf Seite 3, sondern auf Seite 19, aber der gleiche Wortlaut.
Brief. As though I wouldn't notice. And they're still making the argument just in a different...
Like just copy and pasting.
Yeah, they just moved it elsewhere to come in a different order in the brief. And I'm like, guys, no, this is still not true. This is still a lie. I can't sign this. And this leads to this sort of dramatic last minute, late in the night conversation I had a conversation with my immediate supervisor. It's about 1:30 a.m., we're talking. It's an uncomfortable conversation because we both understand in some way in our minds that if I don't sign this brief, it's unclear that I'm employed next Monday. Really? He's thinking of it as, don't do this, this is not worth it, this is not the hill to die on. He's also thinking of it as he can't lose a senior litigator like myself, given all the crazy in this period of time. So he says to me, you signed up to do this, you asked for this job, this is the job, something to that effect. And that's when I say, I didn't sign up to lie. And that's the end of the conversation. He then files the brief with the information that I objected to. He signs it. And then the following day, around 10, 12 in the morning, I get an email that I've been put on administrative leave for failure to follow an order, failure to advocate on behalf of my clients, and once that letter was sent to me, it was pretty clear that that second letter actually firing me was coming.
So, er wurde also gefeuert und macht jetzt im Nachhinein diese Aufklärung über diesen Whistleblower Anspruch, den er da sich gibt, und in the New York Times kam er auf ihn zu. Und jetzt gibt es ja große Bemühungen, dass andere nicht gleich so handeln wie er. So, und er beschreibt jetzt nochmal, wie die Bedrohungslage über, er wird einfach aus dem Staatsdienst entlassen, hinaus reicht. Und jetzt hat man so einen interessanten Reentry von allem, was wir jetzt beschrieben haben. Denn da arbeitet jemand nach Recht und Ordnung für jemand, der schon nach Recht und Ordnung illegal abgeschoben wurde und dem nachträglich so eine Gangmemberschaft unterstellt wurde. So, und der landet da also auf irgendwelchen Listen, von denen John Oliver auch schon mal so aufgezeigt hat, wie das so geht mit diesen Gangmember-Listen. Also im Grunde, wenn du im falschen Chat schreibst, kill it. Und du meintest im Grunde nur, ich wollte in meinem Klassenkameraden schreiben, dass die Prüfung gut gelaufen ist. Dann ist das schon ein Ohr, ein Schwarz hat in einem Chat killen geschrieben. Also sofort auf so eine Liste. Und es gibt wohl Städte, wo 3000 Leute auf so einer Liste stehen und darunter ein Weißer und so. Also krasser Rassismus einprogrammiert. Diese Listenführung, auf die außer die Polizei, die die Listen schreibt und führt, auch niemand Einblick hat. Also, wenn man auf so einer Liste steht, ist man plötzlich, die halten mich immer an, was ist denn los, also mein Kennzeichen, wie auch immer und so. Aber niemand hat da Zugriff. Auch die Anwälte können da nicht nachfragen. Also, diese Listenführung ist schon mal ganz scheiße. Und jetzt droht ihm selbst auch so eine Listung.
The next big step that you take, of course, is filing this whistleblower report. And a lot of people might be aware that being a whistleblower comes with certain legal protections. It's an actual classification. But there are, of course, risks. Can you talk a little bit about how you were assessing the risks of filing this report when you did it?
I mean, I felt it very important for me to tell my story through the proper whistleblower channels, given what is happening to DOJ. So, yeah, the risks, sure. I'm not naive that I've put a target on me. And that sucks. But this story, what's happened to DOJ, what they're doing to career civil service is so important to me that I think the risks are worth it.
But what are you afraid of?
Well, I'll give you an example. I was watching some news coverage about Abrego-Garcia, and a certain Trump administration talking head gets on the TV and floats the following possibility. Anyone supporting Mr. Abrego-Garcia is aiding and abetting terrorism. And that sent me to a dark place, because it's not hard to connect the dots there on maybe, you know, maybe they come after people like me on trumped up charges.
Ja, also er steht jetzt selbst auf einer Liste für Terrorunterstützung. Weil er hat ja Garcia geholfen. Da selber damit nichts zu tun hat. Also das ist die neue Entkopplung von politischer Macht und rechtlicher Norm.
Nee, das sind unsere Wertepartner.
Das sind unsere Wertepartner. Und das gilt halt wirklich nicht nur, also diese Art von Donald Trump hat eine Doktrin. Das gilt ja einfach überall. Das betrumpft dort einfach Rechtssetzungen.
Naja, aber schau doch...
Gesegnet vom Supreme Court.
Schau doch die Reaktionen an. Es war bei der ersten Amtszeit doch wahnsinnig viel Widerstand, da Trump in irgendeiner Weise zu normalisieren. Jetzt aber ist das ja vollkommen aufgehoben. Wir haben das schon hier beobachtet, diesen ganzen Zirkus der NATO-Mitgliedsländer, wie sie um Donald Trump buden, ihm alle möglichen Liebesbriefe schreiben. Wir sehen auch, wie wenig taff die EU auftritt, auch wenn das jetzt mit den Zöllen dann nicht so dramatisch wohl erst einmal werden wird. Man wird sehen, ich spreche es hier aus, vielleicht ist morgen schon wieder alles anders. Das können wir alles ja nicht mehr sagen. Und wir merken aber auch, dass gerade, was diese Einschränkung von Meinungsfreiheit, was die Torpedierung von Migrationsrechten und so etwas anbelangt, ja etwas ist, was wir in europäischen Ländern auch stark beobachten können, in Deutschland. Aber wir haben ja auch mit Meloni plötzlich eine Politikerin, die als beliebte Politikerin europaweit dargestellt wird, von bürgerlichen Medien. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass wir das jetzt nur noch am rechten Rand finden. Und deswegen habe ich eigentlich den Eindruck, dass tatsächlich die transatlantische Partnerschaft verfestigt wird, aber noch mal in einer anderen Weise als jetzt nur über so eine militärische Kooperation, sondern dass das jetzt tatsächlich, deswegen sagte ich eben ironisch, Wertegemeinschaft meint es aber eigentlich ernst, die neue Wertegemeinschaft ist, dass man das jetzt so macht. Und hier in Europa hat man sich natürlich durch Verfassungen, Verfassungsgerichte sehr noch gebunden, dass man das jetzt noch gar nicht so aufheben kann. Du sagst immer, die sind noch contained. Deshalb ist das noch hier in einer anderen Modus. Aber eigentlich erleben wir eine ziemliche Annäherung, so dass der Westen hier nicht plötzlich zerbricht. Das war so ein bisschen erst bei der Amtszeit Nummer eins bei Trump. Da hat man so gedacht, das ist jetzt die andere Welt. Und als Biden dann zurückkam, sagte Osloff von der Leyen, America is back. Und jetzt hat man jetzt wieder so eine alte Verbindung hergestellt. Und ich glaube jetzt gibt es wieder eine Verbindung, die sehr stark ist. Aber dafür muss man sich dann entsprechend anpassen. Und wir sehen ja, wie die Kritik dann auch leiser wird an so etwas. Oder dass man dann auch bereit ist, bei solchen Vorgängen, wo man ja immer gesagt hat, ja, die Chinesen überwachen alles mit Gesichtscams und versuchen dann Leute, die Delinquents sind, da rauszufischen. Jetzt findet das in den USA statt, ist schon irgendwie normal. Können wir diese Unternehmen auch mal kennenlernen? Vielleicht wäre das auch was, um unsere Flughäfen und Bahnhöfe sicherer zu machen.
Total. Also da darf man auch. Es gibt eine Parallele zur Alten Republik. Wenn ich dann eingeladen werde zur Amtveranstaltung, sind das immer diese urbanen Zentren. Und dann ist immer der Einstiegs-Joke, wir reden heute über die Alten Republik. Also wir sind gerade in keiner. Weder Frankfurt noch Hamburg noch Berlin noch München noch Düsseldorf. So, aber es gibt nur 80 Großstädte in Deutschland, in denen leben aber nur ein Drittel der Leute. Das heißt zwei Drittel der Leute leben irgendwo in einem Umland. Also die haben vielleicht Wochenends mal Kontakt zu einem urbanen Zentrum, aber typischerweise leben die so in ihrem eigenen Gefilde. Da gilt schon vieles von dem Denken, über das wir uns hier ganz selbstverständlich aufregen als, wie sagen die denn da jetzt was dagegen so ungefähr. Also in der Ansicht, falls ihr diesen Podcast hört, noch mal kurz reflektieren, ihr lauft wahrscheinlich gerade durch Münster. A bicycle and a student city, die wirklich nichts mit Europa gemein hat, so in der Fläche, sondern das ist einfach wie die Rückseite des Mondes, so wie Frankfurt. Koblenz in Abstrichen bestimmt auch noch. Da geht es aber bestimmt auch schon anders zu als in so urban Zentren. Also das, was wir hier in Amerika besprechen, das droht uns auf jeden Fall. Wäre ein Wunder, wenn sowas hier nicht passiert. Und der Einflugschneiser ist eben erstmal die Duldung. In Amerika ist das halt jetzt so. Machen wir trotzdem den größten Deal aller Zeiten.
Die Literatur stirbt. Die englische Literatur, über die wird hier gesprochen, aber das gilt natürlich auch für die deutschsprachige Literatur und wohl auch für die Literaturwissenschaften. Es gibt den Podcast von The New Statesman und dort unterhält man sich über das Sterben der englischen Literatur. Dieser Podcast beginnt wie folgt.
English Literature no longer makes the top ten of A-level subject choices. English departments at universities are regularly closing. Studies show dramatic drops in literacy and reading, particularly amongst teenagers. So today, we're asking, is English literature dying?
Das ist das Thema. Eingeladen ist als Kolumnist von der New York Times James Marriott. Der bespricht jetzt einmal, wie er das sieht, sagt aber vor allem, es gab mal goldene Zeiten der Literaturwissenschaften, aber die liegen lange zurück.
And I think literature, especially in its golden age, in the 40s, 50s and 60s was adopted.
Is that golden age in Britain? Was that in America?
In Britain and America. Okay. Was adopted as the kind of, by some people, by some critics, especially Lionel Trilling, literature was viewed as the kind of ideology of liberalism. Trilling wrote a book which amazingly in the 1950s was a bestseller in America called The Liberal Imagination. And part of the sort of implied argument of that book, and Trilling made it more explicitly elsewhere as well, is that literature and the study of literature is a fundamentally liberal enterprise, because literature acquaints us with the diversity of human character, the uniqueness of human character. And we understand different points of view, we understand different people. And literature fulfills this function as this sort of liberal subject, which in the Cold War was viewed as a kind of important bastion against the totalizing ideologies behind the Iron Curtain.
Das heißt, die Literaturwissenschaften und die Begeisterung für die Literatur hingen. So hier die These von Thrilling, und die wird jetzt noch mal aufgegriffen von Marriott, ist, dass die Literatur ein Bollwerk war gegen eine Kollektivierung, wie sie jenseits des Eisenen Vorhangs vorgenommen wurde. Das ist ja erstmal direkt einleuchtend, das so zu sehen. Da gibt es doch auch Literatur auf der Seite. Richtig, ja, eben. Es wurde ja sehr viel gelesen. Die DDR war das große Leseland.
Wir hatten ja nichts.
Jetzt kann man natürlich darüber diskutieren, was ist denn eigentlich dann diese Literatur, die dabei entstanden ist. Ging es da auch um das individuelle Subjekt. Es gab ja durchaus verschiedene Ideen, wie eine sozialistische Literatur auszusehen hat, dass zum Beispiel das Subjekt nicht so sehr in den Mittelpunkt gerückt wird, sondern eher das Kollektiv. Da gab es ja verschiedene Phasen, zum Beispiel in der DDR-Literatur dann. Aber erst einmal ist es ja eine interessante These zu sagen, dass aus der Beschäftigung mit Romanen, die Einzelpersonen in den Mittelpunkt rücken, die individuelle Schicksale verhandeln, individuelle Entscheidungen, so etwas wie das liberale Subjekt hervorgeht. Das hat natürlich noch weitere Einflüsse, warum so ein Subjekt entsteht. Aber man hat auch immer gesagt über das bürgerliche Trauerspiel, da wurden dem Bürger nahegelegt, wie er zu fühlen hat. Er hat gelernt, wann zu weinen, wann zu lachen ist. Diese Empathie, die man also aufbringen muss, um dann Rezipient zu werden des bürgerlichen Trauerspiels, bringt also das Bürgertum selbst hervor. Und so kann man auch über die Literatur so etwas sagen. Aber du hast vollkommen recht, es gibt ja sehr viele Länder, die wir als nicht liberal bezeichnen würden und wo es trotzdem eine große Literatur gibt, die auch die individuellen Figuren stark macht in Romanen und wo nicht nur kollektiv oder so etwas ist. Deswegen ist diese These nicht so ganz haltbar. Aber man sieht schon, wenn so über Literatur heute diskutiert wird und hier Rückgang, dann geht man gleich auf so eine große Ebene. Ist die Demokratie bedroht? Ist das das Ende des liberalen Zeitalters?
Genau, also man kann ja, ich will eine scharfe These formulieren, du als Film-Schaffender, sage ich mal, also Filmreflektionsschaffender. Bist du eigentlich jetzt besonders im Fokus für diese Art These? Literatur haben wir ja, weil der Text relativ zügig zeigte, wie leistungsfähig er ist. Und das war zum einen ernste Texte, also die guten Bergpresse kommen. Dann gibt es erst mal diesen ganzen religiösen Hokus Pokus, von dem Harari so beschreibt. Und dann relativ zügig moderne mit das Handbuch, der Beipackzettel, der Vertrag und so weiter. Also alles hin zu gesetzen, wie auch immer. Und man hat gesehen, man kriegt ganz schön viel hin mit Text. Und dann hat man so eine imaginäre Parallelwelt geschaffen, auf Basis von Text. Und es ist nicht lange her, 50 Jahre vielleicht, also wenn ich jetzt so Westworld nehme. Westworld ist eine Idee von diesem Michael Crichton, der hat auch Jurassic Park erfunden. And there is a Westworld film. You just can't watch it. Because you see it like this and think, yes, the idea is clear, Roboter and so on. But the film-like possibilities are so weak-hearted that it's just not convincing. And you need a lot of thinking power to bring the idea, to bring this actually into negotiation with yourself, to put yourself in the spotlight. And it's of course a lot easier when you make a movie with literature that you just read in the evening. But, that's the thesis, out of lack of other sources of inspiration for such an idea world. And now we're getting into such a...
Now you have to say that again so that I can contradict you. So you want...
Na ja, ich sag mal, Leute sind auch ein bisschen zu faul zu lesen und gucken lieber einen Film, aber der Film selbst konnte nicht liefern, was Literatur versprach und hielt. Nämlich das wirkliche Eintauchen in eine andere Welt, die einen auch emotional erreicht und so weiter und so fort.
Und jetzt sind die technischen Möglichkeiten da.
Genau, und jetzt sieht man so Filme schon, bei denen man denkt, also die Westworld-Serie zum Beispiel. Ich wüsste gar nicht, wie man die in Worte fasst, so dass sie mich so begeistern könnte, wie diese Serie oder bei Adolescence. Diese Bandbreite an, ich sehe es als vierstündige Serie, ist so viel höher als das, was ich jetzt Text unterstelle oder aus eigener Erfahrung.
Ja, aber der Text ist ja anders. Also du kannst so, ja ich verstehe das entweder oder nicht sogar.
Es ist sehr viel anders.
Also du kannst ja nicht sagen.
Also Filme, brauche ich kein Fleiß für Bücher lesen schon.
Genau, darum wird es jetzt gehen. Also oder darüber können wir diskutieren. Also offenbar bedeutet das für viele Leute, eine zu große Anstrengung zu lesen. Und deswegen schauen sie sich lieber etwas an. Die Bilder laufen ja von selbst. Man kann dann die Augen auf den Bildschirm richten und dann wird man auch so gelenkt, wo man hingucken muss.
Darf man mal weg, der Mann.
Also stellen wir uns vor, es gibt ja Filme, die schon mal mit Splitscreen arbeiten. Da werden wir gleich schon herausgefordert. Schaue ich nach rechts oder links. Aber wenn ich einen Film habe, der einfach so durchläuft mit der unsichtbaren Kamera, also die uns einfach delegiert, wo es jetzt hingehen soll, dann kann ich den natürlich angenehmer rezipieren, wie bei der Aktivität, die ich bei dem Lesen mit einbringen muss. Aber ich würde nur unterstrahlichen wollen, dass die Literatur anderes herstellen kann, was der Film niemals kann. Und das hat gar nicht mit Technik oder so zu tun, sondern die Literatur ist so, wie man auch sagen würde, ja die Musik kann was herstellen, was jetzt beispielsweise ein Gemälde nicht kann.
Genau, das ist eine Gegenthese, bei der man jetzt sagen muss, der Bereich an Wertschöpfung, den Literatur schafft, den anderes nicht schafft, der ist sozusagen Verhandlungsmasse. Also sehr viele Leute verrechnen das mit dem Fleiß.
Es geht ja nicht immer um Immersion. Also man liest ja auch jetzt nicht immer nur Geschichten, in die man hineingehen will oder so.
Aber wie heißt dieser eine Film, der vor zwei Jahren oder so den Oscar für den besten Film, der so völlig abgespacet in Asien und hier und da und dann blitzes so lange Finger. Nee, nicht Parasite. Parasite war ja so extrem naturalistisch. Also wir sind vor Ort, wenn was passiert.
Ach so, everything everywhere, all at once.
So, und das ist ja ein Film, für den braucht man gewisse technische Grundlagen, um den einfach herstellen zu können. So, dann haben die den so gemacht. Man sieht den so und denkt, okay, hier passiert irgendwas. Und das ist schon so eine Art von, okay, das ist ein echter Konkurrenz zu literarischem Leseerlebnis. Allein, weil es weit darüber hinausgeht, was Filme bisher mit einer Kamera, die einen durchführt und ein Erwartbares und so weiter. Ja, und dann läuft es auf den Climax hinaus. Sondern, nee, das war ja ein Film, der es erst mal so schafft, irgendwie so Neues wären.
Sehr artificiell setzt auch den aktiven Zuschauer voraus, deshalb, weil der Film einem einiges abfordert.
Genau, da wird fast das Lesen, das Zuschauen zu der Fleiß arbeiten.
Ja, und das sind ja die Ausnahmen. Da liegt es wahrscheinlich nicht, dass die die Drogen wegfassen.
Und da sind nämlich die Filme plötzlich genauso wenig erfolgreich, außer bei den Kritikern und den Oscars, wie die Literatur. Nur die Literatur kann halt nicht ausbrechen aus diesem, wir zeigen es euch einfach.
Jetzt werden ja einige Leute sagen, aber es gibt auch Booktalk und all das. Ja, es wird auch gelesen. Und wir wollen jetzt nicht über Booktalk reden. Wir werden gleich mal so eine Statistik hören, wie wenig jetzt inzwischen gelesen wird. Also das macht das nicht wett, dass es da jetzt ein paar Trends gibt. Was aber interessant ist, ist, dass wenn über das Ende der Literatur gesprochen wird, man gleich auf so einer politischen Ebene ist und auf einer moralischen Ebene ist, ist das denn gut oder schlecht? Jetzt sagt Marriott erstmal, für die Literaturwissenschaft hat sich folgendes ergeben an den Universitäten.
I think literature has lost its capital and its status in that sense. Probably unsurprising to a degree. No subject is going to dominate a university forever. I think it's arguable that it's been replaced by subjects like psychology. I think people come to psychology for what they might have once come to literature for. So that's part of it. And that's, I think, part of the natural development and evolution of universities. And that's, I guess, would make me sad, but it's fine.
Das bedeutet, man studiert nicht mehr den psychologischen Roman, der ja im 19. Jahrhundert besonders stark ist, sondern man studiert die Psychologie gleich. Damit wäre zumindest erklärt, warum die Literaturwissenschaft nicht mehr einen solchen Stellenwert hat, bei denen die Studieren gehen. Nun ist es aber generell so, dass weniger gelesen wird.
I think the bigger story that makes it more different and more interesting is that it's simply that people are reading much less than they once did. There are various statistics that show this. And the decline of literature, I think, is most interesting to me as a kind of casualty of the end of the culture of reading, which has been a central feature of our civilization since the invention of the printing press, and especially since the end of the 18th century, when reading really spread beyond the elites and into the middle class and further down society.
Du hast hier mitunter von der Gutenberg-Parthese gesprochen, davon, dass wir so ein Zeitalter der Literarizität hatten und möglicherweise schließt sich das wieder. War das so eine Klammer? Und danach geht es wieder so weiter wie zuvor.
Im 14. Jahrhundert.
Will Lloyd fragt nach den Statistiken.
Let's have a couple of the statistics, if you will, James.
So, there's been some really interesting work on this recently, because I think people are waking up to it. But there's a survey last year that found more than a third of adults who said they once read regularly for pleasure, no longer do so. There's another report earlier this year from the National Literacy Trust, which reports shocking and dispiriting falls in children's reading for pleasure. Children's reading has never been lower. The number of eight 18-year-olds reading for pleasure has halved in the last two decades.
Achtzehnjährige halbiert einfach so zum Vergnügen zu lesen.
And I think the really alarming thing that shows this is not just the province of moaning opinion columnists finding something to be cross about is a report from the OECD released at the end of last year, which found that literacy was declining and stagnating in most OECD countries, which is a really remarkable finding. If literacy is declining in a developed country, that would imply some kind of, you'd think there'd been sort of economic shock or war or the education system had collapsed. In fact, I think what we're seeing is the replacement of the culture of the book by the culture of the screen.
Also das ist auch wirklich interessant. Das ist normalerweise nimmt das immer mehr zu. Ja, eigentlich, dass Menschen des Lesens mächtig sind, komplexe Texte verstehen und all das. Und wir haben jetzt erstmalig, dass das abnimmt, ohne dass es eine Krise gibt, dass nicht alles zerbombt und die Schulen sind zu.
Ja, genau. Und ich habe noch im Ohr, wie das ein oder andere SWR Zwergforum, dann so Argumente wie, ja, ja, die Leute greifen nicht mehr zum Buch, aber sie lesen doch auf dem Bildschirm unglaublich viel. Und es gibt so Twitter-Literatur und Spiegel online und alles voller Text, Text, Text und so. Und auch das geht jetzt vorbei. Also die Leute gucken ihre Kurzvideos und so. Das wird wirklich nicht mehr gelesen.
Gleich aber kommen Sie jetzt wieder zu so einer Debatte. Ist der der Least ein besserer Mensch und all das? Marriott streitet sich jetzt ein bisschen mit Tanji Rashid. Der ist auch noch im Podcast eingeladen. Gehört auch zu The New Statesman.
The decline of literacy and the replacement of literacy by like video and internet, I think is like is a catastrophe and I think a lot of the sort of unhappy and depressing things that we're seeing playing out in our politics can be traced to the decline of reading.
I suppose it would be very easy to find societies in history that have had printed material, that have been led in some cases by very literate. People who could write, people who wrote poetry, people who read novels, people who reviewed plays and operas.
We should all of us be free from the idea that when people read, they automatically become better people. First of all, it's about what you read. But yes, there are many beautiful, intellectual people who have done terrible things. Or they were poets themselves, such as Milozovic, Scherger, Randovan, Karacic, der ja auch gedichtet hat. Denken wir an den Roman Die Wohlgesinnten von Jonathan Littell, der diesen Ästhetizismus bei gleichzeitig Brutalität und dem Vernichtungswillen in einen Roman von 1400 Seiten gegossen hat. Das heißt also, das gibt es alles, weshalb, ich glaube, kommt man nicht weiter, wenn man sagt, ja, das Lesen ist besser oder schlechter. Im Sinne von die Menschen, die gelesen haben, werden schon die moralischeren Menschen sein. Und wenn ich so sehe, wie sich gerade hier in Deutschland die Intellektuelle in Bezug zu Krieg und Militär und so weiter verhalten haben, würde ich auch sagen, ich will lieber mit denen auf der Straße sprechen, die noch nie ein Buch in der Hand haben. Die sind wahrscheinlich moralisch eher auf der richtigen Seite als diese Leute, die gerade wieder mal den Friedensnobelpreis, ach nee, den Friedenspreis des deutschen Buchhandels verleihen.
Also ja, das ist die eine Pointe. Die andere Pointe wäre, lesen die eigentlich noch? Also wie viel wird gelesen unter denjenigen, die den Friedenspreis des deutschen Buchhandels bekommen?
Die gehen ja einfach danach, wer ist am allermeisten für NATO und der bekommt den Preis.
Ja, da wird der Preis selbst nochmal so ein bisschen und so.
Das wird sein. Also ich glaube, dass auch die Kollegen nicht mehr lesen. Also die Kollegen lesen sich nicht mehr untereinander. Ich glaube auch, dass die, die noch Literatur produzieren, selbst immer weniger lesen und das auch in diesen Juries, das nur nach irgendeinem politischen Gutdünken geht. Und dann wird dann nicht aufgrund von Textlektüre irgendeine Entscheidung getroffen. Was ich aber glaube, ist, man sollte vielleicht, bevor man diese großen politischen Argumente macht, erstmal einen Gang zurückschalten und zu sagen, Lesen reichert einen. Lesen stärkt die Imaginationskraft oder erweckt sie erst. Die Ausdrucksmöglichkeiten, also die Bandbreite der menschlichen Ausdrucksmöglichkeiten, die gilt es ja zu erweitern. Und da hat die Literatur einen ganz entscheidenden Anteil dabei. Ich reduziere also den Menschen auf doch sehr wenig, wenn ich plötzlich das alles wegfallen lasse. Und darüber kann man natürlich reden. Und wir werden jetzt gleich noch Alternativcontent uns anhören, was die Leute dann sonst so konsumieren. Und dann kann man sagen, ja, dann ist da tatsächlich angesagt, auch kulturpessimistisch drauf zu blicken. Und da muss man aber noch gar nicht über, sagen wir, die liberale Weltordnung oder so reden.
Genau. Also ich würde auch in die Richtung gehen, zu sagen, Leute, die lesen, sind halt zu etwas mehr in der Lage als Menschen, die nicht lesen. Und das sieht man auch daran, zu welchen negativen Sachen sie in der Lage sind. Also ich würde sagen, Peter Thiel wird schon viel lesen, auch wenn er in dieses Metier gehört, wo man nicht, also es gibt so einen ganz tollen Text, den habe ich mal zugeschickt von, vielleicht wird es mal Salon-Lektüre, von Moritz Klänk, unserem Professor Podcast, also der hat ihn mir empfohlen, über 19 Arten des Lesens. Und es gibt ja auch nur den Buchdeckel Lesen, gehört davon, wie andere Leute darüber reden, dass sie lesen und so. Ja, und da muss man ja auch bei Peter Thiel immer so hinschauen. Wenn Leute so viel Geld haben, dass sie die Bücher nicht mehr lesen, sondern einfach ein Stunde Gespräch mit dem Autor führen, dann ist das ja auch ein anderes Lesen, als wie den Text wahrnehmen, wie wir ihn jetzt im Salon besprechen oder so. Also wenn wir jetzt zwei Stunden mit Alex K gesprochen hätten, statt dass er einfach in seiner Bude sitzt, das aufschreibt, wir das dann lesen, wäre das wahrscheinlich zu anderen Conclusions gekommen und so. Dasselbe bei Robin Alexander, der unglaublich viel liest, deswegen auch unglaublich viel nachgefragt wird, weil er dieses Detailwissen dann immer abrufen kann und das irgendwie in seinem Tabelkasten hat. Aber in der Essenz bleibt dann einfach nur, er hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Letzte Chance, also ist er jetzt der Gesprächspartner für, das ist die letzte Chance. Das wird dann gar nicht ausgearbeitet, sondern jeder zieht aus diesem Letzte Chance seine eigene Lehre. Ach ja, stimmt, genau. Also jetzt ist noch mal die Letzte Chance und danach regiert die AfD. Also auf Simpels drunter gebrochen und das Buch hält nicht mal diese einfachen Ideen stand. Kann man dann kritisieren. Aber Lesen mobilisiert auf jeden Fall und kann auch zu Völkermorden führen. Also da ist der Weg nicht dran vorbei. Aber solange alle anderen, die was gegen Völkermorde haben, eben nicht lesen, sind sie nicht in der Lage, da Widersprüche zu formulieren. Wird das schwierig. Lesen erweitert halt die Bandbreite. Und wenn nur noch einige Leute lesen, dann droht die Bandbreite der Gesellschaft dünn zu werden. Weshalb ja, und das finde ich auch sehr gut, es gibt da so ein Publikationsgeschehen von Menschen, die immer mitbetonen, dass sie die migrantische Stimme und so, ich hatte dir auch einen Podcast geschickt. Kommt gleich noch ein kurzer U-Ton. Okay, dann heben wir uns das auf. Wo diese Meta-Spur immer mitgezogen wird, die halt in der klassischen Literatur als Selbstverständlichkeit so ganz inkorporiert ist. Natürlich liest man, wenn man Millionärssohn ist, in den Ferien auf einem Internat ist für zwei Monate, dort den Thomas mannen und bespricht ihn dann auch und so. Aber diese zweite Bandbreite, also da, wo Lesen ungewöhnlich ist, weil man eben einfach den Rückhalt und die Eltern haben schon mal nie vorgelesen und das Vorbildhafte gibt es auch nicht. Und dann ist es auch noch eine andere Sprache als die Muttersprache, weil man lebt ja woanders und so. Dieses Lesen ist ja doch erstaunlich wirkungsvoll. Also ich habe diesen Podcast, den ich dir da geschickt habe, ja sehr gerne gehört, weil da mal richtig was los war.
Ja, also wir können den Podcast ja schon nennen, das ist der Podcast-Brennpunkt.
Genau, mit Abdul zum Beispiel. Also ich höre den nur, weil Abdul da mit drin ist. Die anderen haben ja wohl auch Migrationsgeschichte.
Küppers und dann war zu Gast Mitya Mahmoud.
Genau, die Erlebnisse vom Bachmann-Preis erzählt hat.
Ja, man ist vier Tage da und bekommt 1100 Euro. Das hat mich schon mal entsetzt, dass man so schlecht bezahlt wird, um sich dort öffentlich demütigen zu lassen. Aber es bewundert mich auch, warum nicht.
Aber da sieht man plötzlich, wenn selbst Wolfram Weimer jetzt sagt, uns ist das alles ganz wichtig, wir erhöhen unsere Anteile an den Wagner-Festspielen und machen hier noch und so weiter. Und die haben ein anderes Leseverständnis, als die bei Brennpunkt haben.
Ja, genau.
Das fördern die aber nie mit.
Ich glaube, das ist, ich weiß nicht, wer das ist. Ich glaube, Borak erzählt, dass er dann in Hauptschulen schon mal liest und irgendwann meldet sich dann jemand und sagt, Bruder, wie du stichst morgens auf und schreibst.
Gerne.
Und warum eigentlich? Und das nur da meine Hausaufgaben, dass denen mal gezeigt wird, man muss nicht einfach nur einen Beruf dann machen, der hier vorgesehen ist. Und sonst gibt es nichts anderes. Würde das beeinigen, vielleicht doch auslösen zu denken, ach ja, okay, das kann auch sein. Und ja, hast du keine Freunde, wird er dann gefragt. Doch, doch. Aber das ist auch schön, was zu tun.
Also lesen, vor allem dieses übers Vorlesen, also da, wo Kinder sich noch nicht wehren können, sondern wo man einfach was vorliest. Und sei es eine Geschichte von GPT, die man abends nochmal, weil das Kind sich wünscht, deren, der soll drin vorkommen, wenn alle Freunde werden und so. Ist sozusagen der zentrale Indikator für gelingendes Leben. Und es ist so erstaunlich, dass man, obwohl man das weiß und es in jeder Statistik abgebildet sieht und man es auch fühlt, die Tragweite trotzdem immer wieder ausblendet beim Blick auf das konkrete Buch und so denkt, naja, habe ich das jetzt liest? Und es ist ja auch egal, so irgendwie. Also es erzieht sich immer wieder so.
Wir gehen nochmal kurz zu diesem OECD-Report. Der wird nochmal drauf eingegangen.
You know, the media which we absorb really can change society, and I think it is changing it now. And I think the thing that's different now is that we have evidence for it. Not only these surveys, but the statistics like that OECD report, that's kind of unprecedented in recent history that literacy is declining, like people's ability to engage and interpret complex texts is declining. That's pretty much a first, I think, in the kind of modern history of Europe, and I think that says this is more than a moral panic.
Ja, es geht nämlich darum zuvor, dass man sagt, naja, es gab doch damals diese große Panik im 18. Jahrhundert, in der zweiten Hälfte, dass Frauen so viele Romane lesen und dann irgendwelche merkwürdigen Fantasien haben. Und das war doch moral panic.
Ich will auch leben wie die aristokratische Frau.
Verrei, verwegen. Verfallen wir jetzt auch wieder in eine moral panic bezüglich dieser Zahlen, die dort vom OECD-Report veröffentlicht wurden. Da sagt jetzt Marriott, nein, das ist schon etwas grundsätzlich anderes. Wenn die Fähigkeit, Texte zu verstehen, einfach abhanden kommt, dann geht es darum sehr viel mehr. Und da kann man nicht sagen, ja, aber die Leute machen ja irgendwas anderes. Nein, sie sind nicht mehr in der Lage, dies zu tun. Und er blickt auch sehr pessimistisch darauf.
Er sagt schließlich, The money in Silicon Valley and the economic incentives of these enormous corporations to take up as much of our attention as they possibly can. I'm very pessimistic about the idea that human beings can do much to resist that force.
Es ist ganz schwer. Wir machen ja hier das Angebot, Bücher zu lesen, oder wir empfehlen dann noch darüber hinaus Texte, die man lesen kann. Was passiert da eigentlich im Silicon Valley? Du hast vielleicht auch dieses Interview, dieses lange Format gesehen von John Oliver, in dem er 30 Minuten lang über AI Slop spricht. AI Slop ist das, was wir alle schon mal gesehen haben. Nämlich, wir kennen ja diese Videos von irgendwelchen generierten Katzen, die dann merkwürdige Dinge tun, oder wir haben so etwas wie Bury the Soap. Das ist eine Seife mit einem Gesicht und diese erlebt dann irgendeine Abenteuer. Wir werden zugemüllt mit KI generierten Videos und Bildmaterial. Und wenn man sich ansieht, wie stark das schon bei YouTube ist, selbst wenn man überhaupt nicht danach sucht, sondern man bekommt es die ganze Zeit auf der Empfehlungsseite angezeigt, dann merken wir, was da jetzt gerade passiert, welcher Schrott da produziert wird. Und millionenfach geklickt wird. Dafür gibt es einen Begriff AI Slop. Und John Oliver erklärt diesen mal.
Es ist einer der Zehn ähnliche Videos von dem selben Creator. Und wenn ihr mehr solche Sachen gesehen habt, ist es, weil die Spreite von AI-Generation-Tools es sehr einfach gemacht, massproduzierte und flottere Social Media Sites mit cheap, professionelle-sehrenden, oft auch sehr seltsame Content. Es gibt sogar einen Namen für es, AI Slop. Und es kann in viele Formen kommen. Es können News Articles oder Musik auf Spotify, aber ihr habt es wahrscheinlich am meisten gemerkt, in weird images and videos, that have begun to dominate everyone's feeds. Whether it's images of a Jesus made out of shrimp, or videos like Baron Trump wowing the judges on America's Got Talent, while his dad plays backup piano, a pug raising a baby on a desert island, or Pope Francis taking a selfie with Jesus while flying through heaven.
Ja, das ist halt für Leute gemacht, hat ja Mark Zuckerberg direkt adressiert, die schon keine Freunde mehr haben, die ihm die Timeline vollmachen. Und jetzt ist zumindest sowas aus dem Nirgendwo kommt das ja an.
Und dir wird das überall angezeigt. Ein Beispiel ist es in diesem Monat die wunderbare Conny Francis verstorben. Ich wollte mir also bei YouTube noch mal ein paar Videos von ihr ansehen. Und das erste, was ich angezeigt bekam, direkt war, Conny Francis geht am Stock, also als alte Frau daher. Ich klicke das an, dachte, was kommt da jetzt? Dann wachsen ihr Flügel und sie fliegt in den Himmel. So ein Scheiß wird da produziert. Das flutet jetzt das Internet und es ist nicht so, dass das nur für die KI's gebaut wird und die KI's schauen sich das selbst an, sondern die Menschen sehen sich das an. Das ist jetzt der Ersatz. Facebook ist da vor allem die relevante Plattform für die Älteren nach wie vor. Wir haben das ja so ganz für uns ausgeblendet. Ich denke wirklich darüber nach, wir müssen glaube ich mit dem Podcast stärker auf Facebook vertreten sein. Denn hört ihr das ja an.
This AI Soup recipe was the 7th most viewed post on Facebook at the end of last year. And at another point, three of the top 20 most seen posts there were AI generated, including this one of a giant fan bed, which had 35 million views. And the start of this year, This image of a horse backed out of bread got nearly 50 million views on Facebook and was even loved by Mark Zuckerberg.
Es gibt mittlerweile Videos, in denen jüngere Menschen, Kinder, ihre Eltern filmen, wie sie durch so Eifiz scrollen, und dann sich die Eltern fragen, ob das echt ist. Also beispielsweise sieht man dann in einem Video, wie eine Frau da sitzt, ich nehme mal an, so Anfang 50, und die sieht ein Video von einer Frau, die eine etwa 1,50 Meter große Eule auf dem Arm hat, und fragt ihre Tochter, ob das echt ist.
Ja, das haben wir ja auch gesehen.
I mean, was hat sich da verschoben? Das bedeutet aber, dass also...
Die Väter sitzen alle im politischen Talk Radio und hören dazu. Und die Mütter scrollen da durch und sehen Lustige Tiere. Große Tiere.
Papst mit Jesus. Und auf zum Himmel. Musik.
It is now incredibly easy to create slop like that. Which, as this CEO of an AI music generator points out, is one of its key selling points.
Jetzt hören wir also jemanden, der ein solches Tool anbietet. Alle, die jetzt Musik machen, also die Musik lieben, werden sie jetzt aufhören, die die Musik aufregen, die die Musik machen, werden es nicht fassen können.
It's not really enjoyable to make music now. People enjoy it. It takes a lot of time. It takes a lot of practice. You need to get really good at an instrument or really good at a piece of production software. I think the majority of people don't enjoy the majority of the time they spend making music.
Leute, die Musik machen, machen das eigentlich gar nicht an. Ist auch so anstrengend, ein Instrument zu spielen.
Aber da werde er auch das Ganze sehr viel Wut bekommen.
Er bietet das jetzt alles an. Dann hat mir unser Freund Olli hier aus Frankfurt zwei Videos via Facebook geschickt. Da ist einmal Marben, der sich zu dem Thema KI und Musik äußert und ich finde, er hat recht.
People say that AI is a threat to music. And I have an honest question to these people. How much worse do you think it can get? If you listen to the poo-poo that's called mainstream music these days, I mean, it's so bad. Are we really worried that Cardi B's writing team might get replaced by artificial intelligence? Honestly, maybe we'd finally get that hit we've been waiting for. The song we deserve, Wet Ass Robot Pussy. That's what I'm talking about. That's what I want. If ChatGPT takes over, at least there'll be some level of intelligence involved. Artificial or not, I'll take it, I'm ready. We already invented that AI sound anyway. A large language model just mashes up random data and spits out something that technically resembles music. Without soul, without intent, just with vibes. We have a name for that already. You know what it's called? That shit's called pop songwriting for the last 25 years. It's done by a nine-person writing team, huddling around the laptop, surgically trying to remove every ounce of humanity until an empty product is left. So why are we so scared? Are we scared that a robot might do it better? And whose job are we trying to protect exactly?
Ich erkläre mich schuldig. Also meine Vorliebe für, ich sag jetzt mal, elektronische Tanzmusik, aber eigentlich ist es keine Tanzmusik, sondern es ist wirklich nur Vibe. Ich bin das erste Opfer von, also ich war bislang Opfer von den letzten 25 Jahren und jetzt bin ich das Opfer der nächsten Welt.
Ich finde das doch sehr schlüssig argumentiert zu sagen. Eigentlich haben die doch diesen Aufstieg von AI vorbereitet. Denn wenn jetzt alle Menschen die wirkliche Musik, ob sie jetzt von Hand gemacht ist oder mit dem Computer, das ist ja gar nicht die Frage, aber ob es wirklich originelle Musik ist oder ob es dieses generierte Zeug ist, das jetzt noch von irgendeinem Team von sieben, acht Leuten gemacht wird, oder ob sie die AI-Musik bekommen, da gibt es doch eigentlich keinen Unterschied mehr. Und das ist meine These, dass eigentlich diese Gewöhnung an AI-Slop längst stattgefunden hat. Ich war jetzt gerade im Kino, nämlich in Ich weiß, was du letzten Sommer getan hast. Dieser Film erlebt jetzt ein Reboot. Das ist ja ein Film, der damals schon sehr schlecht war. Damals gab es diesen Hype um Scream. Dann hat man sich entschieden, diesen Film auch rauszubringen, ins Kino zu bringen. Und da war er dann einigermaßen erfolgreich. Aber er war schon damals kein guter Film. Wenn man sich jetzt diesen zweiten Film ansieht, dann versucht man, erst mal genau an das anzuschließen, was schon da war. Indem man jetzt ein bisschen die alten Figuren von damals verwebt mit neuen Figuren, die wieder dort sind an der Küste und irgendein Unfall geschieht. Und dann muss da ein dunkler Recher auftreten. Zuerst einmal ist es so, dass die Handlung so gemacht ist, dass man wahrscheinlich mit einem Prompt das hinbekommt, zu sagen, Chachi Biti, ich hätte gerne ein Reboot von, ich weiß, was du letzten Sommer getan hast, bitte mit ein paar alten Figuren und bring noch ein neues Element mit in den Filmen, so etwas wie Podcast. Nämlich, es gibt natürlich eine True Crime Podcast, damit die dann auch dort dem Ganzen zum Opfer fällt. Dann wäre also schon mal die Geschichte von Chachi Biti schnell geschrieben. Wenn ich mir dann aber noch ansehe, und das ist eigentlich das Interessantere jetzt, wenn wir über das Generieren sprechen und was ist eigentlich AI, was ist echt, wenn ich mir dann ansehe, wie die Schauspiele aussehen, also was sie mit ihren Gesichtern schon gemacht haben, bevor sie am Set erschienen sind, und wenn ich dann noch sehe, wie schematisch die spielen, dann würde ich sagen, diesen Film, dass man den noch mit Menschen gedreht hat, ist geradezu anachronistisch.
Mhm, das stimmt.
Wir hören einen zweiten Instagrammer, der heißt Pritesh Valiya. Der sagt Folgendes. Der macht sonst so Videos über wie man richtig Gitarre spielt und so was.
What the fuck happened to music, guys? What happened to the music? Let me just say this shit real quick. And if it pisses you off, maybe you're the one I'm talking to. And I promise, this comes from the most loving place possible here. I've met musicians who spend 20 hours a day crafting the perfect solo for a 30 second Instagram clip multi-tracked, color graded, edited to death, that splice together nine takes just to play something they could never reproduce live. And yet, ask them to play over a simple blues progression in front of a real human being. And it's like watching a deer get hit by a truck. Like what the fuck happened to the music? What happened to sitting with your instrument and spending time learning music, transcribing, training your ears, composing, reading books? What happened to all of that? Now we just chase numbers, chase likes, chase fake ass approval. Since when did Instagram become our manager, a teacher and our audience somehow? We've confused visibility with value. We've confused content with craft. We've confused attention with art.
Also, ich glaube, man sollte es nicht sehr unterschätzen, wie sehr es doch noch eine analoge Welt gibt, in der junge Kinder einfach zu ihrem Musikunterricht gehen und niemals auf die Idee kommen, sich da zu filmen, das also da nie aufschlägt. Während gleichzeitig, wenn solche Leute dann durch Instagram scrollen, natürlich sehr viele Leute sehen, die sie einfach zeigen wollen und das über Musik machen.
Nur ist das dann oft ja so, dass diese Leute Plattenverträge bekommen, dass das ist, was funktioniert oder dass man hier ja den Fall hat, dass er sagt, die haben das derart optimiert, dass sie nicht mal in der Lage sind, das zu spielen. Das heißt also, man produziert die ganze Zeit was, was man gar nicht mehr spielen kann, was eigentlich schon dann generiert ist. Also man macht das dann zwar noch händisch und offenbar braucht man viele Stunden dafür, aber auch hier, das ist eigentlich so eine Anwarnung dieses Weges.
Also ich finde, wenn man jetzt mehr Instrumente hat und Leute sich lange damit beschäftigen und dann etwas in Anführungszeichen zusammenstümpern, was sie so nicht reproduzieren können und wo sie auch immer punktuell eingreifen können, um dann eine Note doch nochmal zu verschieben oder so, das ist halt Neues, aber auch Musik machen.
Wir sind nun dann in dem Bereich, dass man natürlich sich vom Menschen löst dadurch.
Ja, also die Maschine ist halt auch ein Musikinstrument.
Das hat ja Glenn Gould beispielsweise durchaus für statthaft gefunden, dass man als Pianist einzelne Takte einspielt und das dann nochmal etwas versetzt. Oder, dass in einer Aufnahme, wenn dann eine Sängerin das hohe Zehn nicht hinbekommt, dass von einer anderen Sängerin geklaut wird. Er hat sich ja dafür ausgesprochen, natürlich noch nicht wissen, wohin das mal alles führt. Aber wir sind jetzt an einem Punkt angelangt, bei dem wir Sounds die ganze Zeit präsentiert bekommen, die uns als live vorgegaukelt werden oder als so klingt eine Gitarre vorgegaukelt werden. Und die sind aber ja gar nicht mehr irgendwo herstellbar. Also ich hab ja nichts gegen elektronische Musik, die sagt, ich bin elektronische Musik. Das ist ja unsinnig, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich hätte gerne nur noch Akustikgitarre oder so. Das wäre blödsinnig zu sagen. Aber wir sind ja in so einem Bereich, wo Stimmen und all das so gepitcht werden und auf eine gewisse Markkonformigkeit getrimmt werden, dass plötzlich nicht mehr gewusst wird, wie klingt dann eigentlich eine Stimme? Das ist wie bei den Kindern, die irgendwann glauben, dass die Kühe lila sind.
Genau, ja. Also der Raum für echte Stimmen ist ja da. Er ist natürlich zugegebenermaßen so ein bisschen teuer, wenn man wie wir immer in der ersten Reihe der Oper sitzt und so.
Ja, ich weiß, es gibt ja wesentlich günstigere Operhäusern, als jetzt in Frankfurt zu sitzen.
Also diese Räume sind ja da.
Aber sie werden weniger?
Ja, aber sie sind immer noch da.
Aber ich glaube, das sind wirklich die marginalen Räume. Und ich habe ja jetzt immer wieder bei Veranstaltungen mit Musikern gesprochen, nicht klassische Musik, sondern Indie-Rock und anderes. Die sagen alle, wie prekär das ist, wie viele Leute aufhören. Und ja, man kann immer sagen, es ist nie so gewesen, dass alle super vor Musik leben können. Aber gerade diese Räume, in denen Musik wirklich aufgeführt wird und direkt gehört wird und nicht über irgendeine algorithmische Geschichte überhaupt an jemand geraten ist. Diese Räume werden definitiv weniger. Und das Publikum wird auch geringer dafür. Und ich war jetzt wieder bei einigen klassischen Events, zum Beispiel auch beim SWR Vokal Ensemble. Und ich kann dir sagen, ich war nach wie vor der Jüngste dort.
Genau.
Und dann kommt noch mal ganz lange nichts. Und irgendwann kommen sehr viele Leute, von denen man weiß, okay, die sind aber ja in zehn Jahren nicht mehr alle da.
Genau, also da würde ich auch sagen, da ist eine Einflugschneise für... Also es ist halt ein bisschen blöd, dass man schon so einen engagierten Lehrer braucht, damit ein Klassenverband mal in den Konzert geht. Das kann man auch einfach institutionalisieren. Auf der anderen Seite, ja, wir trauen heute über so eine Medienwelt, die uns die Musik irgendwie nimmt oder verändert, aber wir kommen eben auch aus so einer Medienwelt, in der Rod Stewart einfach so eine ganze Häuserreihe direkt am Central Park kaufen konnte und so.
Das ist auch falsch.
Genau, also es hat halt immer solche Verwerfungen.
Aber wir haben ja über dieses wunderbare Buch von Liz Pelli gesprochen im Salon über Spotify.
Wir haben es doch beide jetzt schon gemerkt, wie wir das jetzt sagen wollen.
Ich bin selbst jetzt, ich höre mit unter gerne alte Countrymusik schon mal so für nebenher und habe jetzt schon zweimal was untergejubelt bekommen, also von einem Countrysänger, den es nicht gibt. Ein Bild generiert, das so aussah, sei das aus so einem Western von 1955, von Howard Hawks oder sowas und dann guckt man nach, wer ist denn das überhaupt, kenne ich ja gar nicht, er gibt es ja auch gar nicht.
Ja, also dass dieser Veralberungsaspekt da drin steckt, um Geldströme in seine Richtung zu lenken, das finde ich auch nicht gut.
Mark Zuckerberg hat natürlich begriffen, wie er jetzt die Plattform umbauen muss, um diesen AI-Content zu generieren und auch noch diejenigen, die das dann generieren, zu belohnen. John Oliver spricht darüber.
And now getting in on this. Here's Mark Zuckerberg proudly unveiling a new suite of AI tools for meta users.
We call it EMU, for Expressive Media Universe, continuing with our animal theme. And just take a look at these images. Because today we're starting to roll out a bunch of products with this in it. And it's, you know, they're high quality, photorealistic. But, you know, one of the coolest things is that Emu generates them fast.
Wenn man sich diese Bilder ansieht, sie sind allesamt krässlich. Irgendwelche Tiere sind darauf abgebildet. Landschaften, Sonnenuntergänge, kitschiger Kram. Also das finde ich auch, wir haben jetzt eben darüber geredet, wie die Literatur verschwindet, dass auch diese ästhetischen Kriterien sich so verschieben. Wir haben das ja schon mal besprochen in Bezug auf diese ganzen Schönheitsoptimierungen, die vorgenommen werden. Dass man irgendwann glaubt, dass das Lippen erst normale Lippen sind, wenn da fünf Kilo noch reingespritzt worden oder so. Und das sieht man ja jetzt auch gerade hier, wie plötzlich eine Ästhetik etabliert wird. Und wenn man sie nur lange genug wiederholt, hält man das dann auch irgendwann für gut und schön.
Ja, Mark Zuckerberg ist wirklich ein ganz erbärmlicher Kulturzerstörer. Wie man das zu seinem Lebenszweck und sich das immer noch schönreden kann, dass man eigentlich ein gossip Publikum bespielt.
Ein unmusischer Mensch, der auch glaube ich alles verachtet, was mit Kunst zu tun hat. Und dann auch da sitzen kann und sagen kann, das sind ja schöne Fotos und vor allem werden sie ganz schnell generiert. John Oliver.
But Zuckerbergs obviously trying to make sure metacapitalizes on the popularity of AI by keeping it within their ecosystem. He said that adding AI images to user feeds is the next logical jump for Facebook and Instagram. They've even tweaked their algorithm so that more than a third of what people see on their Facebook feed now comes from accounts they don't follow. That's how Slop sneaks in without your permission. So it seems to be good business for them, but what's in it for the people that produce it? Well, platforms like Meta, Twitter, YouTube and TikTok now have monetization programs where they make direct payments to people who successfully go viral. And there's now a whole industry of AI-slopped gurus.
Das heißt, du wirst jetzt angestiftet, diesen Content zu generieren. Und es gibt ja schon ganz viele Videos, in denen dir jetzt Leute erklären, so kannst du einen viralen Hit mit JetCPT oder irgendeinem anderen KI-System programmieren oder prompten, muss man eher sagen. Interessant ist auch, diese Gewinne, die man damit erzielen kann, sind natürlich oft nur im Cent-Bereich oder im Dollar-Bereich. Da ist jetzt nicht sehr viel zu holen. Aber das sorgt natürlich auch dafür, dass diese Art, der in Anführungszeichen Kulturproduktion jetzt woanders stattfindet, nämlich in Ländern, wo ein Dollar viel Geld ist. Das heißt, es wird sehr viel natürlich jetzt abseits des Westens in dieser Weise produziert. Und man hofft darauf, dann so ein bisschen was vom Kuchen abzubekommen. Hier noch ein letzter Clip von John Oliver zu diesen Gurus, die anbieten einem zu sagen, wie man perfekte AI-Slop programmieren kann.
As possible. Here is a video by another Slop Guru, showing you just how quickly that can be done.
Er zeigt jetzt, wie er Pinterest nutzt, um ein weiteres Foto zu generieren.
What we're going to do, we're going to type in Home Decor Inspiration Pinterest. Why? Why Pinterest? Because Pinterest is a heavy image-based platform.
Und Pinterest ist schon vollkommen von AI zerstört.
And what you're gonna find as we scroll through these, probably 80% of these images are AI-generated now. What's so cool is that we can come to this free tool right here, Ideagram, and ask it, create a beautiful bedroom design with black curtains and make it hyper-realistic. You're gonna find that the images, boom, just rendered. And right off the bat, for free, we have four images that could do really, really well.
Wir alle können uns vorstellen, wie das aussieht. Das sind so hyperrealistische Ansichten von tollen Apartments mit einem spektakulären Bett drin. Haben wir alles schon tausendmal gesehen, funktioniert. Aber dann in dieser Social Media Welt gut, wird nochmal geleitet, nochmal geteilt. So ein Bett hätte ich aber auch gerne.
Ja, das sind ja Trends, die sich nach zwei Monaten manchmal schon leer gesehen haben, einfach.
Erstaunlich, aber dass es überhaupt so geht, dass Leute sagen, das reicht mir. Also das reicht mir als ästhetische Erfahrung.
Naja, das ist halt, eigentlich könnte jeder das selber machen, sich selber zusammen prompten, mit Journey einfach reinschreiben, was man will.
Aber man könnte sich ja auch schöne Bilder im Internet ansehen. Also ich hatte damals bei Instagram gedacht, okay, da ist sehr viel Schrott, aber es gibt ja auch tatsächlich guten Künstlern die Möglichkeit, ein bisschen was von ihren Werken zu präsentieren. Und ich folge ja auch ein paar Künstler oder kenne auch ein paar persönlich. Und die werden jetzt vollkommen noch mal an den Rand gedrängt durch diese AI-Kunstproduktion, sodass am Ende die wirklich erschaffende Kunst nicht mehr relevant ist.
Aber da hast du ja jetzt eine große Trennung zwischen persönlichen Medien, Kunstwerken, wie auch immer, und den anderen. Also wenn die Geschichte mitgeliefert wird, oder wenn man die Podcast-Macher schon ewig verfolgt und so weiter, dann gibt es da so eine Verfestigung.
Aber wenn du dich jetzt etablieren sollst, ist es echt schwierig. Also ich glaube, dass wir hier…
Nein, die Story kannst du immer mitliefern.
Gut, aber es wird schwierig überhaupt noch gesehen zu werden, wenn AI-Content so dominant ist.
Das stimmt.
Also wenn ich jetzt höre, dass ein Drittel, manchmal auf den Plattformen, schon AI generiert ist, dann wird das auch ja nicht nur für Künstler, sondern jetzt auch für Formate wie die unseren sehr schwierig werden überhaupt da noch Platz zu finden, statt zu finden, weil es ja sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit bindet.
Genau. Also im Dating gibt es gerade so ein neues Phänomen, dass es so eine App gibt, in der sich Frauen über die Männer unterhalten, die sie auf Plattformen finden. Und dann so ein Gespräch darüber, also man hat sozusagen so ein Reportationssystem, das aber im Abseits für diejenigen, die aktiv eine Dating-Plattform benutzen, abläuft. Also du selbst weißt nicht, wie dein Profil auf dem Sekundärmarkt, wo sich Frauen zusammenfinden, um über Dating-Profile reden, wie du da abschneidest.
Klingt nach einer Rating-Agentur.
Genau. Man hat so eine Rating-Agentur, wo dann auch relativ zügig klar wird. Der sieht anders als auf seinen Bildern oder was auch immer, was man halt so bewerten kann.
Aber jetzt muss ich fragen, wie finden sich die Frauen, also wir nennen mal mal, du hast jetzt ein Profil da bei Tinder und jetzt ist da eine Frau, die sagt, hm, finde ich interessant, aber bin mir nicht so sicher, muss da mal auf diese andere Plattform gehen. Woher, wie kommt die eine Frau an die andere Frau, die dich schon mal gedatet hat?
Also ich weiß es noch nicht in dem Fall, weil ich das bisher nur im Podcast gehört habe, aber ich habe es auf so einer Leseliste, will mal nachlesen. Ich kann dir aber sagen, bei Uber zum Beispiel, man holt sich ein Uber und der Fahrer weiß ja nicht, wo willst du hin, wie auch immer, das passiert ja alles erst im Moment, wo er eintrifft. So, es gibt aber so ein Service für Uber-Fahrer, die können per Telegram, kriegen die einfach mal Nachrichten. Also für Angebote, die die bekommen an der Uber-App, wird sofort in dem Telegram-Chat so ein, ah ja, der hat gerade das Angebot bekommen, hier gibt es die Infos, zum Beispiel, wo will der denn hinfahren? Eine Information, die dir Uber eben mit Absicht nicht gibt, aber die du auf so einem sekundären Ding bekommst. Also du kriegst sozusagen Informationen, die dir eigentlich vorbeihalten wird. So, und dann erfährst du auch über den Mitfahrer und so weiter, also alle möglichen Informationen, die dir Uber eben so nicht gibt, weil es sind dann plötzlich da. Das ist sowas selbes, gibt es natürlich auch für Airbnb, wie auch immer. Also da ist eigentlich immer eine Reputationsmaschine, die aus ökonomischen Gründen irgendwie so reglementiert und limitiert ist und daneben parallel noch mal als weiteren Service, aber entkoppelt von dem eigentlichen Anbieter die anderen Reputationsmarker, die dir so Sachen anbieten. Genauso wie wir ja feststellen, dass dieses ganze Podcastinggeschäft nicht darüber läuft, dass jetzt in dem Podcastcharts oder in Podcasts irgendwas erzählt wird und so weiter, sondern nein, man trifft sich ganz analog und empfiehlt sich gegenseitig Podcasts, dann wird mit so einer persönlichen Note, solltest du mal hören, auch wenn es lang ist oder wie auch immer, ein bisschen abgedreht, aber manchmal ganz cool. Also man kriegt dann so nebenbei Information. Und meine Vermutung ist ja beim Thema Fotografie zum Beispiel. Also Oli, unser Freund in Frankfurt, ist ja auch davon betroffen, macht also sein Leben lang Fotografien. Und jetzt stellt sich so raus, also Produktfotografie ist es nicht mehr, Häuser müssen auch nicht mehr unbedingt fotografiert werden, Gesichter aber schon. Und das, obwohl ja gerade eine große, selbst biometrische Fotos werden ja mittlerweile KI generiert. Also gib uns drei normale Fotos von dir, wir machen dir ein biometrisches, als ob das der Sinn ist, dass man mit so einem gefakten, biometrischen Bild, nur weil die Haare aus dem Bild, wer weiß was noch alles, so verschoben wurde. Oder eben du brauchst ein neues LinkedIn-Avatar-Bild, lass dir doch eins von uns generieren, das sieht dann besonders businessmäßig aus. So, Leute stolpern also rein in so ein, ah ja, ich bräuchte das hier mal so quick and dirty, und dann kann man sich gerne Kunst holen oder Musik machen lassen oder Sonstiges. Aber es könnte auch eine Einflugschneise sein für, ah jetzt hab ich so ein bisschen Karriere gemacht, jetzt brauche ich echt mal ein Foto von mir. Und dann plötzlich geht so ein Markt auf.
Bei so einer Sache ja, wenn man sagt, jetzt brauche ich mal eine richtige Visitenkarte oder jetzt brauche ich das.
Bei Kunst ist das ganz wichtig. Also mir ist das aufgefallen, in Museen, du rennst so durch und denkst so, okay, sieht irgendwie so und so aus, dann gibt es dieses kleine Schildchen, man liest so ein bisschen was über den Künstler. Wenn man auf die Kunstmessen geht, hier Artfaire in Frankfurt zum Beispiel, wo einfach in der Messerhalle jeder Künstler kriegt so drei Quadratmeter, bringt auch nicht alles mit, was er hat im Angebot, sondern nur so eins oder zwei und ist die ganze Zeit präsent an seinem Stand und weiß, das ist hier so abgelegen, hier kommen wirklich nur die Westend-Leute rüber und haben eigentlich Budget dabei. Und er ist sofort in Plauderlaune. Und man kriegt die Geschichte zum Kunstwerk und das wertet alles komplett auf. Also man ist dann wirklich in einer anderen Sphäre, wenn man einmal auf so einer Kurswende war.
Jedoch glaube ich nicht, dass AI uns dahin führt, sondern es führt weiter von weg.
Ja, oder Leute, die dann halt eingefegt werden.
Es ist eine Entwertung der Kunst. Und ich würde sagen, mit dem Schwund der Literatur und dieser unglaublichen Expansion von AI-Slop erleben wir jetzt, was ich einfach mit so einem Wort wie Dumpf beschreiben will. Das, was sich eigentlich herauskristallisiert, ist so eine Kultur der Dumpfheit. Da ist so ein fotorealistisches AI-Bild, dann so eine generierte Musik, die völlig generisch klingt. Dazu dann vielleicht noch irgendein Text, der auch nur generiert ist. Und das mindert eigentlich alle Ausdrucksmöglichkeiten, alle Facetten, die das Leben und das Menschsein eigentlich zu bieten hat. Und wenn erst einmal solche dumpfen Subjekte entstanden sind, dann wird es sehr schwierig sein, dass diese sich noch mal öffnen für die besseren Dinge. Also ich sag mal so, wenn man die ganze Zeit irgendeinen schlechten Wein getrunken hat und wenn für eine Süßigkeit nur daran besteht, dass man diese komischen Quengelwaren in sich reinstopft, die es an der Kasse noch mal gibt und nie eine gute Praline gegessen hat oder so, wird man am Ende nicht mehr wissen, wie eigentlich eine Schokolade zu schmecken hat. Wird man nicht wissen, wie eigentlich eine Praline schmecken könnte. Wird man nicht mehr in der Lage sein, den Akkord zu hören, sondern dann ist alles sehr dumpf geworden. Und ich finde, dass jetzt Mithia Mahmood, über die wir schon geredet haben, im Brennpunkt Podcast recht hat, wenn jetzt nicht bezogen auf den RE, sondern generell so auf die Strömung, die stattfindet, Folgendes von Mithia Mahmood gesagt wird.
Es findet auch kontinuierlich ein Angriff auf unsere Imaginationskraft statt.
So, das stimmt. Sie ist ja in diesem ganzen Podcast sehr wütend und urteilt scharf. So ein sehr zurückhaltender Ausschnitt, der natürlich deinen Punkt trifft. Also beim Lesen stimmt das auf jeden Fall. Und ich finde, die Filme werden auch immer dümmer, wobei ich jetzt häufiger hier in diese Filmfreunde, wie heißen diese kleinen Privat-Stadtteil-Kinos irgendwie, wo so ein paar andere Filme kommen und so, sehr lustiges Zeug gesehen. Also es gibt dann doch noch so Filmproduktionen. Es gibt doch andere, ja klar. Genau. Es gibt eine Neu-Sottierung aus Massenmarkt und Avantgarten. Und du hast ja schon häufiger betont, dass Hochkultur jetzt Subkultur ist. So, dass wir Hochkultur bisher einfach fanden, indem wir nämlich sagten, ich will mein Bildungsbürgertum zurück. Da war es einfach geregelt, wo es ist. Schön und gut. Aber ich halte viel, also ich vertraue einfach diesen subkulturellen Einschlägen, die es so gibt, viel. Denn in politischen Diskussionen ist es schon erstaunlich, wie häufig man einfach auf Leute trifft, die dann sagen, nee, nee, ich wähle schon FDP und März macht es irgendwie ganz gut und keine Ahnung und Trump hält sich ja auch ganz gut. Bei diesen Kultursachen ist es genau umgedreht. Ich treffe kaum jemanden, der sagt, meine Timeline war wieder so geil und überhaupt, sondern nee, die Leute suchten nach Oper, nach echter Kunst, nach Zeug, diese Aufregung über Musik. Wir haben das Spotify-Buch besprochen, wir haben, glaube ich, gefühlt noch nie so viele Reaktionen und auch wütend, das ist ja voll krass, was in da los und überhaupt bekommen, wie bei diesem Buch. Von daher, ja, das sortiert sich neu. Und ich finde, dadurch, dass jetzt dieser AIslop so da ist, kontouriert sich nochmal so richtig raus, um was es eigentlich geht. Und sie kann ja sehr deutlich hier markieren. Das ist ein Angriff auf meine Imagination. Und sie meint ja sogar, der Literaturbetrieb, der zu einem Bachmann-Preis führt. Und selbst da wird mittlerweile so treffsicher formuliert, was Sache ist. Von daher denke ich mir, Max Zuckerberg soll das mal alles schön machen, aber da bleiben Welten übrig.
Das interessante an diesem Brennpunkt-Podcast ist ja, dass es ja die Kritik an so einer bürgerlichen Kanonbildung gibt. Und das war aber dann oft so eine Kritik, die eigentlich aus so einer akademischen Mitte heraus wieder kam. Und die bedeutete, ja, alles ist Literatur, ist doch alles gut. Also man wollte das so aufweichen.
Alles, was auf Twitter passiert ist Literatur.
Das findet jetzt ja gerade über Allstadt und Alt, das ist dann am Ende AI-Slop. Während jetzt hier im Brennpunkt-Podcast, das war das Interessante, eigentlich Hünenkam-Literatur eingefordert wird. Nämlich wirklich Literatur, die sich mit nichts gemein macht, die nicht nach Marktkonformität schielt und all das. Da wurde auch Bezug genommen auf den einen oder anderen Poetry Slam, wo das offenbar so der Fall ist. Da kenne ich mich zu wenig aus, um das beurteilen zu können. Da gibt es sicherlich solches und solches. Aber das fand ich interessant, dass also da aus der marginalisierten Gruppe heraus nicht jetzt kam, ja, alles soll einfach Literatur sein. Und das sind halt die abgehobenen beim Bachmann-Preis, sondern eigentlich wurde gesagt, die haben ein sehr, sehr, ja, sagen wir, flaches Literaturverständnis. Und Literatur müsste eigentlich viel mehr sein. Texte, die viel mehr irritieren, einen selbst anblicken und einen hinterfragen, müssten ausscheren aus diesen üblichen Konventionen des Erzählens. Also das fand ich sehr interessant. Und von daher glaube ich, hast du recht, dass das da mehr jetzt entstehen wird. Aber der Status, und das ist eben auch das Entscheidende, um Kunst zu machen, wird ökonomisch immer, immer schwieriger werden. Und da gibt es bei mir die große Sorge, dass eben durch dieses Ökonomische, was nicht möglich ist, so viel anderes dann gar nicht erst produziert wird. Es gibt ja von Virginia Woolf diesen berühmten feministischen Text Ein eigenes Zimmer. Da geht es darum also, dass die Frau, die ein eigenes Zimmer hat, dass sie sich zurückziehen kann, indem sie schreiben kann. Dass das die Bedingung für Literatur ist. Also das ist quasi eine ökonomische Frage. Wir wissen aber, wie es mit Zimmern aussieht, wenn wir auf den Wohnungsmarkt blicken. Wir wissen es, wie es mit Räumen aussieht, in denen Bands und all das auftreten können. Und da sehe ich ein großes Problem. Und da wird nicht ein Wolfram Weimer irgendeinen Raum schaffen, sondern er wird eher noch einschließen, weil er sagt, da war aber wohl jemand Antisemitisch.
Jetzt fange ich dich mit einer Idee von dir wieder ein. Also wir hatten die Zeit, in der Künstler eigene Räume hatten, und wir kommen nachher auf Armandalier zu sprechen. Da war das ja auf jeden Fall gegeben, da ist man ja durch den Dispuls gedingst und so, und war überall präsent. Heute haben wir ja so intellektuelle Heimatgefühle, die sehr eng an den Computer gebunden sind. Zum Beispiel, weil der Computer einfach eine Schreibmaschine ist, oder eine Videorekorde oder was auch immer. Und jetzt hast du ja diese Frage bekommen in der Hörerschaft, in Wohlstand für alle, in eurer SpeakEasyBar, wie ist das jetzt mit den Verlagen, was soll ich tun und so. Und da hast du gesagt, Verlage, installiert ihr in WordPress und schreibt. Und ein WordPress kostet genau nichts, und das Hosting kostet einen Euro im Monat. Also in der Hinsicht, ja, der Abverkauf ist schwieriger geworden, ökonomisch, aber der Einstieg ist doch sehr viel leichter geworden, um sich präsent zu machen. Und schaut euch mich an, ich habe Sozialtheoristen, das war auch nur ein WordPress-Blog vor 15 Jahren damals. Und jetzt sitzen wir hier, machen Podcasts und so weiter. Und ich musste nie dafür einen Kredit aufnehmen oder mich verscholen oder irgendwas.
Das stimmt, aber die Aufmerksamkeit zu bekommen, wir wollen es auch nicht zu beschuldigen, ist auch, das ist Arbeit, ist viel Arbeit, engt auch mit Glück zusammen. Und man muss dann die Zeit finden, das zu machen. Und ich glaube, da sind eben sehr viele Leute, die ja sehen müssen, dass sie, dass sie über den Monat kommen. Und dann zu sagen, nachdem man einen Job gemacht hat, der vielleicht auch sehr kräftezehrend ist und nervenzehrend ist, zu sagen, ich mache jetzt mal noch heute Abend schnell Kunst. Also da wird es schwierig. Ich bin ja auch nicht dafür, dass man sagen kann, wir können nicht eine Million Stipendiaten haben, die sich nur den Künstln widmen oder so, dass so eine Volkswirtschaft nicht funktioniert. Ist mir schon klar. Aber ich sehe einfach, dass da die Räume werden knapper und weniger, im übertragenen Sinne auch. Aber du hast vollkommen recht, auf diesem Wege, auf dem anderen ist sehr viel möglich. Und ich glaube, das ist auch das, was jetzt zu tun ist und was man dann aber auch entsprechend unterstützen muss.
Ja, da fordern wir die Politik auf, die Räume zu schaffen.
Und auch das Publikum, also das auch wirklich so Dinge teilt und unterstützt, sondern und dann nicht einfach nur am Ende wieder das Geld da eingibt, wo es ohnehin schon genügend vorhanden ist.
Wenn man durch die eigene Stadt läuft und man hört handgemachte Musik, dann kann man kurz stehen bleiben. Ich meine, das ist nicht Straßenmusik, sondern schon so, indoor macht irgendwer, in irgendeiner Kneipe wurde was live organisiert oder was auch immer, da steht jemand, macht Musik. Dann kann man da einfach reingehen und sozusagen so einen bewussten Moment test, das gucke ich mir jetzt mal an. Denn hier in Frankfurt zum Beispiel, also Olli macht selber Konzerte, da kommen dann diese ganzen Einschlagszeniere, diese Kanadier, genau, die dann dort so größere Touren machen, die dann hier vor 40 Leuten spielen. Ich war mit Olli in Sachsenhausen bei einem Western-Konzert, also wo einfach am Kontrabass gezupft und gesungen wurde und so, und dann zwei Leute hinten für Rhythmus sorgen. Das gibt's schon überall so ein bisschen. Und dann, wenn man das spontan sieht, denn typischerweise hat man das nicht am schwarzen Brett ausgeflackt und geht dann gezielt hin, wie zu irgendeinem großen Konzert, sondern das passiert dann spontan. Und dann muss man die Gelegenheit halt wahrnehmen und das einfach kurz auskosten, dass es die Gelegenheit gab. Wir reden über Politik und zwar über unser deutsches Schicksal. Das ist aber mal wieder ein Paradox, das die ganze Welt betrifft, denn wir hatten in Robin Alexanders Buch diese schöne Paradoxie, dass welche demoskopische Institut hat die CDU mehr beraten? Infratestimap oder so? Die Köcher?
Er hat das von früher Nölle Neumann und jetzt ist die Köcher da.
Aber das ist Infratestimum. Also eine dieser Rosen, die wir auch so kennen, weil sie immer mal so Umfragen machen, sagt also Friedrich Merz, machen Sie Wirtschaftspolitik bitte, wenn Sie Wahlkampf machen, denn da haben Sie zumindest noch eine Kompetenzunterstellung. Wenn Sie Migration betonen, dann heißt es danach immer, dann wähle ich das Original. Was macht Friedrich Merz? Lässt sich immer überraschen von irgendwas, ist ganz ergriffen. Robin Alexander schreibt es auch, ist auch ganz ergriffen. Die, wie heißt seine Podcast-Kompanie in Rosenfeld, Dagmar Rosenfeld liest das Buch, ist auch ganz ergriffen. Und was wird am Ende vorgelesen in der Live-Show? Natürlich das Kapitel, dass Friedrich Merz am meisten bewegte, also der Terror von Aschaffenburg oder was auch immer. Also alle sind ergriffen, aber eigentlich hätte man lieber Wirtschaftspolitik machen sollen. Wir sind ergriffen, Kaskade ging durch das Milieu. Wolfgang Büchner war Regierungssprecher. Unter Scholz, aber das Hebstreit war Scholz-Typ. Also Büchner wurde, glaube ich, von wem auch immer, den Grünen oder der FDP, Grünen wahrscheinlich eingeladen.
Kann sein.
Es ist so ein bisschen, es ist nicht der Nummer-1-Regierungs-Sprecher, aber Regierungssprecher. Und er ist eingeladen im Podcast Elefantenrunde, beziehungsweise er hat sich dort eingeladen, denn es wurde darüber gesprochen. Und Frank Staus und Hajo Schumacher haben der Nachricht von ihm bekommen. Und da war natürlich die Gelegenheit da, das mal so ein bisschen zu thematisieren. Also, woran ist die letzte Regierung zerbrochen? Ich möchte diesen Joke immer wieder machen. Eigentlich war am 13. November, als das Urteil oder am 15. November 23 kam, eure 60 Milliarden sind leider in Luft aufgelöst. Da hätte man sofort sagen müssen, okay, so, der hat keiner gemacht. Alle dachten, sie mogeln sich noch so durch, machen einen scheiß Wahlkampf und so weiter. Heute rückblickend sind natürlich alle super klug. Also, es noch mal so aus dem Munde des Regierungssprechers von damals zu hören, ist schon ein bisschen Slapstick. Da sollte sich auch jeder Journalist ein paar Gedanken machen, wie kann es denn sein?
Wo war der Bruch der Ampel? Also, war das tatsächlich dieses Bundesverfassungsgericht zu urteilen, dass diese 60 Milliarden plus, die Olaf Scholz sich da zurückgelegt hatte, dass die nicht nutzbar sind? War das der eigentliche, war das der Anfang vom Ende?
Ich glaube ja. Also, natürlich ist dieser Querschlag durch den russischen Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine ein ganz wichtiger Faktor und alles, was damit zusammenhängt, was man nicht unterschätzen darf, was Handlungsmöglichkeiten genommen hat. Aber letztlich hätte man und ich glaube, das sehen mittlerweile eigentlich fast alle so, man hätte diese Zäsur, dieses Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts nutzen müssen.
Neuweilen.
Ne, weiß ich nicht. Man hätte sie aber nutzen müssen, um zu sagen, wie wollen wir hier eigentlich wirklich weitermachen?
So, einfach eine Zwischenfrage unter unseren Vodcastern. Sind wir, die wir 600 Kilometer weit weg von Berlin, einfach Nachrichten gucken, klüger als alle in Berlin die Politik machen?
Ja.
Kann das sein?
Ich glaube schon. Ja, man muss es so selbstbewusst und arrogant sagen.
Wie kann der das denn? Na gut, okay. Also nach einer zerbrochenen Regierung, ja stimmt, irgendwie, ein schöner Thema muss sein. Gut, also Wirtschaftspolitik ist also wichtig. Man kann sie nicht einfach übergehen. Wenn ein Naturereignis passiert, von außen herangetragen, eine echte Gefahr, man kann es nicht vorher sehen. Ein bisschen Risiko als war es schon, aber passiert, dann schlägt wirtschaftspolitische Grundlage einfach alles. Dann zerbrechen da Regierungen. Egal welchen Mikrationsfülle-Fanz man irgendwie macht, weil die AfD größte Oppositionspartei ist. So, Robin Alexander heute macht sogar noch Jokes draus.
Also die Finanzpolitik der Regierung März ist doch die Finanzpolitik, wenn man es mal ein bisschen hämisch sagen will, von Saskia Esken. Die hat 500 Milliarden Sondervermögen für Infrastruktur als Erste gefordert.
Aber warum gewinnt die SPD dann nicht in den Umfragen dazu?
Ich glaube, dass ich glaube, es geht tatsächlich nur über das Erarbeiten von Ergebnissen. Das klingt jetzt ein bisschen spießig, aber ich glaube, es stimmt. Die Leute müssen sehen, dass wir wieder Wirtschaftswachstum haben.
So, die Leute müssen sehen, dass wir wieder Wirtschaftswachstum haben. Und in Amerika beobachten wir ja auch, okay, die Inflation war es, die Eierpreise oder was auch immer. Nur warum ist der politische Wahlkampf und die journalistische Begleitung dann immer nur, da wurde ein Kind abgestochen, das muss das Topthema sein, das war ein Migrant, wir müssen das sofort hochgeneralisieren, alle Migranten sind sofort verdächtig, sie müssen alle raus, wir müssen die Kinder schützen. Also in der Reflektion sind die Politiker und die Journalisten eigentlich einig. Wirtschaftspolitik ist es so. Aber trotzdem machen sie ja immer Migrationspolitik, das ist ja ein bisschen verrückt.
Ja, es ist immer das Nachträgliche. Also mittlerweile hat man ja den Eindruck, dass alle Journalisten sagen, bei Corona sind wir aber zum Teil auch zu weit gegangen. Also jetzt auch die Maximalisten, die da nochmal, wo schon alle wieder draußen rumgerannt sind und verrückte Partys gefeiert haben, nochmal sagten, jetzt aber ein Lockdown. Selbst die sagen ja jetzt, da sind wir irgendwie zu weit gegangen, keiner will da mehr festhalten. Jetzt sagt man so, offenbar denkt man so bei sich. Wo sind wir denn da eigentlich wieder reingeraten? Na ja, hat das auch mit mir zu tun. Will ich lieber nicht drüber nachdenken? Aber jetzt sage ich nochmal nachträglich, wie man es hätte besser machen können.
Genau. Also man legt dann immer so eine Retrospektive. Okay, ich bin nicht ganz doof. Kann ich mir noch ein bisschen Klugheit bei euch ergaunern, so ein bisschen ansehen, indem ich zumindest nachträglich sage, okay, er hatte doch vielleicht umgerechnet.
Wirtschaftswachstum war doch wichtig.
Genau. So, Roman Alexander sagt jetzt, bla bla, Wirtschaftspolitik war ganz wichtig. Und jetzt kommt er doch wieder auf die Migrationspolitik. Und er hat jetzt den Fehler gefunden bei der Migrationspolitik.
Auch das ist mir klar geworden bei der Arbeit zu dem Buch. Die Ampel hat ja gar nicht nichts gemacht bei der Migration. Das stimmt ja gar nicht. Olaf Scholz hat ja mehr gemacht als Angela Merkel. Also ich meine, die haben ja angefangen mit Zurückweisung. Olaf Scholz hat gesagt, im großen Stil abschieben.
So und das klingt ja jetzt so wie eine zweite Einsicht nach der ersten Einsicht. Okay, Wirtschaftspolitik war für die ein blinder Fleck. Hätten sie mal machen sollen. Und jetzt Migrationspolitik. Ja, da sind sie eigentlich voll weit gegangen. Und jetzt erklärt uns Robin Alexander mal, warum es trotzdem nicht geklappt hat.
Das ist mir gerade ein Kommunikationsproblem, oder?
Ja, so ein bisschen. Wir müssen noch einen Schritt weiter zurückgehen, denn wir haben ja sozusagen handlungsorientierte Beobachtungen. Das heißt, da kommt es auch auf Intention und Kognition an. Also Kommunikation ist schon so weit gedacht. So, die Erklärung ist, also ich finde sie haarsträubend für ihn, ist natürlich voll in der Logik.
Die haben die Bezahlkarte eingeführt. Die haben in Europa auch nicht eine Rolle gespielt, wo sie gar nichts mitgemacht hätten bei Gias. Also die Ampel hat sich beim Thema Migration in eine Richtung bewegt, die wir beide richtig finden würden.
Also so ein kleiner affirmativer Einschlag kommt natürlich. Also ich bin ja auch gegen Ausländer, also hat die Ampel eigentlich eine ganz gute Ausländerpolitik gemacht, indem sie die nämlich alle rausschmeißen wollten.
Und der spricht ja mit Ronzheimer, oder?
Er spricht im Ronzheimer Podcast.
Der muss da auch nochmal zustimmen, dass er das auch gut findet.
Ja, alles ganz gut.
Leute haben es ihr nicht gedankt. Und ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass die Ampel den Eindruck erweckt hat, sie wollen es gar nicht tun. Und das lag vor allen Dingen an den Grünen. Das war ein schwerer strategischer Fehler der Grünen Partei. Sie haben diese Dinge immer mitgemacht, aber immer nach Wochen des Verzögerns und des Sich-Ab-Handlens lassen.
So, wir haben jetzt folgende Konstellation. Die Ampel hat sehr gute Migrationspolitik gemacht aus dieser Sicht, die ich ja nicht teile. Und jetzt konnte Friedrich Merz durch die vorgezogene Neuwahl das einfach für sich einheimsen und sagen, liebe AfD, wir haben minus 45 Prozent Asylanträge, das ist doch voll geil. Und die Ampel hat es aber so halbherzig gemacht. Und wir kennen das Gegenbeispiel aus Italien, Meloni. Meloni kam zwar auch mit diesem, ich mache die Migrationszahlen klein, nur dann hat sie sich nie halbiert, sondern sie sind explodiert. Es sind so viele Leute auf den Italienischen angelandet wie noch nie zuvor. Aber die Leute glauben, Meloni, dass sie es aus ihrem Innersten heraus wirklich will. Und deswegen kutieren sie das.
Und die Grünen haben Bauchschmerzen gehabt bei den Entscheidungen.
Also Meloni könnte man sozusagen nicht rechts überholen.
Ja.
Weil noch mehr inbrünstig kann man es nicht machen. Also sie treibt es auf die Spitze, aber ja gut, die Zahlen sind ja trotzdem hoch. Aber die Zahlen sind nicht so wichtig. Das Gefühl, ob sie denn jetzt für uns das macht. Während man bei den Grünen immer dachte, ja, die sind schon ganz schön erfolgreich, so rückblickend gesehen. Aber die hätten ja noch viel erfolgreicher sein können, wenn sie es ernsthaft auch selbst gewollt hätten, dass die Ausländer hier nicht herkommen. Was bedeutet für Robin Alexander, der eben noch meinte, Wirtschaftspolitik ganz wichtig, daran können die Regierungen zerbrechen. Das muss man im Blick behalten. Schwenkt jetzt doch wieder um auf Migrationspolitik und die muss auch möglichst AfD mäßig sein, aber nicht ganz so menschenfeindlich.
Und auch das Versprechen von Friedrich Merz, ich werde die AfD halbieren. Also diese Idee, es wäre etwas, was die Union ganz alleine tun könnte, die funktioniert glaube ich nicht. Das sieht man auch, wenn man sich mal anguckt, wir hatten schon über Ostfalschland gesprochen. Wenn wir auf den Westen gucken, wenn du mal schaust die Regionen, wo die AfD dramatische Einbrüche hatte, Kaiserslautern, Pforzheim, Mannheim, Gelsenkirchen, das sind alles so, ich sag mal post-industrielle SPD-Hochburgen. Da war die Union nie hegemonial. Also deshalb, ich glaube, die gesamte politische Mitte muss das Problem bearbeiten der AfD und muss eine Politik machen, die Leute erreicht, die zuletzt bei der AfD waren oder darüber nachgedacht haben. Und jetzt kommt die Schwierigkeit, natürlich ohne den menschenfeindlichen Impetus zu übernehmen. Weil sonst, das ist ja das Ziel, dass man eben aus der Mitte rechtsstaatlich gute Politik macht und die Leute trotzdem erreicht.
Das heißt jetzt, Ausländer raus, aber mit Gefühl. Aber trotzdem muss man ja zeigen.
Mit Überzeugung, aber ohne die Slogans.
Ja. Ja.
Verstehst du das?
Ja, genial. Also ich muss jetzt, ich habe ja eben als wir über Trump und all das Diskutierten gesagt, mich stört jetzt so langsam diese Rede. Es ist fünf vor Faschismus und wir sollten jetzt einfach mal akzeptieren. In 2029 wird die AfD mitregieren. Und die Frage ist also, was bringen wir jetzt schon alles auf den Weg, das sie übernimmt? Nachdem ich das jetzt hier höre, würde ich noch zu einem zweiten Gedankenexperiment einladen. Wir sollten vielleicht mal gerade so tun, als würde die AfD schon mitregieren. Und vor diesem Hintergrund, die AfD regiert bereits mit, betrachten wir eigentlich alles, was in Sachen Migration, Chatkontrolle und Beendigung von irgendwelchen Kunstaktionen, Demonstrationsverbote, Einschränkungen von öffentlicher Meinung und so weiter, was alles schon stattgefunden hat. Also wir sollten mal all das, was stattgefunden hat und was gerade stattfindet, so betrachten, als hätten wir auch schon eine Regierung, in der die AfD beteiligt wäre. Dann würde man mit einer ganz anderen Kritik, nämlich mit einer fundamentalen, daran gehen, während hier ja die ganze Zeit uns gesagt wird, ihr dürft nur diesen einen Step nicht machen, mit der AfD das so zusammen zu machen, aber sonst macht bitte AfD Politik nur nicht so laut.
Genau.
Ja, das war ja auch mehrmals von Unionsleuten zu hören. Ja, der Trump ist eigentlich gut, aber so seine Art, das ist so ein bisschen Geschmacklos, das ist so wie der Onkel, der sich nicht benehmen kann. Der ist zu laut.
Kann er die Mauer nicht still und leise bauen, weil jeder sein Zaun aufstellt.
Ja, weiß nicht, wie man Fischmesser benutzt und so. Das ist nicht schön. Aber eigentlich will man das. Und deswegen glaube ich, ist es viel sinnvoller, jetzt mal nicht immer so dieses dramatische Szenario 2029, die AfD ist da, zu imaginieren, sondern einfach mal zu sagen, ja genau, wir werden ja schon von der AfD regiert. Wie gehen wir eigentlich damit um?
Das heißt, die Wirtschaftspolitik ist jetzt schon ein bisschen aus dem Fokus geraten. Man hat das zwar am Anfang kurz so angemerkt, ja, wäre irgendwie cool gewesen und so, wenn man da die Regierung nicht hätte zerbrechen lassen, einen echten Fakten. Diese Gefühlspolitik gibt jetzt ewige Beratungsleistung von Robin Alexander, wie man so, du hast ja beschrieben, so AfD-Politik, aber nur so, dass man es nicht so ganz merkt, aber trotzdem überzeugend. So, was bedeutet, in Amerika hört man jetzt was, und das ist jetzt The Daily. Also, ich betone nochmal, der reichweitenstärkste Nachrichtenpodcast der Welt, der jetzt kurz eine Einschätzung der amerikanischen Wirtschaftspolitik macht zum Thema 3, 4 Trillionen Dollar müssen da irgendwie gefunden werden und so, um dieses Big Beautiful Bill zu organisieren, während Trump beim Thema Migration immer noch die Leute auf seiner Seite hat. Also, ich finde das zwar blöd für die Familien und so, aber er kann von Wirtschaftspolitik ablenken, wenn er diese Migrationspolitik weiterhin so macht. Findet ja nur in Kalifornien statt und so. Also findet zwar flächendeckend im Land statt, aber in Kalifornien wird es halt thematisiert. So, wir hören zwölf Sekunden und überlegen uns mal, käme man in Deutschland zu einer anderen Einschätzung, wenn man mal schnell eine wirtschaftspolitische Einschätzung zum Stand der Dinge macht?
And so, Senate Republicans in their bill, they use for the first time ever, what amounts to basically a fiscal magic math to try and make the tax cut work.
Fiscal magic math.
Just explain that.
Da würde ich mal sagen, ja, also die Finanzkonstruktion um diese Zinsen und so weiter. Und das hatten wir ja hier auch. Also, dass Linden irgendwie sagt, wir zahlen so und so viel Zinsen. Und dann macht Moritz Höfgen die Auflösung. Nee, der verbucht einfach nur alles heute und macht dann so ein Durcheinander. Genauso mit diesem Ja, ich hatte noch seit hier, ich hatte noch seit da Vermögen. Nein, das ist kein Sondervermögen, das sind Sonderschulden und der ganze Kram. Also es ist ja im Grunde auch nur so eine semantische Fiske, Magic, Math, die da irgendwie durchgeprügelt wird. Weshalb wir also bleiben können beim Thema Migration. Und wir hören jetzt wieder Robin Alexander bei Ronsheimer, der einfach gar nicht mehr merkt, dass er zwar eine schöne Rhetorik hat zum Thema. Und es klingt auch total Anschlussfähig. Und da höre ich so, klar, voll klug der Typ. Nur, das bekäme man politisch niemals auf dem Boden. Also dafür ist eine Migrationspolitik, die angeblich für AfD-Leute funktioniert, wäre wirtschaftlich so einschneidend, dass man das niemals auf einen Nenner bekäme. Aber das ist ja einfach völlig egal in solchen Gesprächen.
Das Ganze rechts, das nähert sich ja aus dem Frust. Das ist ja eine Bewegung, die aus der Enttäuschung Kraft zieht.
So, und wir überlegen jetzt, welcher Frust, welche Enttäuschung, dass durch Bremenberg zu viele Ausländer laufen und die deswegen frustriert und enttäuscht sind? Oder wo kommt der Frust her?
Aus der schlechten Laune, ja. Und deshalb, wenn es besser wird wirtschaftlich, ist die Hoffnung, dass auch die Stimmung steigt.
So, wenn es besser wird wirtschaftlich. Also, er schwenkt jetzt einfach mal wieder so auf die Wirtschaftspolitik um. Nachdem er vorher, ne, die sollten schon harte, harte AfD-Politik und auch mit Überzeugung, aber nicht mit dieser Semantik, die er so dazu führt. Wir haben es ja von Aladin Al-Mafalani durchgerechnet bekommen. Remigration durchgerechnet. 20 Millionen Leute gehen, alle Rentner bleiben, alle Schüler sind weg.
EP, so ein Keller.
Degrowth minus 20 Prozent und so. Und jetzt ist aber plötzlich wieder voll auf diesem, nee, wirtschaftlich muss es aber gut laufen für die AfD-Wähler. Also es passt nicht zusammen.
Vor allen Dingen frage ich mich, was er dann damit meint, wirtschaftlich gut laufen. Denn dann muss man ja sagen, so wie jetzt Familien belastet werden sollen, die jemanden haben, der gepflegt werden muss. Wenn wir sehen, wie die Arbeitszeit verlängert werden soll, wenn wir sehen, dass die Löhne weiterhin nicht entsprechend wachsen, wenn wir diese ganzen Maßnahmen sehen, die nur dazu da sind, dass eben einige noch ein bisschen reicher werden, dann würde ich sagen, wird ja da, oder wir sagen das schon sehr lange, der Frust produziert, der dazu führt, dass die AfD gewählt wird. Bei Robin Alexander klingt das jetzt einfach so, als würde Wirtschaftswachstum automatisch sich verteilen auf alle, die an der Wirtschaft teilnehmen. Und das ist ja leider nicht so.
Man sieht dann im Fernsehen, dass der DAX steigt und soll dann gute Laune bekommen. Also es ist sehr merkwürdig alles.
Das ganze rechts, das nähert sich ja aus dem Frust. Das ist ja eine Bewegung, die aus der Enttäuschung Kraft zieht, aus der schlechten Laune. Und deshalb, wenn es besser wird wirtschaftlich, ist die Hoffnung, dass auch die Stimmung steigt und dass sich das auch gegenseitig bedingt. Und ich glaube, da hat er auch einen Punkt. Und das zweite ist das schon Angesprochene, wenn wir aus der Überforderungssituation der irregulären Zuwanderung rauskommen, dass das Thema ein Stück weggeht. Wobei, da darf man sich natürlich keine Illusionen machen. Die AfD führt gerade eine Debatte, wer hat hier in Deutschland Bürgerrechte? Und da darf man auch Leute remigrieren, die schon einen deutschen Pass haben.
Also ich dachte, man musste jetzt mit Wirtschaftswachstum bekämpfen. Und jetzt muss man plötzlich auf deren Remigrationsding einschwenken, um irgendwas zu gewinnen.
Weil ich stelle das ja auch gar nicht hin. Die AfD räumt ja gerade das ab.
Das kommt noch dazu.
Der Remikationsbegriff, das ist ja ein Stand von, weiß ich nicht was.
Vor anderthalb Jahren, genau. Eigentlich hat man ja Krache wieder händeringend und alle um sich schlagen, da zur Vernunft bringend, willend, also aus deren Sicht.
Auch was eingerissen, die sich da eine rein weiße Gesellschaft vorstellen, die wir nie wieder bekommen werden. Also richtig harten Ausländerhass, den wirst du aus der Mitte niemals adressieren können.
Kein Mensch, der jetzt bei der AfD eine wichtige Rolle spielt, geht davon aus, dass hier diese weiße Gesellschaft etabliert wird, die nur noch dann hier ist. Also das ist ein ganz merkwürdiges.
Selbst die haben es eigentlich geblickt.
Ja, und damit will ich nicht die AfD verharmlosen, aber man muss doch begreifen, dass man nicht immer nur vom Maximalen ausgehen kann. Also ich kann das natürlich machen und den Anschlag bringen. Und nur dann will ich nicht mehr analysieren, dann will ich nicht mehr differenzieren. Und dann will ich auch nicht merken, wo jetzt gerade Verbindungen entstehen, wo zuvor noch keine waren. Also ich will es nochmal deutlich machen. Maximilian Krah war viele Jahre in der CDU. Und ich würde behaupten, wäre dieser Mann in den Bundestag gekommen und hätte so ein bisschen gegen Merkel da Arbeits machen können, wäre der auch immer noch in der CDU und würde wahrscheinlich jetzt ein Podcast mit Wolfgang Bosbach zusammen machen. Für den hat sich dann ein anderer Weg ergeben. Jetzt geht er diesen. Er ist vollkommen auf den transatlantischen Kurs eingeschwenkt oder wieder dahin zurückgekehrt, denn der ist immer in CDU-Kurs gewesen. Das funktioniert mit Donald Trump besonders gut.
Hat sich mit China mal kurz in China verbrannt.
Mit Alice Weidel hat man diese libertäre Seite noch drin, die bei der CDU auch stärker wird. Und selbst Höcke wie auch Kra haben in mehreren Aussagen, die sie getroffen haben, immer wieder gesagt, wenn Friedrich Merz über uns gesprochen hat, dann hat er ja gar nicht über unsere Migrationspolitik gesprochen, sondern nur noch über so Sachen wie Westbindung, Euro-Austritt, Exit und und und. Und das wollen wir ja gar nicht. Oder das müssen wir erst mal noch diskutieren oder so drücken.
Warte mal, da passiert gleich noch eine Überraschung drin.
Also jetzt so zu tun, als sei das einfach diese völlig durchgeknallte AfD, die aus allem raus will oder so. Also man kann das gerne so machen, aber dann will man einfach darüber nichts wissen. Und wo ich gerade dabei bin, will ich das auch nochmal sagen. Wir sind nicht mehr im Jahr 2014 oder 2015. Da kann man Anfängerfehler machen. Wir wissen, die AfD funktioniert gut, wenn sie irgendwie virale Hits schafft. Wenn ich ein Sommerinterview mache mit Alice Weidel und dann tritt da ein Chor auf, dann produziert man für Alice Weidel einen viralen Hit. Ich würde mir geradezu wünschen, dass wo immer ich auftrete, so ein Chor auftritt und genügend Kameras vor Ort sind.
Kann man mich auch mal so stören und dann ein Video produzieren?
Wenn man das hier mit unserem Podcast machen würde, wir würden durch die Decke gehen. Also bitte teilen, gerne einen Chor noch drunter geben. Also das ist einfach falsch. Es ist einfach dumm es zu machen. Ich kann ja irgendwie noch sagen, ja gut gemeint, aber es ist ja noch nicht mal mehr das. Und dass wir nicht mal den ein oder anderen Schritt jetzt mitgehen in der Lernkurve, wie mit der AfD umzugehen ist, beziehungsweise wie über sie nachzudenken ist, leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Nee, mir auch nicht. Ja, es ist schräg. Vor allem, die einen kommen da mit diesem komischen 100.000 Watt Bus und machen Lärm, keine innerliche Dimension. Robin Alexander geht einfach nach diesem sehr aufreibenden inhaltlichen Gespräch bei Ronzheimer zu Micky Beisenherz in dem Podcast, um dort noch mal über die persönlichen Komponenten zu reden.
Aber das, was ich noch sagen wollte, ja, was ich da schrei-
Also es ist ihm sehr wichtig, das wollte er jetzt unbedingt noch sagen....
ist wirklich so interessant und es ist auch wirklich so abgründig und es ist streckenweise auch wirklich so lustig.
Er musste das quasi aufschreiben. Das, was er da aufschreibt, ist halt wirklich so lustig, wie er das aufgeschrieben hat. Und wir haben ja auch gelacht zwei Stunden lang.
Nur.
Weil es halt menschelt.
Ja, Beisenherz weiß, weil es menschelt.
So sind die Leute und...
So sind die Leute.
Wie wir das, das ist ja toll, das kannst du ja parallel hören. Also das, was jetzt eben schon Fabian Köster...
Jonas Hector gesagt haben, ach, dann erlebt man die auch mal so, wie sie sind. Mal authentisch.
Der Amt war so ganz authentisch.
Dann erleben wir jetzt noch mal mit Robin Alexander und Micky Beisenherz einen Politikpodcast. Das heißt, dieser Politikdiskurs, den wir haben, ist eine solche Verblödungsmaschinerie, dass natürlich alles durchgehen kann. Also ich bin völlig entsetzt.
Naja, ich mein, irgendwie muss man halt den Weg dafür bereit machen, dass man nicht mehr über Konzepte sprechen muss.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich nur über Personen.
Mensch, schön.
Du hast Köpfe oder Konzepte, musst dich halt entscheiden, über wen du jetzt reden willst. Köpfe oder Konzepte, oder? Dann bleibst du bei Köpfen.
Ja, warum soll ich das langweiliger aufschreiben, als es gewesen ist?
Na, das macht ja die guten Politbücher aus, dass man halt eben die menschliche Komponente nicht vergisst.
Also, was macht die guten Politikbücher aus, dass man noch was über die Menschen erfährt?
Ja, Donald Trump ist ein toller Vater und ein guter Golfer. Das sind die Geschichten, die mich interessieren.
Robin Alexander...
Netanyahu isst gerne bei Bürgerkriegen lieber als bei McDonalds.
Robin Alexander verpackt das jetzt nochmal in Pointen, weil das war ja noch keine Pointe, die kommen jetzt.
Ja, Robin, du berichtest über...
Das ist jetzt schon wieder weitergezogen im Machtwechsel, also im eigenen Podcast.
Okay, du bist zurück in den Männerpodcast.
Friedrich Merz in einem entscheidenden Moment des CDU-Wahlkampfes. Es sind die letzten Wochen, bevor die Wähler an die Urne dürfen und er macht einen radikalen Kurswechsel. Also das, was er trotz Magdeburg, trotz dieser harten Debatte, die öffentlich geführt wird, durchgehalten hat, nämlich auf Wirtschaft zu setzen, weil er da die Kompetenzwerte der CDU sieht, vermutet. Davon geht er jetzt ab. Auf den letzten Metern wechselt er.
Genau wie ihr, Dagmar, es dauert noch drei Minuten. Und dann fragst du, ja Robin, willst du jetzt mal die erste Textstelle vorlesen? Am besten die zu Magdeburg oder zu Aschaffenburg. Also das Kind sollte schon jetzt erst kommen.
Das ist aus einer Emotion heraus, aus einem sehr emotionalen Moment. Und das ist, glaube ich, doch der krasseste Unterschied zu seinen Vorgängern, zu Olaf Scholz und zu auch Angela Merkel. Emotionalität hat es bei diesen Kanzler und beiden Kanzlern nicht gegeben.
So und jetzt sagen wir ja eigentlich, das war das Feature. Das war nicht der Fehler dieser Leute, sondern die konnten einfach in einer Zehn-Stunden-Sitzung es aushalten, dass es da emotional zur Sache ging und am Ende einen Strich drunter ziehen und sagen, und die Bilanz ist, das Corona-Virus wird sich so und so ausbreiten, also müssen wir genau auf diese Mathematik so politisch reagieren und uns jetzt nicht verunsichern lassen. Stattdessen, äh, pflichtet ihr Robin Alexander jetzt natürlich bei.
Der emotionale März, ist das eine gute Nachricht für Deutschland?
Ja, das ist eine ganz schwierige Frage und das war auch das Erstaunliche dabei. Natürlich hatten auch Merkel und Scholz Emotionen, bei Scholz wäre ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, aber eigentlich glauben wir schon.
Es geben Gerüchte, es gibt das Gerücht.
Aber die haben das natürlich verborgen.
Ja, die haben das verborgen. Und deswegen waren sie irgendwie dann doch Kanzler, die was geregelt bekommen haben.
Das nennt man Effektkontrolle. Und nur so funktioniert überhaupt unser öffentliches Leben. Ich fahre ja viel Bahn, sehe dort viele Dinge, die mir nicht gefallen. Wenn ich das ständig sagen würde, dann gäbe das da ein Problem im öffentlichen Nahverkehr. Ich muss mich also zurücknehmen. Ich muss mich in ganz vielen Situationen zurücknehmen, öffentlich bleiben, schweigen und aber auch Entscheidungen in den richtigen Momenten treffen. So funktioniert eigentlich ein zivilisiertes Leben.
Außer der Kanzler, da möchten wir Berliner das eher nicht.
Wenn wir nur noch rausrennen und jedem an den Kopf werfen, was uns jetzt gerade durch die Birne saust, dann ist hier wirklich Bürgerkrieg.
Ja.
So und jetzt haben wir aber ein Thema etabliert, ein Paradox zwischen Wirtschaft und Migrationspolitik. Wir haben in der CAS uns zuletzt nicht nur darüber lustig gemacht, sondern auch darüber beschwert, auf welche Art und Weise auch Dobrindt als Innenminister Gerichtsurteile ignoriert, indem er einfach sagt, naja, die Instanz ist so nieder, die hat ja nur über einen Einzelfall befunden, auch wenn die Richter da 30 Seiten lang sozusagen eine Abhandlung zum Thema Staatswesen schrieben und es völlig klar wurde, jeder Einzelfall würde so entschieden und die Bundesregierung gibt dann klein bei und eskaliert das nicht in die nächste Instanz, damit es keinen Grundsatzurteil gibt. So, dieses Prinzip etabliert bedeutet eben, es gibt Grenzkontrollen zu Polen. Und die Polen reagieren mit Grenzkontrollen. Und die Polen machen das auch, um überhaupt noch eine staatliche Hoheit zu behaupten, wo schon private Milizen rumgehen und sagen, also wenn ihr uns diesen Migranten über die Brücke schiebt, wir schlagen den hier zusammen. Liebe deutsche Polizei, überlegt selber, was ihr jetzt machen wollt. Also so geht es ja da grad zu. Also greift dann irgendwie der Staat ein und sagt, okay Leute, geht mal nach Hause, wir machen jetzt hier diese Grenzkontrolle.
So.
Und die Bundesregierung hat einen Polenbeauftragten, Knut Abraham. Und der versucht jetzt, uns in echter Politik zu vermitteln, was ihn Robin Alexander gerade als Aufgabending gegeben hat. Also die Wirtschaft nicht aus dem Blick zu verlieren, weil die ist sehr wichtig, aber in der Migrationspolitik klare Zeichen zu setzen, aber nicht mit Nazisprache oder Neonazisprache oder AfD-Sprache. So, dieses Interview hat also einen gewissen humoristischen Einschlag, der aber nicht gezeigt werden darf, weil es ein hochernstes Thema ist. Wir allerdings werden das jetzt so ein bisschen entschlüsseln können, alleine durch Zuhören. Also Knut Abraham wird im Deutschlandfunk auf diese Grenzkontrolle zu Polen angesprochen und er wird gefragt, ist die nicht eigentlich falsch, weil wirtschaftliche Einbrüche, wenn die ganzen LKWs da rumstehen und so weiter.
Knut Abraham von der CDU ist Mitglied des Deutschen Bundestags und Polen bei Auftrag der Bundesregierung und mit ihm habe ich am Abend gesprochen. Herr Abraham, Sie finden die Grenzkontrollen falsch und richtig zugleich. Das müssen Sie uns bitte erklären.
Ja, falsch und richtig zugleich. Erklären Sie uns das mal. Da ist jetzt nicht Robin Alexander in der Pflicht, das zu erklären, sondern das muss jetzt Knut Abraham, von dem wir noch nie gehört haben.
Daran vielleicht zunächst ist falsch.
Also falsch ist zu stark, aber es ist eine große Belastung für die Verflechtungsräume im deutsch-polnischen Grenzbereich. Verflechtungsräume, die in 35 Jahren intensivster Arbeit entstanden sind, die auch historische Räume wieder vereinigen und vor allen Dingen Wirtschaftsräume sind. Und für die ist eine Grenzkontrolle und vor allen Dingen auch beiderseitige Grenzkontrollen eine Belastung im täglichen Ablauf.
Can also sehr gut darstellen bis hierhin, würde ich sagen. Jetzt muss er natürlich das Aber anfügen.
Ich will nur ganz kurz sagen, als ich dort in Bayern auf dem Podium saß, mit den Unternehmern und die alle von Bürokratieabbau sprachen, habe ich gesagt, naja, sie schaffen ja jetzt sehr viel Bürokratie mit dieser Migrationspolitik. Ich saß da neben einem CSU-Generalsekretär, da kommen dann kaum Reaktionen. Aber wir hören das jetzt, die über Jahre wurden diese Verflechtungen erst mal geschaffen. Und jetzt?
Ja, jetzt kommt das große Aber.
Und zwar ist der Punkt dabei, die Unberechenbarkeit. Dass man eben einfach nicht weiß, wie lange dauert ein Grenzübertritt und wie kompliziert ist das. Richtig sind die Grenzkontrollen deswegen, weil wir ein deutliches Zeichen hinaus senden müssen, dass sich die Migrationspolitik, Symbolpolitik würde ich damit sagen. mit der neuen Bundesregierung verändert hat. Und zwar so, dass klar wird, dass Deutschland eben nicht mehr das Ziel für jedermann und jede Frau sein kann, die ein neues Leben in Europa beginnen will. Und das müssen wir dokumentieren. Und das dokumentieren wir eben auch durch diese Grenzkontrollen, so schwierig das für die Verflechtungsräume auch ist.
Ja gut, das geht nicht zu einem unorthodoxen Vorschlag. Und zwar öffne ich ja jeden Morgen kurz bild.de. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dir auch so geht.
Nein. Oh Gott. Sehe ich irgendwie krank aus oder so?
Na du hörst die Podcast dieser Leute. Ich gucke nur mal ganz kurz, was ist da? Und da ist Folgendes, seit jetzt, seit dem Märzantritt zu beobachten. Es gibt sehr regelmäßig, ich will nicht sagen täglich, aber doch sehr häufig, direkt als Allererstes wird ein Flugzeug fotografiert und dann steht da wieder 40 heimgeschickt nach Afghanistan oder sonst was, Bundesregierung greift durch, Flieger geht noch heute Nacht los. Also immer so etwas und es ist immer so ein Flieger abgebildet. Und das ist genau das, wir müssen mal Symbolpolitik machen, wir müssen ein Zeichen setzen. Und das hat mich natürlich auf diese wunderbare Idee gepaart. Also das reicht ja offenbar. Man müsste jetzt, weil man natürlich sieht, das ist ein Fiasco, was man da produziert mit dieser Abschiedespolitik. Also erst mal menschenrechtlich sowieso, aber auch wirtschaftlich und bürokratisch und so weiter. Ich glaube, das Sinnvollste wäre jetzt beim BER, das ist ja gut erreichbar für die Journalisten, mietet mal ein Rollfeld und dann nimmt man Schauspieler mit Migrationshintergrund, die setzen sich immer in so einen Flieger rein, dann werden Fotos gemacht, hier werden sie wieder weggepackt, dann fliegt man die einmal rum, dann kommen die auf der anderen Seite wieder rein, und am nächsten Morgen macht man wieder so eine Show, und immer sind die von der Bildzeitung da, fotografieren das und vermitteln den Leuten alles super, die Regierung greift durch. Und dann könnte man sich tatsächlich mal vernünftig um die Sache irgendwie kümmern und könnte vor allem diese albernen Grenzkontrollen fallen lassen. Also es geht nur um dieses Zeichen. Es geht darum und die Bildzeitung hat sich offenbar jetzt auch entschieden, jeden einzelnen Flug journalistisch zu begleiten. Wir wissen ja, vorher gab es ja diese Flüge auch schon. Dann war aber immer so, das reicht noch nicht. Warum hat FASER nicht noch fünf weitere Flugzeuge zur Verfügung gestellt?
Aber jetzt ist man so ganz darauf gepolt, das immer positiv darzustellen und jeder Abschiebeflug ist ein Guter und so was. Und ich finde, man sollte jetzt einfach, wo die Journalisten solche Diskurse faken, sollte man auch in die andere Richtung faken und sagen, seht hier her, wir haben hier wieder was ganz Tolles, ihr könnt wieder fotografieren.
Man hätte ja die 40 abgeschobenen auch auf 40 Tage verteilen können, statt jetzt alle in ein Flugzeug zu sein. Es ist halt dumm, mit Jahr gesehen, was das Zeichen angeht. Ja, aber dieser Knut Abraham ist jetzt hier in dieser bedränglichen Lage, Robin Alexander Forderungskatalog als Beraterleistung entgegenzunehmen und das irgendwie auf die Straße zu kriegen. Und ja, natürlich kann ich nachfragen.
Polen, Herr Abraham hat gesagt, sie sind bereit, diese Kontrollen auf unserer Seite zumindest wieder zu beenden. Wenn auch Deutschland darauf verzichtet, sollte die Bundesregierung darauf eingehen.
Dieser Tag wird kommen und ich hoffe, dass er bald kommt. Aber ich kann Ihnen sagen, dass dieser Moment noch nicht gekommen ist.
So, jetzt kommt wieder die Erklärung, warum. Also bis hierhin, ja, der kommt auf jeden Fall der Tag, weil sie ja voll Recht und überhaupt so.
Weil die Bildseite noch 40 Mal was fotografieren muss oder so.
Genau, genau, wir müssen noch ein bisschen das Bild etablieren.
Denn wir müssen weiterhin deutlich klar machen, dass wir eben migrationspolitisch anders unterwegs sind, als in den vergangenen Jahren und Jahrzehnten. Und dieser Prozess hält noch an. Aber ich hoffe sehr, dass es bald möglich sein wird, beiderseits auf die Kontrollen zu verzichten.
Ja, auch da. Da könnte man einen schönen embedded Journalismus machen. Man macht eine Grenze. Dort können die sich ja auch so richtig dann maskieren in Montur, wie die dann kontrollieren. Ja, das ist auch so ein bisschen wie ganz früher ist noch. Und da sagen wir dann, hier wird ganz hart kontrolliert. Und woanders macht man sie schon alle wieder auf. Also ich glaube, vor allen Dingen, wir haben schon häufig darüber geredet. Diese Zeichen, die gesetzt werden, Sybode, die gezeigt werden und all das. Wir wissen, dass die Leute, die am meisten gegen Migration sind, am wenigsten Migranten sehen.
Genau.
So.
Also eindeutige Korrelation. Die ändert sich. Die brauchen nur Medienspektakel.
Im Alltag ja gar nichts. Sie sagen nicht, ich sehe schon, sind 15 weniger geworden oder so. Die sehen ja ohnehin keine. Das heißt, die brauchen nur ein mediales Spektakel. Und wir haben aber ein Journalismus.
AI-Slop wäre die Lösung.
Genau, AI-Slop ist die Lösung. Wir haben nur Journalisten, die die ganze Zeit zu tun, als ginge es jetzt wirklich darum, irgendwelche Zahlen zu wissen, von den Zahlen wissen die gar nichts. Man hat ja auch schon herausgefunden, wenn man diese Leute dann manchmal befragte über Migrationsanteile oder irgendwas, sie wussten ja nichts. Also sie wissen nicht, wie groß Deutschland ist und sie wissen auch nicht, wie viele Migranten oder sonst wer hier wohnt.
Wir haben gleich noch ein anderes Beispiel für AI-Slop. Also wie man das journalistisch angehen kann, was in deine Richtung geht, aber eher ungewollt von denen. Aber wir können dann auch eine Beratelleistung draus machen.
Ich stelle es mir auch so ein bisschen vor wie eine Schlingensief-Aktion. Schlingensief hat doch, damals, ich empfehle das sehr, das gibt es auch noch auf DVD, vielleicht auch im Netz, das hieß Ausländer raus. Das war so ein Container, den hatte er in Wien aufgestellt wie Big Brother. Und dann sagte er, die Österreicher wollen ja sowieso, die Ausländer los werden, wollen abschieben. Und jetzt haben sie hier die Möglichkeit, hier sind die drin. Und jetzt, wen sollen wir zuerst abschieben? Und das ist eigentlich die Symbolpolitik, die natürlich Schlingensief persifiliert hat, die wir jetzt hier reale Teilen.
Es geht ja nur darum, Aufmerksamkeit zu fesseln. Es ist ja genau wie, dass diese Abschiebeflüge immer gerade dann stattfinden, wenn so ein Koalitionsausschuss tagt, damit man einfach so ein Publikumsflow hat, sagt man dann unter Profis. Robin Alexander macht jetzt ein nächstes Kapitel auf, nachdem er uns vorher mit seinem Buch und so weiter darauf gebracht hat, okay, hier ist irgendwas mit Migrations- und Wirtschaftspolitik. Eigentlich braucht man gute wirtschaftliche Grundlagen. Dafür bräuchte man eigentlich demografische Gegebenheiten, die man aber dann wieder abräumen muss durch eine inhaltlich überzeugende Migrationspolitik, aber ohne Nazisprech. Eigentlich schonmal unlösbares Paradox. Robin Alexander berichtet jetzt von einer Präsentation, von der er gehört hat, die er sehr schlüssig fand, denn es geht ja immer noch darum, die AfD abzuwehren. Und manchmal denke ich mir, ja, das ist der Zeitgeist, die Palästinenser müssen wirklich sterben, damit man sieht, dass sie verhungern. Also wie Daniel Gerlach das eigentlich so androhte. Aber nein, es muss wahrscheinlich wirklich passieren einfach, bis man sieht, ah ja, ne stimmt krass, die waren wirklich vom Hunger bedroht, weil jetzt sind sie tot. So, also eins plus eins scheint zwei zu sein. Robin Alexander, die AfD muss jetzt selber ihre Strategie explizit ausgesprochen haben, damit Robin Alexander mal versteht, worum es geht.
Jetzt auf der Fraktionsklausur hat Beatrix von Storch eine Präsentation vorgestellt. Also so eine 30-seitige Powerbräuen-Präsentation. Und Beatrix von Storch ist die stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende. Also die ist keine Figur vom Rand. Die ist eine Figur vom Zentrum. Und diese Präsentation, die Sie, wenn Sie sich dafür interessieren, als Hörer bei Politico finden, oder der Politikwissenschaftler Johannes Hillier hat die, glaube ich, auch auf Twitter gestellt.
So, wir sind also schon mal angeteased. Da ist eine Präsentation von Beatrix von Storch. Die verrät jetzt das Prinzip. Und es könnte sein, dass die AfD selbst in dieser Präsentation eingesteht, dass die Migrationspolitik von ihr nur als Schiffre benutzt wird. Ach. Für etwas. Also symbolisch. Eine Symbolpolitik. Wir hören uns das mal an.
Ich finde, der zentrale Satz in diesem, man muss es so sagen, klugen Vortrag, also ich habe ihn nicht gehört, ich habe nur die Charts gesehen, aber in dem, was da steht, der zentrale Satz ist, die AfD will, ich zitiere, mittels kultureller Polarisierung die Mitte beseitigen.
Ach, ja, wirklich, Robert Alexander. Das ist ja hochinteressant.
Zitatende. Die Mitte beseitigen, nicht die Mitte erobern, wie andere Parteien formuliert hätten. So, und dazu wird halt kulturelle Polarisierung, also gendern, trans, vegan, ja? Und da will man tatsächlich, der sozusagen die vorgestellte Kluft soll aufgehen zwischen der Union und der Sozialdemokratie und den Grünen auf der anderen Seite. Und das unterscheidet sich von dem bisherigen AfD-Angang. Weil bis jetzt hat die AfD immer gesagt, ihr seid alle Altparteien, ihr seid alle Kartellparteien, Merkel ist auch eine Grüne. Also da war die Kluft zwischen der AfD und allen anderen. Also auch die Union war auf der anderen Seite. Und nach diesem Vortrag ist die Idee halt, du brichst die Mitte auf mit diesen kulturellen Themen, die die Leute so erregen, legst dann nach mit Wirtschaftspolitik auch interessant.
Der Union den Markenkern soziale Marktwirtschaft streitig machen.
Ja genau, also das sind jetzt meine Worte, aber du sagst der Union immer, ihr wollt doch eigentlich was anderes. Also wir wissen doch beide, ihr habt keinen Bock auf linke Wirtschaftspolitik und wir schmieren das euch immer wieder aufs Brot. Also du brichst es auf bei der Kultur und du schiebst es dann nach bei der Wirtschaft. So ist die Idee, wie du die Mitte zerstörst. Und natürlich ist die Idee, wenn die Mitte zerstört ist, hast du bürgerlich-konservativ, wie die das nennen, also du hast einen Blog AfD Union und auf der anderen Seite, was die Linksradikalen nennen, SPD, Grüne und alles weitere. Und es ist wirklich interessant, dass sie offen sich dazu bekennen, sie wollen nicht nur die Union nach rechts ziehen, sie wollen auch die SPD und die Grünen nach links ziehen. Und ich glaube, das kann man Perfine nennen, aber dumm ist es nicht.
Ja, Herr Alexander, also jenseits der Weltleitartikel, in denen der CDU immer untergejubelt wurde, also ihr müsstet eigentlich mal voll die krasse Migrationspolitik machen, aber eigentlich ist die Wirtschaftspolitik so wichtig und so, war eigentlich schon breit diskutiert, auch hier und so, dass die AfD Migration nur als Vehikel benutzt, um halt diesen Spalter da rein zu treiben. Und diese kleine Nuance mit, na ja, unter Merkel hat die AfD die CDU halt noch ins linke Lager einsortiert und jetzt unter Merz schiebt sie sie ins rechte Lager, weil ihr das eine Machtoption gibt. Ja, so ist das halt, wenn man von 7 Prozent auf 23 anwächst, dass man dann irgendwann eine Machtoption braucht.
Ja, und mit Merkel hätten sie niemals koalieren können, weil dann hätten wir das feindliche Feindbild in die Arme geschlossen. Und das geht nur so. Und dass die Migranten da vorgeschoben werden, um einen Kulturkampf noch mal zu hinsenden.
Für Rommel Alexander ist das eine ganz neue Erkenntnis im Juli 2025. Weil die AfD selber mal gesagt hatte, was sie da tut. Jetzt plötzlich hat er das in sein Denken inkorporiert.
Aber erst mal sagt sie ja, das ist schon die ganze Zeit. Und es geht ja darum, die Mitte anzugreifen und diese Merkel-CDU zu zerstören. Und das gelingt ja auch offenbar ziemlich gut, was wir sehen können, ohne dass sie jetzt gerade mitregiert. Und jetzt mal über die Migrationsfrage nochmal. Wenn wir uns doch ansehen, wer jetzt an der Spitze der AfD so unterwegs ist. Es gibt ja immer diese Unterscheidung, die auch dann jemand wie Höcke aufgegriffen hat, aber die auch in linken Diskursen vertreten ist oder in bürgerlichen Diskursen. Also zwischen den Somewheres und den Anywheres. Also die Somewheres sind die, die an einem festen Ort sind. Die sind da zu Hause und die wollen da bleiben. Und die fühlen sich nicht mehr repräsentiert etc. Dann gibt es die Anywheres, die sind zu Hause in Konferenzhotels, an Bahnhöfen, an Flughäfen.
Heimat ist der Laptop.
Der Heimat ist der Laptop und man kennt gute Restaurants und trifft sich dort etc. Wenn man sich jetzt ansieht, die AfD-Spitze, dann leben die ja alle nicht wie die Kubitschecks mit ihren Ziegen zusammen irgendwo im Kaff, sondern die leben wie die Anywheres. Das Leben von Maximilian Krah gleicht dem Leben eines anderen Spitzenpolitikers, eines Topökonomen, eines vielgefragten Podcasters oder Schriftstellers oder sonst was, bis aufs Haar. Die sind in denselben Hotels, denselben Lokalen überall zusammen und sie werden dort sehr häufig auf Migranten treffen. Entweder weil die dort zu Gast sind oder weil sie zum Personal gehören. Natürlich haben die eine völlig andere Lebenswelt und müssen aber diese völkische Geschichte so gerade, so unglaublich hochhalten, weil das natürlich das Potenzial ist, mit dem sie die Wähler bekommen können. Aber das kann einem doch nicht jetzt erst einleuchten.
So, ich stelle mir mal vor, wir würden den KRA, sagen wir mal in zwei Jahren, wenn dann so die März-Regierung ist zerbrochen, es lag auch an Spanern, da die Fraktion nicht organisiert, wie auch immer, man konnte sich den dritten Fopar nicht erlauben, und dann sitzt KRA einfach als Polenbeauftragter da und sagt genau dasselbe. Ja, wirtschaftlich ist das alles ganz wichtig, aber wir müssen hier auch Zeichen setzen. Die Grenze muss halt zu. Und dann der Deutschlandfunk so, ja, okay, dann vielen Dank für das Interview. Ja, also semantisch ist das alles schon angekommen. Also wie du sagtest, die AfD regiert eigentlich schon. Da wird einfach eine Grenze geschlossen. Man will ja so ein Zeichen setzen. Die Wähler sind doof. Da kann man ja auch wenigstens machen. Da muss halt ein Zeichen gesetzt werden und so. Und jetzt muss man sich mal entscheiden. Also wir lösen das Paradox jetzt einfach auf zwischen Wirtschaft und Migrationspolitik, das nicht in der Art und Weise unter einen Hut zu bekommen ist, indem wir sagen, dieses Paradox wird nicht aufgelöst, sondern abgelöst. Man muss es hinter sich lassen. So wie ja bei der CDU völlig ersichtlich ist, okay, die sehen schon ein, dass das nur Symbolpolitik ist. Die kann man einfach weglassen. Und wir jetzt bei der AfD auch festgestellt haben, durch den sehr klugen Vortrag von Beatrix von Storch, ohne das hätten wir das ja nie gewusst, dass das auch nur Schiffre-Politik ist. Man braucht halt eine spaltende Dings und dann nimmt man sich halt Migrationspolitik. So, und jetzt muss man entscheiden, ob man jetzt wirtschaftlich vernünftig oder halt weiter diese migrationspolitischen Pfade. Und da haben wir zwei Denkangebote. Das eine ist Scott Galloway, der so eine Art Mafalani-Revigration mal durchgerechnet, der in einem Text, den er geschrieben hat, den er sich auf Proff.G da einfach vorlesen lässt von so einem Typen. Also es sind Scott Galloways Worte, aber man hört ihn nicht. Der fedelt einfach so Studienwissen ein. Aber eben wirtschaftliche Studien zum Thema Migrationspolitik. Kann man hier in Deutschland auch einfach mal machen. Einfach mal durchrechnen.
The argument that immigrants are stealing jobs is a lie, told by people who've never built a business or managed a P&L. Immigrants create jobs. They work jobs native-born Americans won't touch. They pay into Social Security but rarely collect. Deporting them is an economic own goal. The Cato Institute estimates the cost of mass deportations could eventually exceed 1 trillion dollars.
Das Cato Institut, also das ist ja jetzt nicht ein linksliberales Institut und selbst die sagen das schon.
Ja, 1 trillion, also 1000 Milliarden, die sind immer bei Billionen.
Projects a 1.2 % drop in GDP, if 1.3 million people are deported, growing to 7 % if deportations hit 8 million. That's not policy, but see above, stupidity, hurting others while hurting yourself.
Also, Eigentor, Dummheit.
Instead of militarizing immigration enforcement, we should be investing against the real challenge. AI.
Und dann nochmal der Nachklar, wenn du dich gegen Jobverlust wehren möchtest, dann KI. Aber nicht Niedriglohnsektor und so weiter. Und wir wissen ja heute, die Trump-Regierungen, die wollen die ja nicht wirklich aus dem Land schmeißen. Die wollen die ins Gefängnis bringen und denen dann anbieten, dass sie für einen Dollar am Tag und so weiter. Also das ist wirklich der Versuch, dort einfach Sklaverei zurückzuholen. Das zweite Denkangebot, also das wäre sozusagen das Kluge. Wir können jetzt einfach sagen, okay, Migrationspolitik, inkorporieren wir jetzt in die Wirtschaftspolitik. Wir rechnen das mal durch und sagen, wir brauchen die. Wir können ja erst recht niemanden rausschmeißen. Und selbst Grenze zu, kein Neuer kommt rein, ist...
Ja, ich will nur gerade das noch aufgreifen, was du sagtest mit den Gefängnissen, die arbeiten dann dort für einen Dollar die Stunde oder sowas. Oder am Tag. Was wir ja hier erleben, ist, dass Winzer oder Bauunternehmen dazu ja übergegangen sind, schon seit langer Zeit aus dem fernen Osteuropa Leute herzuholen, über Sub-Sub-Sub-Unternehmen. Und die arbeiten dann hier. Und wenn sie den Mindestlohn gezahlt bekommen, dann wird ihnen aber abgezogen. Und wir wissen, wie das geht. Wir haben das ja auch damals bei den Fleischfabrikanten gesehen. Und ich glaube, dass diese Antimigrationspolitik, die wir jetzt gerade erleben, nicht nur aus der ökonomischen Unvernunft heraus ist im Sinne von, ja, wir treiben die aus dem Land, aber wie stehen wir dann da? Sondern ich glaube auch, dass man mit einer solchen Verschärfung einfach nochmal die Rechte derer, die hier dann auch zu Gast sind, um hier zu arbeiten, nochmal drücken kann, dass man plötzlich nochmal mehr Nachfrage nach diesen Kräften auch schafft, die nämlich dann nicht mehr hier im Land sind, sondern die werden dann aus Rumänien oder so hergeholt. Dort gibt es irgendwelche Subunternehmen und die werden dann hier nochmal eingesetzt. Und wahrscheinlich gibt es dann nochmal eine Sonderregelung, warum dann noch nicht mal mehr der Mindestlohn gezahlt werden muss und all das. In diese Richtung geht das ja. Und bei den Winzern ist es, glaube ich, jetzt auch verboten worden, dass sie die Kost und Logie anrechnen können. Und sofort wird dann geklagt, ach, jetzt wird es aber so teuer und so weiter. Und ich glaube, dass auch das, also diese Art des Kolonialismus und der Neosklaverei nochmal zu betrachten sein wird in der nächsten Zeit, wenn sich das nämlich so verschärft, dass man natürlich auf Arbeitskräfte noch weiterhin zugreifen will, aber denen dann noch weniger Recht und weniger Geld zugesteht. Und dass das dann auch ein amerikanisches Vorbild gerade ist, das wir da beobachten.
Wir haben ja auch das Urteil des Bundesarbeitsgerichts. Das sagt, die 800.000 osteuropäischen Frauen, die hier privat Pflege leisten für ein Tausender im Monat. Das heißt eigentlich alles Mindestlohn. Noch nie wurde eingesetzt, so wenig durchgesetzt durch Zollpolizei oder wem auch immer wie dieses. Weil dann wäre einfach Ende Gelände. Das ist alles nicht gut. So, also das eine ist, einpreisen, verrechnen, politisch ehrlich einen Umgang oder halt das Land vor die Wahl stellen oder halt die Growth. Oder aber Mark Cuban macht den Demokraten das Denkangebot.
Democrats try to extrapolate. Everything that Democrats talk about is an extrapolation. If Trump did this, you know, and in their mind, they're extrapolating, then the normal conclusion is hell is freezing over at some level or another. Republicans deal with the here and now. You know, they're eating cats and dogs. They're coming to your neighborhood to eat your cats and dogs. There's no question mark about whether or not there's going to be, whether or not they want you to have a visceral experience. Democrats want you to think. They want you to understand what they envision and get you there. Republicans, you know, they're taking your jobs. That's what immigrants do. DEI is keeping your husband, your son, your wife, your daughter from getting a promotion. Those are here and now things that people can, whether it's true or not, assign to themselves and say, this really could impact me.
Also, wenn man sagt, die Immigranten nehmen halt deinen Job, Punkt. Wir reden darüber nicht. Du willst nachdenken? Nee, wir machen hier kein Denkangebot. Wir sagen einfach, wie es ist. Wir verlagern alles in dem Moment. Keine Konzepte, nur noch Köpfe und so weiter. Und da würde ich sagen, nee, lieber volkswirtschaftlich durchrechnen. Ich glaube, davon ist dann allen mehr geholfen. Diesen Mark Cuban Weg sollte man da nicht einschlagen. Und jetzt ein Denkangebot meinerseits. Angelika Hellemann ist Bildvize, Chef, Politik, irgendwas.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich habe noch nie gehört.
Sie war bei Ronzheimer im Podcast. Denn Ronzheimer interessierte sich dafür, warum ist die Richterwahl nicht so schiefgegangen. Und dann war ja ganz schnell die Losung. Ja, der Spaner hat seine Fraktion nicht ordentlich organisiert und da gab es so Vorbehalte. Und wir wissen aber heute, die Vorbehalte waren, die haben alle zu viel News gelesen oder sowas. Also irgendwie so ein Scheiß. Also wir denken, okay, die haben schon wirklich das Denken eingestellt. Dann kommen sie irgendwie mit ihrem Plagiatsvorwurf und so weiter. Sie hat von ihrem Mann abgeschrieben, der drei Jahre später einen Text geschrieben hatte und so. Also lauter so blödes Zeug, wo man nur eine Sekunde drüber nachdenkt und denkt, nee, das passt irgendwie nicht. So, jetzt hast du uns schon über AI. Slop aufgeklärt in der Kulturszene. Ich würde sagen, wir haben auf jeden Fall ein Fabulierungsproblem in der politischen Berichterstattung. Wir hören uns jetzt mal hier eine Minute 30, also ich würde es nicht zu kurz machen, wie Angelika Hellemann uns vermittelt, wie die CDU-Fraktion funktioniert und warum die Richterwahl nicht funktioniert hat. Und ich denke mir so, wenn ich das höre, das ist so viel menschliche Spekulation, obwohl die sonst nie erlaubt ist. Also wir wollen wirklich genau wissen, wie viele Leute in Gaza vom Hunger bedroht sind, damit wir nicht ein Brot zu viel da abwerfen, weil könnte ja sein, dass ein Hamas-Typ eins isst oder so. Also nirgendwo ist menschliche Spekulation erlaubt. Alles muss handfest bewiesen werden und so. Außer hier. Was glaubt die Bild, wie die CDU-Fraktion funktioniert? Das ist reinste Küchenpsychologie. Das ist einfach nur mit Vehemenz vorgetragene absolute Dummheit, die wir jetzt hören. Und da liegt aber für mich eine Einflugschneise, um zu sagen, wenn die Leute einfach nur so eine Ansprache haben wollen, können wir ihnen erinnerlich alles unterjubeln. Wir hören also hier in der Methode, finde ich, so kann man es machen, also jeden Morgen einfach 20 Podcasts aus allen Richtungen, aber halt mit anderen Themen. Dass es nämlich methodisch funktioniert, Leuten einfach den größten Scheiß zu verkaufen, das hören wir mal hier. Also Frau Angelika Hellemann, warum hat jetzt diese Richterwahl nicht funktioniert?
Wie wird da argumentiert in solchen Gesprächen?
Also wie wird argumentiert in solchen Gesprächen, in der der Fraktionschef noch mal die Fraktion auf sich einschwört.
Es ist ganz unterschiedlich, man versucht eben auf diese Leute einzugehen und dann kommt es ganz drauf an, ob das jemand ist, der kämpfen will und der böse ist. Manche wollen aber auch gestreichelt werden und wollen ihre Bedenken sehen. Also am meisten ist es so, weil man ja...
Also sie redet nicht darüber, wie man Dreijährigen im Kindergarten das Essen reicht, wenn es nicht schmeckt, sondern es geht ja darum...
Der eine spuckt es aus, der andere macht das.
Es geht ja darum, wie eine Fraktionsspitze die Fraktion auf die Linie bringt, bei einer Entscheidung, die eigentlich durch alle Gremien schon durchgelaufen ist.
Tatsächlich einen Abgeordneten nicht zwingen kann, vor allen Dingen kann man ihn nicht kontrollieren, wenn er in einer Geheimwahl abstimmt. Da wird dann eher so das Prinzip des Schamierens eingesetzt. Und man überlegt doch mal, ich höre dir zu und ich teile ja auch deine Bedenken, aber es geht doch um was Größeres und was auch immer gesagt wurde oder nicht immer, aber bei einigen Leuten, naja.
Also das, was jetzt kommt, wurde nicht immer gesagt, also immer nicht immer bei einigen.
Aber mitunter bisweilen schon.
Jetzt hören wir mal, um was es da geht.
Du hast jetzt sozusagen gerade den Lebensschutz bei dir entdeckt und dein Ego, aber überleg dir, wenn die Wahl schiefgeht und wenn das hier alles schiefgeht, wird der Kanzler beschädigt? Unser Kanzler? Möchtest du wirklich Friedrich Merz beschädigen? Ist es das wirklich wert? Also deine Bauchschmerzen für eine Richterin, die entscheidet ja im Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht alleine, die ist eine von acht. Und deinen Fraktionsvorsitzenden Spahn, den beschädigst du auch. Also willst du dich wirklich über unsere Chefs stellen? So, damit wird natürlich auch ein schlechtes Gewissen gemacht, um so zu erzeugen, überleg mal, was das für die Koalition bedeutet, dann kriegen wir viel weniger bei den Sozialdemokraten durch.
Und wenn dann alle brav sind, dann gibt es noch Spaghetti-Eis.
Genau. Also den Leuten wird einfach jeden Morgen in diesem Ronziger-Podcast so, ja, also Berlin läuft so ab, also da werden die Leute so angeguckt, ach du möchtest ein bisschen gestreichelt werden, ja dann kannst du die Richterin bitte mit wählen und so. Also so sollen wir uns irgendwie das politische Geschehen da vorstellen. So, da wir jetzt beim Thema sind, schließe ich das mal noch ab. Also wir hören jetzt nichts weiter zur Richterwahl. Nur zwei Clips von Amin Nassihi.
Ein Soziologe?
Mein Lieblingssoziologe, denn selten habe ich jemanden so, also wirklich, ich verachte das so sehr, was ich da immer höre. Man kann sich nicht in Worte fassen. Und hier auch wieder. Man kann es sich nicht vorstellen. Wir wissen jetzt sehr genau, wie diese Richterwahl ablief, denn es wurde ja am Fernsehen gezeigt. Und zwar auch für alle sichtbar. Typischerweise gibt es diese Abläufe. Da gibt es einen Richterwahl-Ausschuss, der debattiert so ein bisschen. Dann gibt es eine Abstimmung, die um eine Zweidrittelmehrheit. Das ist so koalitionsgetragen. Und danach, im allerletzten Schritt, geht das halt ins große Parlament und wird einfach abgesegnet. Dann wird den Leuten gesagt, das ist die Beschlussvorlage. Wir sind in Deutschland sehr stolz darauf, dass es ein Arbeitsparlament ist. Wir entschuldigen immer, wenn da nicht alle im Parlament sitzen, sich die Reden anhören, weil da wird ja gearbeitet. Und diesmal war es eben so, der Richterwahlausschuss hat eine Beschlussvorlage erarbeitet, die plötzlich aber nichts mehr galt. Sobald es hieß, nee, das ist ja ein Gewissensparlament, da sind ja alle mit ihrem Gewissen verpflichtet und so weiter. Und Merz selbst, nee, also eigentlich gibt es keine Fraktion und Disziplin und überhaupt keine Koalition, das steht ja nirgendwo. Die sind alle nur dem Gewissen verabschiedet. Also völlig dumm. Aber der reguläre Weg...
Zumal wir nochmal ganz kurz darauf hinweisen, diese Äußerungen da bezüglich Lebensschutz und soetwas. Die Richterin wäre nicht in einem Amt gewesen, in dem sie hätte darüber alleine befinden können. Ja, noch nicht mal war sie überhaupt in diesem Bereich.
Sie war gar nicht für diesen Sinn abgesehen.
Wo das eine Rolle gespielt hätte. Also nur, um das nochmal durchzumachen. Das war nicht das Thema. Weshalb diese Geschichte jetzt, das komme ich mal mit meinem Gewissen daher, ohnehin eine sehr fragwürdige Argumentation ist.
Das sagst du so. Aber jetzt bin ich natürlich getriggert, noch einen Clip zusätzlich zu spielen. Wolfgang Bosbach im Ronzheimer Podcast.
Aber bei bioethischen Fragen ist es sogar in der Regel...
Die Richterbestellung ist eine bioethische Frage, weil sie fraust ja aus Biologie, weißt du?
Das gilt so, dass es gar keinen Fraktionszwang, den es eigentlich gar nicht geben dürfte, in der Praxis gibt.
Es wurde nämlich über den Paragraph 218 abgestimmt im Bundestag. Eine bioethische Frage. Da wurde noch nie die CDU-Fraktion von ihrem Gewissen abgehalten. Ach so. Deswegen fragt man sich so ein bisschen. Aber die Angela Helligermann hat mir doch gerade erzählt, warum die Fraktion auf Linie gebracht wurde. Und jetzt im selben Podcast, das ist eine bioethische Frage, da wird niemand auf Linie gebracht. Ja, also man kommt nur auf solche Paradoxien. Okay, wir hören das mit Bossbach nicht zu Ende. Wir kommen jetzt zu Amin Azei. Amin Azei sitzt im Table Media Podcast. Und ich konnt's nicht glauben, also. Alle Verfahren wurden eingehalten, bis Jens Spahn vermelden musste, Shit, ich hab meine Fraktion nicht auf Linie. Obwohl das voll die Erwartung war, völlig zu Recht von allen, die da beteiligt sind. Journalistisch, politisch, verwaltungstechnisch, wie auch immer.
Und du hast ja eben auch sehr gut gesagt, da haben sehr viele ein bisschen zu viel News geguckt und gelesen. Und ja, das ist ja genau so, dass es immer diese Strömungen dann gibt, die Journalistischen, die dann so versuchen, eine Kampagne zu fahren. Und mal verfängt sie, mal verfängt sie nicht. Hier verfügen sie sehr gut. Dann war das auch ein bisschen zu kompliziert, wahrscheinlich für einige, um dazu erkennen, okay, für welchen Senat und so ist sie zuständig. A, Bioethik, Abtreibung. Ah nee, da bin ich ja von der CDU dagegen. Also Schluss. So, das sind ja diese Kurzschlüsse, die gemacht werden.
Genau, diese Art von Kurzschluss oder Komplexitätsreduktion ist ja eigentlich die Funktion einer Beschlussvorlage aus dem daran arbeitenden Ausschuss und nicht von News.
Ja, aber die haben News konsumiert und brauchen ein paar andere.
So, und jetzt, nach diesem ganzen Theater, sagt Amin Nasehi Folgendes.
Also ich glaube ja doch, dass das, was wir so die politische Mitte nennen, viel mehr Argumente hätte in verschiedenen Politikfeldern und die auch kontrovers austragen könnte, wenn man sich nicht so sehr hochfort, sagen wir mal, treiben lassen würde, durch diese Eskalationsstrategie. Ich weiß, das ist vielleicht ein naiv, wenn ich das so sage, aber es gibt ja manchmal Hinweise darauf, was mich zum Beispiel in den letzten Tagen beeindruckt hat. Das war, dass der Bundeskanzler angesichts der ganzen Diskussionen um die Wahl von neuen Verfassungsrichterinnen und Richtern versucht hat, Dampf aus der Debatte zu nehmen und vielleicht darauf hinzuweisen, dass es hier in diesem Punkt nicht um das aller, allerletzte Ganze geht, sondern auch Verfahrensfragen eingehalten werden müssen. Das sind sozusagen Versuche, sich dieser kulturkämpferischen Situation zu entziehen. Davon brauchen wir mehr und es geht nicht nur um atmosphärisches, sondern es geht tatsächlich auch darum, Inhalte so darzustellen, dass das vielleicht mehr an der Lebenswirklichkeit der Menschen ist.
Also derjenige, dem wir jetzt eine Woche lang erzählen mussten, sorry, aber wir haben hier eigentlich ein Verfahren. Das wäre cool, wenn wir das auch einhalten, denn dafür sind Verfahren da, deswegen machen wir das. Das haben wir auch immer so gemacht. Und jetzt kriegt er plötzlich Lob von Amin Nasehi, weil dieser Bundeskanzler, der so viel Appell und Hinweise auf, sorry, aber wir haben ja eigentlich Verfahren, weil der selbst nochmal sagte, ich habe hier Verfahren.
Nachdem er es erst überhört hat, tagelang.
Wie kann man zu so einer Einschätzung kommen? Also ich verstehe das einfach wirklich nicht. Es überragt mein intellektuelles Fassungsvermögen, wie man als Soziologe so dasitzen kann. Also geht es da wirklich, ist es so profan, dass er sich einfach die Beraterjobs erhalten lassen möchte, von März weiter einladbar sein. Aber selbst das wäre doch irgendwie zu doof, oder? Also es ist wirklich schräg. Aber macht es auch im zweiten Punkt nochmal.
Also ich will jetzt nicht zu positiv über Friedrich März sprechen, aber es scheint ja auch Lernkurven zu geben und Erfahrungsmöglichkeiten zu geben. Das kann man relativ deutlich sehen im Moment. Und es ist natürlich auch die Frage, dass einem der Laden um die Ohren fliegt, wenn man es jetzt nicht gelingt, da die Emotionen so ein bisschen runterzufahren. Wir haben es ja leider doch im Teil der veröffentlichten Meinung mit Eskalationsunternehmern zu tun, die natürlich davon profitieren mit Totalkritik und der, sagen wir mal, in Fragestellung von allem, auch der Verfahren selbst, sowas wie eine Systemkritik zu machen. Mich erinnert das fast so ein bisschen wie so die K-Gruppen in den 70er Jahren. Für die die größten Feinde eigentlich, die Sozialdemokraten waren, also die Mitte Linkspartei.
So, also er beschreibt jetzt das Phänomen, da gibt es Protestunternehmer, das ist also News und die haben dann Kundschaft und das ist die CDU-Fraktion und eigentlich kann man jetzt, sollte es im Schluss kommen, das könnte man jetzt mal aufarbeiten, das ist irgendwie doof gelaufen, so geht es nicht weiter, ja, aber jetzt kommt seine Schlussfolgerung.
Und die sind wie die Linksparteikratikaten in den 70er Jahren.
Ja, genau, genau.
Weil die auch so reich damit geworden sind, wie wir wissen.
Genau, das auch. Den Teil blende ich jetzt mal aus. Also wir haben dieses aktuelle, diese Diagnose, okay, da sind irgendwelche Leute auf News reingefallen, die CDU-Fraktion, deswegen kam es nicht zu und so weiter. Und sie haben von dem eigentlichen Verfahren abgewichen, haben gesagt, nee, News ist jetzt unsere Beschlussvorlage und so. Und jetzt Schlussfolger, er hat es ja gerade so beschrieben, jetzt kommt die Schlussfolgerung von Amina See.
Die größten Feinde dieser Eskalationsunternehmer ist sozusagen die große Mitte Rechtspartei, also die Union. Und die kann sich nicht dagegen wehren, indem sie gegen die argumentiert, sondern indem sie sachlich ihre Dinge macht. Und ich hoffe, dass man dahin zurückkehren kann. Das ist das Einzige, was die Menschen wollen. Wir wissen das übrigens aus Umfragen ziemlich genau, nicht irgendwie den großen Helden, der alle Probleme löst, sondern das Gefühl zu haben, dass da eine Kompetenz ist, der man irgendwie vertrauen kann. Vertrauen heißt nicht, auf jedes Detail zu gucken.
So, Friedrich Merz ist jetzt der Kandidat der Kompetenz und des Vertrauens.
Der die Verfahren hat.
Genau, der sich auch ein bisschen nicht allzu sehr in dieses starke Männerding verliert. Das machen ja die anderen alle, sondern er ist jetzt der Gegenpol. Kompetenz und das Vertrauen. Ich denke so, nee, selbst...
Das war Merkel, so nannt man die.
Also jemand, der ins Amt kommt mit diesem Arich Arbiri, mal die AfD, und dann stellt man so fünf Jahre später, ja, das lag ja alles an der Ampel und so weiter. Am Tag eins mache ich das und das, und es ist mir auch egal, wer den Weg mit mir geht und so. Das ist doch genau dieser starke Mannkreis.
Ich will Dekrete, ja, der macht ja diese Dekretpolitik von Trump.
Wie kann man denn jetzt, genau, von Dobrindt noch eingeredet, dass Dobrindt da, der Alexander Dovalent hier dachte, also die Leute lieben, wie Donald Trump Unterschriften macht. Ich kenne selbst die Leute, die Donald Trump so ein bisschen sympathisch sehen, denken, das ist irgendwie albern so. Nichts davon geht auf. Und dann sagt Amina Siehe, ja, und es ist voll gut, dass wir jetzt so einen Bundeskanzler haben, der sich dagegen stemmt und hier auf Kompetenz und Versachlichung geht. Oh je. Ich versteh sowas nicht. Es ist so schräg. Also es ist wirklich schlimm.
Jetzt springen wir. Ich komme jetzt mit einer Kritik an der Identitätspolitik. Man denkt, ach Gott, jetzt auch noch. Hier in den Neuen Zwanzigern.
Du hast mich beauftragt, eine Art Tätowko zu gucken. Das habe ich natürlich fleißig gemacht gestern.
Ja, das freut mich doch sehr. Und wir machen das. Ich muss es ein bisschen einleiten. Es ist nämlich so, dass ich erst dachte, ist das was für die Neuen Zwanzigern? Habe ich aber länger darüber nachgedacht und dachte, ja doch, es ist so symptomatisch. Deswegen muss man, also erst mal klingt es total spezialistisch. Und dann habe ich auch wieder gesagt, nee, es ist so symptomatisch, dass man daran so viel festmachen kann, dass man eigentlich darüber reden muss. Deshalb sprechen wir jetzt über Amanda Lear. Ich habe dich beauftragt, quasi eine Doku bei Arte dir anzusehen. Die heißt Queen Lear, Das Leben der Amanda Lear, die findet man zum Beispiel bei YouTube. Von Gero von Böhm ist diese Doku, der auch schon die Lagerfeld-Doku gemacht hat.
Schade, dass er die nicht selbst gesprochen hat, jetzt wo ich das weiß.
Doch, am Anfang hört man ihn mal kurz. Wir hören ihn jetzt gleich mal. Es gibt noch eine andere Doku, dazu kommen wir gleich, die ist aber nicht mehr auf Deutsch verfügbar. Deswegen habe ich mich jetzt auch besonders auf diese konzentriert. Diese Doku ist vor ein, zwei Jahren entstanden. Ich leite erst langsam dahin, wo ich eigentlich drauf hinaus will. Wir schaffen zuerst mal einen Überblick. Manche werden wahrscheinlich noch nie von Amanda Leer gehört haben. Das ist sehr bedauerlich. Wir bekommen jetzt mal einen Eindruck.
Ein Mensch auf der Suche nach sich selbst, lebenslang. Immer wieder hat sich Amanda Lear neu erfunden, viele Leben gelebt. Woher sie einst kam, weiß niemand. Geboren in Saigon oder Hong Kong, 1950 oder doch 1939, als Mädchen oder als Junge. Alles Geheimnisse, mit denen sie auch heute noch spielt. In Paris studiert sie Malerei und wird als Model entdeckt. Und sie selbst entdeckt den Ruhm als Triebfeder ihres Lebens. 15 Jahre lang ist sie die Muse von Salvador Dalí. Auch er ein Genie der Selbstvermarktung. Als sie sich von Dalí befreit hat, animiert David Bowie sie zum Singen. Bald beginnt eine Weltkarriere als Disco Queen.
Zeitweise ist sie dann mit David Bowie zusammen. Mit Salvador Dalí war sie nie zusammen. Das war keine erotische Beziehung, sondern die Beziehung des Künstlers zu seiner Muse. Und wir hören schon, also das ist eine hochinteressante, schüttelnde Figur, die dann große Erfolge feierte in Deutschland, Italien, Spanien, Frankreich, aber auch weit darüber hinaus. Und zwar wurde sie überredet, doch mit dem Singen anzufangen. Dann ist sie auf Anthony Monn gestoßen. Der hat auch ein paar Italo-Hits komponiert und sie hat Texte geschrieben. Und er hat dann Musik dazu gemacht. Und ihr berühmtestes Lied heißt Follow Me. Und ich will nur mal kurz den Text sprechen. I'm getting out. I'm moving on. And from now on. Address unknown. I shall be difficult to find. So follow me. Just follow me. Weiter heißt es dann Faust was right. Have no regret. Give me your soul. I give you life. And all the things you want to get. So follow me. Just follow me. Und sie singt das mit einer tiefen Stimme. Und weiter geht es dann mit Unbelievable Maybe You'll Have a New Identity. Das ist dieses permanente Spiel mit der Identität. Es gibt auch ein anderes Lied, sehr berühmt von ihr, The Sphinx. Da heißt es I wish that I could be a silent Sphinx eternally. I don't want any past. Only want things which cannot last. Das ist das ewige Spiel mit der Identität. Amanda Leer hat immer wieder gesagt, Ich bin eine Frau. Diese Gerüchte sind falsch. Aber natürlich war das ewig das Thema. Sie hat im Berlusconi-Fernsehen in Italien große Shows moderiert. Dann in den 80er Jahren, in den 90er Jahren auch. Und in Frankreich hat sie moderiert, hat Shows gemacht. Sie spielt bis heute Theater in Paris. Und ist auch in diesen Shows gern gesehen. In den 90er Jahren noch mal einen kurzen Ausflug nach Deutschland gemacht. Sie hat dort diese Erotik-Sendung Piep moderiert, die auch Verona und Nadel moderiert haben. Aber das mochte sie eigentlich nicht. Sie hat alles gemacht. Du hast das ja gesehen. Diese Doku Tausends, das könnte man sagen.
Es ist ganz irre, denn man sieht ja diese Fernsehausschnitte und sie spricht dann perfektes Französisch, perfektes Italienisch, Englisch. Also ist ja alles im Sinne von wir buchen dich mal und fast wie in der Matrix. Ich bräuchte jetzt mal schnell die Anleitung für und dann kann sie es plötzlich. Das zum einen und dann wird so ganz kurz gesagt und sie sitzt ja in dieser Doku am Tisch und erzählt. Und Gender ist das eine, da würde ich sagen, okay, das ist eine Spielerei, Generation. Ganz kurz wird erwähnt, sie könnte 1950 geboren sein oder 39. Das heißt, sie ist entweder 75 oder 86. Aber sie sitzt da wie eine 40-Jährige und erzählt dann, wie sie vor David Bowie, vor den 15 Jahren, mit Dali, mit den Rolling Stones, als es die noch gar nicht gab, im Grunde so fast.
Ja, ganz am Anfang war sie auch mal in London bei den Rolling Stones. Und hat da, ich glaube, auch irgendwie einmal Drogen beschafft.
Da wurde sie in Verhaft gegeben. Genau, genau, hat sie ihr untergejubelt. Also, es ist wirklich sehr, man sieht das so und kann es gar nicht glauben. Eigentlich sehr mystisch.
Ja, sie berichtet dann auch davon, wie sehr diese geschlechtliche Identität anbricht. Sie sieht sehr gut aus. Und sie hat sich auch für den Playboy in Italien mal ausgezogen, berichtet dann hier.
Bei Amanda Lea weiß man nie genau, was sie eigentlich ist, heißt es immer. Ich habe sogar komplett nackt für den Playboy posiert, für die italienische Ausgabe. Da gab es Wissenschaftler, italienische Ärzte, die haben mein Nacktfoto auf einem Bildschirm vergrößert und meine Schamhaare untersucht. Die Buchsrichtung.
Irre. How were the hair if it was in this direction or in that direction?
Meanwhile, terrible things have happened in the world.
Aber man hat sich lieber damit beschäftigt.
Dali hat sich ja gelobt für ihr Skelett. Er hat ja, das war ja das erste Missverständnis. Du hast so einen schönen toten Schädel.
Ja.
Und so. Ja, da hat sie wahrscheinlich relativ früh einfach mitgedacht.
Es ist ein Spiel mit allem. Aber es gab natürlich auch eine Presse, die ja sagen wir in einer Zeit war, die ganz anders zu diesen Themen eingestellt war. Und wenn man sich das dann ansieht, es gibt zum Beispiel einen Auftritt von ihr in der NDR Talkshow 1976, da wird sie von Carmen Thomas, auch eine berühmte Journalistin und NDR-Frau interviewt. Und die drängt sie dann immer wieder auf diese Frage, obwohl sie da gar nicht darüber sprechen will. Wir hören da mal rein.
You were called John. No, that's what I read. Also ich hab gelesen, dass du früher mal John geheißen hat und wirklich als kleiner Junge auf die Welt gekommen bist.
Geht da nochmal weiter? Also es ist, Minutenlang geht das so.
I look like a man.
Not anymore, but what about when you were a child?
Well, what happened is, maybe they think that my voice, like all the girls sing with sexy voice, they say that's the voice of a man. So in this case, you have lots of men in Germany, like me, you have Hildegard Neff is a man, and Zara Leandro is a man, and Marlene Ditches is a man. I'm afraid it's a little silly.
Also sie sagt, es sei völlig albern, denn dann wären ja Hildegard Knef und Zara Leandro auch lauter Männer, wenn man nämlich nur wegen ihrer tiefen Stimme annehmen würde, sie sei ein Mann.
Stimmt. That's my voice.
That's your voice. What does the word transsexual mean to you at all? Does it have any role in your life? Or is it something you don't like to talk about?
Wir merken, das ist unangenehm, so wort sie immer weiter nach. Aber jetzt kann man ja sagen, okay, ist 1976, warum reden wir jetzt in den 29er darüber? Nun, der Grund ist folgender. Bei HBO gibt es eine neue Doku. Man kommt nicht so einfach dran. Es gibt natürlich immer Mittel und Wege mit VPN und so weiter. Also man wird sie irgendwie sehen können. Ich habe sie auch gesehen. Und ich empfehle sie aber nicht, sie zu sehen, weil ich jetzt ein bisschen berichte, was da eigentlich stattfindet. Diese Doku heißt Enigma. Und wir schauen uns jetzt mal den, hören uns jetzt mal den Trailer an. Diese Doku handelt nämlich auch von Amanda Lear, aber nicht nur von ihr.
The European Queen of Disco, Amanda Lear.
28 million records hat sie verkauft. Denn diese Geschichte wird nicht nur erzählt von Amanda Lear, sondern auch die von April Ashley, die tatsächlich trans war, ein Model war, Und auch erst Karrieremachte, als noch nicht bekannt war, was eigentlich ihre, oder eigentlich ist er falsch gesagt, aber was ihre ursprüngliche geschlechtliche Identität war. Und ja, diese Geschichten werden parallel erzählt.
Are you still an object of curiosity? Oh, I think so. Why do you think they're all staring so intently?
The Carousel, das ist also so ein Club für Transsexuelle gewesen, wo aber viele Prominente waren. Und April Ashley und auch andere aus der Zeit sagen dann, ja, da war ja auch Amanda Lear. Das ist also das Thema an dieser Doku. Sie hat sich immer als Frau gefühlt. Da gab es ja diese kleine Sache noch. Aber eigentlich war sie immer Frau. Und das wurde dann durch eine Scheidung und so alles sehr in der Öffentlichkeit plattgetreten. Und damit hat sie dann auch ihre Modelkarriere verloren.
I knew who I was. But I knew I didn't have long to go before something would happen. And sure enough, the judge ruled that Miss Ashley was biologically male. I went to my agent. April, you know, darling, you will never get another job in this country.
Dagegengeschaltet wird jetzt die Geschichte von Amanda Lear. Und ich finde, erst mal, dass der Film da auch interessant ist, wo er diese Transgeschichte erzählt, erzählt von diesen Pariser Clubs und wer da auch alles sich bis heute dann halten konnte, viel kleiner in der Nische. Aber was hier unternommen wird, ist zu sagen, ja, dann gab es die andere, die hat sich davon losgesagt und das ist Amanda Leigh. Das ist jetzt ihr Regisseur und es spricht?
Think what you're saying, think what you want.
Also, ich finde es sehr faszinierend, dass hier wieder dieses Muster, also es steckt ja ein Interesse dahinter. Ja. Sowohl da in den 70ern, als ihr da interviewt werdet, als auch bis heute, dass HBO das nochmal so macht. Und die Frage ist dann immer, wer hat dieses Interesse und wie zeigt es sich? Denn wir haben ja bei einigen politischen Diskussionen, dass immer dem Einlager unterstellt wird, sie überreden die ganze Zeit, die Leute kein Fleisch mehr zu essen oder sie überreden die ganze Zeit, die Leute diese und jene Worte nicht mehr zu benutzen, nicht zu gendern, wie auch immer und so fort. Nur wirklich ausgelebt wird das ja von der Gegenseite. Also plötzlich macht die CDU Gender und Sprachgesetze und so weiter. Und wenn man jetzt so weit wie Jan Fleischhauer geht und verschiedene Fetisch verteilen will, stellt man auf jeden Fall fest, sie oder die Frauen allgemein sind zwar in der Lage, mit diesen Fragen umzugehen und daraus Kapital zu schlagen, weil sie wird eingeladen und und so weiter kann davon profitieren, nur der Fetisch ist auf der anderen Seite.
Okay.
Aber von Leuten, die dann wieder unterstellen, dass sie eigentlich nur den Fetisch der anderen Seite rauskitzeln wollen, während sie selbst ihren Fetisch komplett ausleben, nämlich hier die ganze Zeit so in der Her zu gehen. Aber was bist du jetzt?
Das ist, und damit beginnt jetzt meine Kritik der Identitätspolitik. Es gibt ja bei Amanda Lear zwei Möglichkeiten. Die eine Möglichkeit ist, Amanda Lear war immer eine Frau und an den Gerüchten ist nichts dran. Dann ist das also eine permanente Unterstellung. Die andere Möglichkeit ist, es ist tatsächlich was dran und sie war in den 60er Jahren in Casablanca und hat diese Geschlechtsangleichung vorgenommen, wie einige in dieser Doku behaupten und wie auch die Regisseurin Zachary Drucker heißt sie, eine Transregisseurin, die ganze Zeit in ihrer Doku suggeriert. Es wird immer nebenher geschnitten. Wenn an der Sache was dran ist, aber Amanda Lear sagt, ich bin eine Frau, dann wäre es ja progressiv zu sagen, wir akzeptieren diesen performativen Akt, zu sagen, ja, ich bin es und da ist nicht irgendwie noch mal jetzt über meine Vergangenheit und so weiter zu reden. Wir haben ja eigentlich diese Debatten darüber, Deadnaming, dass man nicht plötzlich immer wieder Transpersonen konfrontiert, mit dem, was sie mal waren oder was man glaubt, sie gewesen sein. Und interessant ist jetzt und deswegen habe ich das hier ausgewählt, dass das, was wir in den 70er Jahren von konservativer bürgerlicher Seite sehen, dass da so nachgebohrt wird, bist du denn wirklich eine Frau? Dass dies jetzt von der progressiven Seite plötzlich übernommen wird, nämlich eine Transregisseurin, die sagt, ich will da mal die Geschichte erzählen und mir jetzt mal genau nachrauschen. Wir hören jetzt mal Zachary Drucker bei der Filmpremiere in einem kurzen Interview.
Amanda Lear is like my original archetype. When I was 18, I moved to New York City. And my first girlfriend was a huge disco fan. And she was like Amanda Lear. She's famous for being trans and denying it. And when I saw a picture of her, I was struck by her incredible beauty. And hung a picture of her up on my wall. And she's always held a very special place in my imagination and in my own self-conception. So meeting her was just the gift of a lifetime.
Ja, genau. Also da steckt ja nun genau nicht das, was hier geschildert wird, drin. Nämlich, ich in meinem Kinder- und Jugendzeitalter vergötterte sie und war erfasst so. Sondern ich möchte jetzt eine Mission daraus machen. Vielleicht ist sie eine Soldatin auf meiner Seite. Sie muss jetzt raus in die Welt. Ich muss sie entblößen. Und seht ihr, sie war immer nicht eine von euch, gegen euch, so in diesem Maße.
Und das findet jetzt dann statt. Wir hören uns mal so einen kleinen Eindruck aus der Doku an. Und zwar war das so, dass man am Andadier immer unterstellt hat, dass sie unter dem Namen Pekki Doslo aufgetreten ist, wird jetzt wieder damit konfrontiert in diesem Interview. Insofern journalistisch mit der Identität wurde gespielt. Das mal nachzufragen in einer Doku über am anderen hier, ist ja völlig völlig, bei Gero von Böhm geht es ja auch mal darum, oder in dieser anderen Art Doku, natürlich auch geht es darum. Und das ist ja in dieser Weise, wie auch immer mit diesem Mysteriösen gespielt wird, das eine. Aber dass man dann, und ich kann jetzt nicht alle Beispiele aufführen, um Gottes Willen, wir wollen jetzt auch nicht die Demaskierung hier fortsetzen, aber das ist dann immer wieder nachgepfeift. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Dann gibt's eine Szene, in der Zachary Drucker jetzt dann mit einem iPad kommt und lauter Fotos zeigt von Peggy d'Auslaw und diese Amanda Lear zeigt.
That's not me.
No, no, that's not me, baby.
That's not me. That's not me. That's not me.
That's me.
Amanda was just like you.
That's not me.
I'm Amanda.
Es ist diese Mission jetzt zu sagen, du musst jetzt hier auf diese Seite gehen. Es gibt ein bisschen Kritik auch daran. Also Amanda Lee hat sich von der Doku distanziert und sagt, sie wurde dahinter das Licht geführt. Sie wusste nicht, dass das in diese Richtung alles geht. Klar, da wird man tagelang interviewt und dann wird das entsprechend nachher geschnitten. Amelia Majesty beschäftigt sich mit Transthemen bei YouTube, hat die Doku auch gesehen und sagt Folgendes.
It's very clear they're trying to compile and stack up evidence that Amanda Lear is supposedly transgender and confront her on the matter of something she's addressed for decades. They even brought up pre-transition photos to confront her with. In the very same style, cis people interrogate trans people and other cis people they want to transvestigate because they think they're trans. Amanda's truth and story is her own detail, and she's made it very clear she's not trans. So the trans community should respect her.
Genau, die richtige Aussage. Und wir erleben ja gerade von der rechten Seite diese Trans-Investigations. Dann behauptet wird Michelle Obama, Brigitte Macron oder wer auch immer, die seien in Wahrheit früher mal Männer gewesen. Guck mal, wie die geht. Dann werden irgendwelche Fotos aus der Kindheit verglichen. Lauter so einen Unsinn geschieht ja da von dieser Seite. Und wie kann es jetzt sein, dass das von progressiver Seite dann von HBO und so weiter unterstützt geschieht? Nun, es ist ja so, dass wir bei der Identitätspolitik dann ein Problem bekommen, wenn plötzlich die eine Identität über die andere gestellt wird. Und Zachary Drucker legt dann Amanda Lear in einem weiteren Gespräch in dieser Doku nahe, dass sie ja damals Erfolg hatte, weil sie das verschleit hat. Aber heute könnte sie ja noch erfolgreicher sein, wenn sie jetzt auch sich outet dahingeht. Wir haben also eine Situation, bei der man eigentlich plötzlich wieder jemanden auf die Identität festschreiben will und nicht mehr akzeptiert, dass das der performative Akt ist, den Amanda Lear gemacht hat, indem sie sagt, ich erfinde mich jetzt neu und ich werde nicht irgendwas von meinen Eltern erzählen und nicht sagen, wo ich geboren bin. Ich bin die Schöpfung. Damit ist sie wirklich das genuin-moderne Subjekt, das sich von diesen Traditionen löst und eine progressiv getarnte Identitätspolitik tut dann jetzt wieder so, als müsse sie sich wieder genau zu ihrer Herkunft von allen bekennen und wird dann auch nach den Namen der Eltern gefragt. Also man versucht dann auf diese Weise, irgendwas rauszufinden. Und ich glaube, es kommt noch so eine weitere Komponente hinzu. Wir hören aber noch mal ganz kurz in diese Doku rein, Enigma. Das ist doch lustig, dass jetzt nochmal gesagt wird, du hast ja die ganze Zeit darunter gelitten, das weiß ich nicht. Und dann, ja, du bist immer wieder mit dieser Frage konfrontiert worden. Und jetzt wird sie wieder einholen mit der Frage konfrontiert. Wir gehen gerade zu dem nächsten noch über. Dann geht Drucke auf Vorbilder ein, auf Mandalir als Vorbild.
I feel like I am a part of your legacy.
Also was ich ja sehr verstehe, ist, dass man 2025, wenn man selber erst 25 ist, in so einem Modus reingewachsen ist, in der die Welt schon immer von Donald Trump regiert wurde und so weiter und es da so Kampfplätze gibt und man sich behaupten muss, wir müssen so in Linien ziehen und so weiter und wir hätten dich gerne bei uns im Lager, so ne. Aber in dieser Doku, die ich da gestern sah, ist das ja auch super interessant, dass hier einfach so die 60er, die 70er, die 80er und man fragt sich ja auch immer, also wenn da jetzt so eine Disco aufgemacht wird in Paris und so und dann will man irgendwie diesen italienischen Flair da haben und dann bucht man das einfach alles komplett und dann wird ja immer nie erklärt, hat da mal jemand einen Vertrag unterschrieben oder was auch immer, ne. Und mein Eindruck ist dann so manchmal, ja vielleicht, weil das wirklich alles so Handschlag-Deals, wie sich Trump das heute vorstellt. Also, dass man einfach so kam und dann so 10.000 Marke kriegt und wie auch immer so. Und was man auf jeden Fall sieht in diesen Videos, die es dann noch gibt, da wird zum Beispiel gesagt, als in Frankreich, in Paris diese Disco aufgemacht wird, stand die Musik im Mittelpunkt. Also, es war auch so ein kommen und gehen und sich zeigen und wie auch immer und harte Tür und alle sollten schön aussehen, aber drin stand die Musik im Mittelpunkt. Sie wurde also ganz klar für ihre Musik gebucht, ist dann da aufgetreten. Und man schaut sich so das Publikum an. Und könnte, wenn man jetzt Trans-Investigation-mäßig drauf wäre, müsste man jeden zweiten dort entweder, was bist du wirklich, oder warum zeigst du dich so offensichtlich in dem anderen Geschlechtstyp. So, was ja mir nur zeigt, okay, damals, und sie reflektieren das halt in der Musik, aber es gilt eben auch für den politischen Diskurs. Es wird dann einfach erklärt, die Leute wollten neue Musik hören. Und es gab kein Spotify, es gab kein Internet, es gab gar nichts. Man musste in diese Disco gehen, weil da wurde die neue Musik gespielt. Also sind die dahingegangen und haben die neue Musik gespielt, weil davor, bevor die da ankamen, fand nichts statt in Sachen Musik und danach auch nicht. Und genauso ist das ja auch für die Kostümierung, mit der man dort ist. Vorher im Alltag spielt das gar keine Rolle und nach diesem Disco Abend auch nicht. Und das ist ja heute ganz anders. Und deswegen sind die da, also deswegen reflektieren die selber nicht mehr, dass sie jetzt plötzlich so ein Fetisch ausgearbeitet haben, weil sie sich 20 Stunden am Tag damit befassen. Allein durch die eigene Biografie.
Reines Spiel und das hat sie ja von Dali. Ich mein, ein Künstler signiert normalerweise immer gleich, damit man das wieder erkennt. Dali hatte dutzende unterschiedliche Signaturen. Ich mein, das hatte auch zum Teil damit zu tun, dass da schon mal Planko signiert wurde, weil man ein bisschen Geld brauchte. Aber der hat immer auch mit der Signatur wiedergespielt. Also mit dieser eigentlich feststehenden Identität auch nochmal gespielt. Und das hat Amanda Lear selbstredend übernommen. Und wenn ich jetzt aber sehe, dass es gerade einen neuen Dali-Film gibt, ich glaube, letztes Jahr ans Kino gekommen, Dali Land, in dem dann Amanda Lear von einer Trans-Schauspielerin gespielt wird, nur um nochmal so deutlich zu machen. Also ich hab nichts dagegen. Wegen mir sollen alle alles spielen. Das ist ja sowieso meine Position dazu. Ich mag diese Identitätspolitik da überhaupt nicht. Aber dass man ausgerechnet da jetzt in diesem Film sagt, ich mach das jetzt so, um nochmal Amanda Lear zu sagen, aber du bist ja eigentlich so, dann wird plötzlich die Identitätspolitik fundamentalistisch. Und ich glaube, es hängt auch noch was da drin. Wir haben einen letzten Clip dazu.
I don't really know what I can do for them. But I don't know.
I have an idea.
Ja, Amanda, ihr sagt, ich weiß nicht, was soll ich jetzt für die Trans-Girls tun, die du da ansprichst? Und dann sagt sie, ich hab eine Idee. Also klar, oute dich doch einfach dazu. Und was wir hier sehen können, ist etwas sehr Interessantes. Nämlich, wir haben eine eigenartige Diskussion ja darüber jetzt, dass man plötzlich den Leuten, die eine Geschlechtsangleichung anstrengen, dann immer diesen Trans-Status verleiht.
Genau.
Und Amanda Lear, ob sie die jetzt vorgenommen hat, die Angleichung oder nicht, will eine Frau sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob die sonst immer nur bienäher denkt, aber für sie ist das entscheidend. Und wir hatten hier auch mal irgendwann mal Clips gespielt von Sassi de Paris und Romy Haag. Die sehen sich als Frauen fertig. Das ist nicht irgendwie so. Und das muss man auch akzeptieren. Man kann nicht jetzt immer wieder anfangen, aber da will ich das noch sein und du soll... Wir haben jetzt gerade die politische Richtung, deswegen musst du diese identifizieren. Ich finde das ganz merkwürdig. Und es ist gut, dass dann jemand wie Amelia Majesty genau dagegen spricht und sagt, also hör zu, genau das muss man akzeptieren, wenn das so ist. Und gerade dann lässt man ja auch alle Freiräume, die man eigentlich haben kann. Nämlich dann kann man sich wirklich gestalten, dann wird man wirklich gelöst von einfach nur biologischen Gegebenheiten oder sonst etwas.
Ja und wer damit spielen will, kann ja auch damit spielen. Also es heißt ja nicht ohne Grund Drag, also Dressed as a Girl. Und das unterscheidet sich von Girl. Und wenn man sich wie ein Mädchen anzieht, kann man auch eine Frau sein und sich dann trotzdem nochmal in die Schuluniform von Britney Spears schmeißen. Und dann geht man dann abend als Drag, obwohl man eine Woman ist. Alles möglich. Genau, ist ja alles möglich. Aber wenn jemand als Girl oder als Woman kommt, ist er halt so da.
Ja, und dieses Investigative, dieses Nachgehen und jetzt muss nochmal die Identität. Das ist für mich jetzt nicht nur auf diesen Bereich der Transsexualität bezogen, sondern ein deutliches Zeichen dafür, dass wir in so ein identitäres Denken eigentlich kommen, wo plötzlich alles nochmal nachfüllt. Wenn sie genau gefragt wird, wo sie eigentlich herkommt, klingeln bei mir gleich die Ohren, weil wir hier die Debatten ja hatten, dass wir nicht, wenn wir ins Taxi steigen, gleich fragen, oh, sie sehen ja nicht so aus wie ich, wo kommen sie denn her? Da sagt er aus Offenbach, ja, aber wo kommen sie denn wirklich her?
Solche Fragen stellt nur Dieter Bohlen.
Ja, das weiß ich noch nicht mal, den würde ich da noch als Tolerante ansehen. Ach nee, stimmt, der hat das ja auch.
Dieter Bohlen hat ein bisschen mit mir gefragt, wie so aus Würzburg. Ja, aber wo kommst du her?
Ja, stimmt.
Ja, aus Würzburg.
Also ja, in diesem Bereich ist man dann eigentlich, und das ist falsch, und deswegen hören wir uns jetzt ganz zum Schluss noch an, wie man es eigentlich vorbildlich macht. Es gibt nämlich noch eine andere Armandalier-Doku, die aber nur auf Französisch mit englischen Untertitel zu haben ist. Wir hören jetzt die französische Version. Ich lese dann das auf Deutsch vor. Die heißt Cormier mademoiselle. Und diese Doku ist so angelegt, dass man in der Gegenwart bei Armandalier beginnt und dann immer weiter in ihrem Leben an die Anfänge zurückgeht, bis man an folgendem Punkt ist.
From his childhood, from his adolescence, there is no testimony, no image. Amanda Lear has transformed her career into a Roman adventure, which she enriched and transformed for more than half a century. Born in Saigon, in French Indochina in 1939, or born in Hong Kong in 1950, fidel malgré elle à l'orient des colonies, mystérieux, étouffant et envoûtant, celui de Marguerite Duras et de Graham Greene. Son père serait officier de la marine anglaise ou un militaire français en poste en cochon chine. The mother of Amanda, whose daughter only said that she swore never to look like her. The beginning has disappeared. Did it erase it to draw a myth in its hand? Did it rewrite its biography as it dreamed it? The film ends on a coil whose mandala itself has disappeared. An absence, silence, Le noir, qui finit le récit. Ou le blanc éclatant. Comme un prélude à une nouvelle histoire.
Was haben wir da jetzt gehört?
Vielleicht sollten wir alle solche Dokus schauen, wenn es Gero von Böhm vorträgt. Das ist auch schon gut, aber das ist natürlich auch sehr gut.
Da kann ich jetzt nicht mithalten, aber es heißt da, von ihrer Kindheit, von ihrer Jugend, gibt es keinerlei Zeugnisse, kein einziges Bild. Amandaliya hat ihre Karriere in ein romantisches Abenteuer verwandelt, das sie über ein halbes Jahrhundert hinweg angereichert und umgestaltet hat. Geboren in Saigon, in französisch Indochina, im Jahr 1939 oder doch in Hongkong 1950. Ungewollt treu gegenüber dem geheimnisvollen, bedrückenden und betörenden Orient der Kolonien, jenem von Magritte du Rasse und Graham Greene. Ihr Vater soll Offizier der britischen Marine gewesen sein oder ein französischer Soldat, stationiert in Kuchangshin. Eines Tages soll er an einem jener abgelegenen Häfen Station gemacht haben, wo er eine Frau traf, ohne Nachnamen, ohne Vornamen, mal transsilvanisch, mal mongolisch, Amandas Mutter. Deren Tochter nur sagte, sie habe sich geschworen, niemals so zu werden wie sie. Der ganze Anfang ist verschwunden. Hat sie ihn gelöscht, um sich einen Mythos nach ihren Vorstellungen zu erschaffen? Hat sie ihre Biografie neu geschrieben, so wie sie sie sich erträumt hatte? Der Film endet mit einer Rolle Zelluloid, auf der ein Mandala zu sehen ist. Und der Mandalier selbst ist verschwunden. Eine Leere, Schweigen, das Schwarz, das die Geschichte abschließt. Oder ein grelles Weiß als Auftakt zu einer neuen Erzählung. Und man könnte auch sagen, das ist die Moderne. Man wird, wer man sein will und muss nicht mehr auf irgendwas zurückgeführt werden, sondern man hat sich dann entworfen. Und das wäre die unterstützenswerte Identitätspolitik, denn ich bin nicht grundsätzlich dagegen. Das wäre die Unterstützenswerte, die genau das ermöglicht und nicht mehr jemanden versucht, wieder an irgendeine Identität zu ankern.
Ja, und der Gegenentwurf oder Anwürfe, die man dann machen könnte, wäre, wenn sich jemand dafür interessiert. Nee, sorry, fand ich schon bei Erik Ahrens nicht zielführend.
Genau, diese Identitätshintervall.
Ich muss jetzt meine Gene ausrechnen, wie viel italienisch ich bin und so. Ja, das ist wirklich ein super interessanter Fall. Die Doku gestern fand ich sehr gut. Vor allem, weil sie nochmal diese Zeit einfach zeigt. Und vielleicht kann man es so nochmal...
Schon viel möglich, ne?
Ja, also unglaubliche Bandbreite an, während wir heute sagen, Nee, man braucht schon Internet, damit was möglich ist. So, wie hat man sich denn sonst koordiniert? Und es war einfach völlig klar, es werden Zeitpunkte und Orte ausgeflagt, in denen ist was möglich. Und dann waren da auch Kameras. Die Kameras waren aber nirgendwo sonst, anders als heute. Weshalb wir als Dokumente nur noch diese Highlights haben.
Ja, klar.
Und das ist schon ziemlich verrückt. But man sieht heute diese junge Frau, die diese Doku da macht und die sich einfach nicht davon lösen kann, dass sie ihre eigene Herkunft, die ihr natürlich viel abverlangt hat, biografisch, ist ja völlig klar. Und die natürlich in so einem politischen, ich sag jetzt mal, Gemengelage stattfindet, in der sehr viel instrumentalisiert, weaponized und so weiter. Man weiß nicht, wohin es führt. Es könnte auch ein schlimmes Verderben sein, wenn man sich Trumpet so anschaut und so. Dass der Appell dann wirklich ist, nee, also wir gehen erstens mal nicht hinter die persönliche Geschichte hinaus, die uns dargeboten wird. Bei Prominenz ist das ein bisschen entschuldigt, aber niemals zeitlich hinter den Zeitpunkt, in dem sich jemand selbst entwirft.
Ja, und hier geht die Kamera, wir haben das jetzt nicht gesehen, die geht da dicht dran und will nochmal gucken, ist jetzt gerade ein Mann, der dir nervös, weil sie das gehört hat.
Genau, was er grundsätzlich bedeutet, Fragen zur Kindheit sind Tapu. So, sondern irgendwann hat man, ich meine, auch die Päpste und so, die dürfen sich einfach einen neuen Namen aussuchen. Ja. Und das ist kein schlechter Modus, so, dass man sagt, ich bin jetzt Papst. Fragen sie mich nicht nach, wann ich nach Peru gegangen bin und warum, ob ich eine Vorhersehung hatte, dass hier mal Trump passiert oder sowas. Sondern das muss dann jeder mit sich selber klären. Klar, man soll es jetzt auch nicht zu übertreiben, Gegenstand einer Berichterstattung zu werden. Aber im direkten Gespräch so auf dieses Kindheitsding abgehen, wie auch...
Ja, und den ganzen Film nur über diese Thematik fahren.
Hotelmatzeartig zu gucken, wie die Leute ticken.
Dass Amanda Leer da mitgespielt hat und dass sie da auch darauf angesprochen werden kann und dann antwortet sie ja auch sowas, ja, aber ich hab noch immer die schönsten Beine des Showbusiness. Dann ist das ja auch gut. Aber diese Art der Nachfrage, das ist ja so symptomatisch leider für viele Debatten. Wir wollen schließen mit etwas, was du nur sehen kannst. Du beschreibst das aber jetzt zum Schluss. Wir müssen die Musik ein bisschen leiser drehen. Aber du sagst mal, was du da jetzt siehst. Ich hoffe, du hast es noch nicht zuvor gesehen. Und dann empfehlen wir es natürlich allen. What do you see there now?
Eine sakrale Veranstaltung mit sehr viel Kompösität.
Ja.
Aber es geht auch ästhetisch sehr......aufgestarrt in weltlich. Man läuft über eine Brücke. Wo kommt man denn her? Ist ein großes Kreuz ausgelegt, ein großes gelbes Kreuz auf der Straße.
Du siehst jetzt in rot gewandelt.
Rot bewandelt, also sind das keine Kardinäle.
Die Kardinäle tragen Sonnenbrillen.
Das sind Kardinäle?
Das verrät es ja schon, dass das dann wohl eher keine Kardinäle sind.
Sondern? Was sind das?
Ich spiele noch den zweiten Clip, damit du das siehst, was das ist. Das ist die Modenschau von Dolce & Gabbana. In Rom und sie haben sich, deswegen zeige ich dir, dass du bist ja neuer Fan des Katholizismus, am Katholizismus orientiert. Das heißt, die Herrenmode ist ganz auf Soutanen ausgelegt. Die Models tragen Weihrauchfässer, die Models tragen Zingulum, also wie bei der Soutaner, ja.
Also wir sehen jetzt einen Model in so einem ganz klassischen, römischen, weißen, ich bin immer sehr neidisch, weil keine Hose, man hüllt sich einfach ein sozusagen. Nur dieses Model trägt noch eine Büste vor sich. Von einem, ah warte mal, also von einer lebensgroßen Büste, aber nur der Kopf. Ja. Und es war ja damals in Rom wirklich so, dass wenn der Hausherr nicht da war, ist halt irgendwer aus dem Haushalt, konnte auch einfach so ein Sklave sein, zur Versammlung gegangen und hat aber dann die Büste mitgenommen und damit war derjenige anwesend. Also während man heute so Passagiere und Papiere so eine Differenz macht, war damals schon völlig klar, hier wird repräsentiert und die Person selbst muss nicht anwesend sein, es reicht die soziale Figur. Und das heute in eine Mode zu binden, ist ja wirklich grandios, denn Mode ist ja genau das, die Person zu erhöhen und zu sagen, wir sind hier in einem sozialen Raum und so weiter, ich bin hier jemand anders, ich repräsentiere. Hier haben wir natürlich einfach flexibel einfach Gesichter genommen, die dann auch passen, aber dass man die Gesichter in die Mode integriert, um sie dann mit Stolz davor laufen, vortragen zu lassen, das ist wirklich grandios.
Ja und man kennt ja diese, du hast jetzt vom römischen Reich gesprochen, und es ist natürlich das, worauf hier in Rom dann auch angespielt wird, die Kirchen, wo wir diese Skulpturen haben. An Messgewändern orientiert und verwandelt das Modus. Das, was hier dann passiert, ist natürlich die Loslösung aus dem religiösen im Sinne von, das ist meine Identität, sondern es wird jetzt überführt in die Ästhetik und in die Mode.
Ich sag mal so, ich habe die ja schon beschrieben und habe dann auch die Diplomarbeit von Jonas bekommen, dass mich der gottlose Katholizismus interessiert. Und zwar einfach nur, weil er jetzt schon sehr lange in Geschichte da liegt und in so, sagen wir mal, Verhaltensregeln geronnen ist. Also da steckt sehr viel Soziologie drin, die nicht unbedingt einen Gründungsmythos braucht. Das allerdings steckt selbst im Katholizismus drin, denn die Geburtskirche war weit. Ich werde im Oktober in Lissabon sein. Da gibt es ja einen Stadtteil, der einfach als Bethlehem ausgeflogen wird. So als Ersatz Pilgerstätte halt, so wie das auch in Frankreich und überall und so weiter ist. So, wir haben hier jetzt, so wie ich mich für die Inhalte des Katholizismus interessiere, ohne den Mythos oder den Glauben für mich mit, sondern einfach nur die inhaltliche Teil, haben wir hier eine Orientierung an der ästhetischen Komponente des Katholizismus, der selbst nochmal auf die Spitze getrieben. Also es ist klar Mode, aber es ist trotzdem total wiedererkennbar, allein weil auf dem einen Kleidungsstück da gerade 30 Kreuze verteilt waren und zwar reingenäht in die Mode.
Oder die tragen Anzug mit Albe, also mit diesem mit diesem Kleb. Oder hier sieht man ja dann dieses Stoffband drunter, das um den Bauch gewickelt ist, also Zingulum. Heißt das sehr richtig?
Ich möchte sie folgt sagen. Diesen Sommersalon ist es leider zu knapp. Man wird mich noch in normaler Kleidung sehen. Ab nächstem Jahr ist hier Action angesagt. Ich werde mir Garnitur zulegen.
Ich befürchte, da brauchen wir...
Und dann erzählst du mir noch mal was. Man braucht schon den Gott in der ganzen Geschichte.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Vor allem, du musst auch ein bisschen Geld mitnehmen. Ich glaube, das ist sehr teuer.
Eine kann ich mir bestimmt leisten. Die 40.000 Euro oder was? Nein, 40.000 Euro. Das ist doch Haute Couture, das ist doch richtig.
Das wird wahrscheinlich schon 15.000 bis 20.000 Euro kosten.
Das ist das Lebensziel. Eine muss drin sein. Eine Garnitur auf den Leib.
Also es gibt auch noch deutsche Gabaner Präter-Proté, das ist günstiger. Da bist du vielleicht mit 2000 dabei.
Wenn die die Linie da auch so ziehen, dann ja.
Oder wir gucken, du machst dir einen Anzug bei jemandem wie sonst und dann kaufen wir im Priesterhandel noch ein Zingulum.
Lass mich noch eine Poante machen. Du hast jetzt über diese Gender-Fragen geredet und wie man heute so einen Fetisch da ausbreitet und wir haben das versucht so ein bisschen mit Allgemeinen und so weiter. Das, was wir hier sehen, ist in einem Maße kulturelle Aneignung. Ja. Also da liegt einfach die ganze Straße, ist so diese Straßenkreuzung gelb mit Teppich ausgelegt, dass sie von oben als Kreuzer sieht und sie haben die Drohne selbst bestellt, die das von oben so filmt.
Ja.
Diese Kartinelle eröffnen wahrscheinlich, indem sie einfach den ersten Gang gemeinsam Lichter drüber machen, danach wird das einzeln.
Das finden natürlich auch nur Models.
So, genau. Das heißt, wir haben es hier mit einer sehr unchristlichen Veranstaltung zu tun.
Man könnte auch sagen Amtsanmaßung.
Genau. Die aber das auch macht, nicht nur weil es toll aussieht und da auch jahrhundertelang reingeronnen ist.
Es ist eine Omaaschenverneigung vor dem Katholizismus.
Genau. Und sie wissen, wir dürfen das, ohne etwas befürchten zu müssen, wie von anderen Religionen, wo man sowas machen würde. Was den Katholizismus wieder ein bisschen aufwertet. Also hier geht man Hand in Handstufen nach oben. Zivilisationsstufen, meine ich. Errungenschaften werden hier gerade gemacht. Das ist nicht nur eine Mode.
Ja, ganz richtig. Und Domenico Dolce und Stefano Garbano sind ja auch katholisch und verstehen sich auch so. Ja.
Ich bin begeistert. Katholizismus. Jeder darf's machen, wie er will. Gut. Und ich werde das für mich auch noch.
Bei YouTube, 30 Minuten lang, glaube ich, kann man sich die gesamte Show ansehen, die Herren.
Wir verlinken das.
Und dann auch zu empfehlen die Damen, dann aber nicht im nonnen Gewand, sondern die sind dann an der römischen Kultur orientiert. Also es lohnt sich, das anzusehen. Es ist eine spektakuläre Show.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, in welchem Kontext. Ich habe vorhin Witze gemacht über die aristokratische Frau, die schon immer Freiheiten für sich errungen hatte. Es wurde immer dokumentiert, wie sie so lebten. Niemals war es erlaubt. Bis dann irgendwann die letzten 30 Jahre Moderne kamen. Wenn man hier den Katholizismus bemüht und die Frau nicht ins nonnen Gewand zwängt, sondern ihr sozusagen den historischen Sonderfall der aristokratischen Frau plötzlich unterfüttert, also ihr den Pelz überwirft, grandios, toll.
Dann weisen wir zum Schluss noch darauf hin, dass wir am 23. August live zu erleben sind, hier in Frankfurt. Tickets findet man ganz einfach, wenn man auf den Link klickt. Da kann man noch Tickets buchen. Ich will darauf hinweisen, dass ich am 30. August in Dienstlaken bin. Da geht es um den Film La Anne. Der wird gezeigt, darüber spreche ich. Am 31. August bin ich in Trier. Dort wird der Film Coriolanus gezeigt. Und über den spreche ich dann. Und am 6. September bin ich wieder in meiner geliebten Schweiz. Da ist ein Podcastfestival in Zürich und dort werde ich seinen Tickets finden. Findet man über den Link auf meiner Homepage beziehungsweise bei Instagram wird man auch das alles finden.
Go Podcasting!
Da freue ich mich, wenn einige Hörer aus der Schweiz dann da sein werden. Wir wollen jetzt nochmal zum Schluss...
Ich habe übrigens keine Termine zu verkünden. Ich musste einen für heute absagen.
Ach.
Denn so schön wie du auf Filme getrimmt bist, bin ich auf Demografie getrimmt. Und das ARD-Morgenmagazin wollte mich heute 5.30 Uhr zur Kita-Schließung im Osten haben. Ich habe gesagt, ich muss ausgeschlafen sein, wenn ich über den neuen Katholizismus rede.
Ja.
Vielleicht sollte ich auch mal noch ein paar Filme sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ich verstehe das auch nicht.
Also wenn man was mit Filmen macht, wird man nicht um 5.30 Uhr gefragt. Wir wollen aber nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass wir uns sehr freuen, wenn ihr unseren Podcast unterstützt. Erstmal bedeutet das, den Podcast anderen zu empfehlen. Egal wie über welche Plattform oder direkt. Das freut uns sehr. Bedeutet auch, ihr könnt den Podcast abonnieren und auch positive Bewertungen abgeben. Das hilft uns sehr. Und ihr könnt den Podcast auch finanziell unterstützen. Das ist natürlich wunderbar. Und zwar über den Salon. Im Salon besprechen wir jeden Monat die wichtigen Sachbücher. Wir suchen immer ein Buch aus oder diesmal sogar zwei. Diskutieren darüber etwa zwei Stunden. Danach kommen noch Empfehlungen, Literatur, Belletristik wie Sachbücher, Zeitungsartikel, Magazinartikel, was wir gelesen haben, wichtige Paper. Das gibt es also im Salon zu hören. Außerdem gibt es die Live-Salons, die in Frankfurt stattfinden, dann auch hinter der Paywall zu hören. So auch den Live-Salon am 23. August. Und wir sprechen jetzt in diesem Monat über zwei dicke Werke. Und zwar einmal über das Buch Sam Altman, Open AI, Künstliche Intelligenz und der Wettlauf um unsere Zukunft von Keech Hagge. Das ist eine große Biografie, die sich auch vor allem beschäftigt mit dieser Ideologie des effektiven Altruismus. Also wir haben ja schon gelernt, das Leid der Welt ist das gerade so wichtig. Wir müssen ja 10.000 Mozarts in der Zukunft haben. So will es zumindest Jeff Bezos. Und auch Altman geht wohl in so eine Richtung. Die Biografie geht dem nach. Und wir werden uns das Unternehmen von Sam Altman genauer ansehen in einer großen investigativen Recherche von Karen Howe. Das Buch heißt Empire of AI, Dreams and Nightmares in Sam Altman's Open AI. Und werden uns auch fragen, wie weit wir durch Open AI, aber auch andere KI-Unternehmen einen neuen Kolonialismus erleben. Hast du schon was fest im Auge, was du lesen wirst? Bei mir ist es noch offen.
Nö, ich habe sehr lange... Nachdem Pocket nicht mehr da ist, nutze ich jetzt Redivice. Die haben auch einen Reader für solche Fälle. Und da wird schon die Liste mit bestehenden Texten Shortlist genannt. Also ich habe eine Shortlist, kann ich sagen. Sehr gut. Ich überlege auch, ob ich nicht sowieso mal die Salon-Texte, die Kandidaten sind, ob man die irgendwie publizistisch noch verlinken oder so weiter und so. Weil da ist ja doch mal einiges. Aber mal gucken. Wir müssen ja eh die Webseite mal neu machen. Das ist ja einiges, was jetzt neu kommt und so. Ja. Da überlegen wir uns durch. Also, gebt uns gerne Wunschlisten. Die nächsten Monate sind wir empfänglich für Wünsche.
Aber nicht dieses Buch von Ulf Poschert. Das wurde jetzt schon mehrmals geschickt.
Ich werde nicht drüber sprechen. Was könnte man auf der Webseite noch anzeigen über den Podcast hinaus, was wir bisher noch so... Ich weiß, Leute wünschen sich immer, dass wir die Clips, die wir spielen, noch mal auflisten. Das, finde ich, steckt im Transkript so weit drin. Da kann man einfach das Transkript fragen. Was haben die denn genannt, was sie spielen? Dass wir Clips einblenden, ist vorgesehen. Also, dass wir den neuen Katholizismus direkt im Video sehen und so weiter, das ist in der Mache. Aber ansonsten gibt es bestimmt noch ein paar Sachen, die ich jetzt nicht so auf dem Schirm habe, aber die man in dem Rutsch mal mitmachen könnte.
Gut, dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Man kann auch schon mal ein bisschen was hören zu den ganzen Open AI und KI Fragen. Wir haben schon häufiger darüber gesprochen, aber jetzt mal ganz systematisch. Und in gewisser Weise reiz ich das ein, eben in die Folgen über Peter Thiel, über was das Silicon Valley Denken nennt oder an das Buch von...
Technologische Republik.
Die Technologische Republik von Alex Karp. Also sehr viel wird jetzt damit auch fortgesetzt. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr in den Salon kommt. Ab drei Euro im Monat seid ihr dabei. Das geht über Steady ganz einfach.
Oder man bucht direkt bei Apple. Wenn man eh bei Apple hört, taucht es auf. Im selben Feed kostet da mal ein Euro mehr. Man kann aber auch in dem Apple Podcast Player die Steady, also die günstigere RSS-Situation einfach abonnieren. Oder wenn man schon einen Patreon-Account hat, da publizieren wir auch. Aber da ist weder das Archiv noch vollständig, noch ist das mit den Kapitelmarken richtig geklärt. Also da würde ich sagen, ist Steady immer noch der... Also Steady, aber nicht auf der Steady-Webseite, sondern man bucht bei Steady, man bekommt eine Mail, da ist ein RSS-Feed drin, man kopiert den in seinen Podcast Player, seiner Wahl ein. Dann kriegt man ganz normal den Podcast einfach geliefert. Und da ist die Kapitelmarkensituation drin. Und der Text in aller Ausführlichkeit und das Coverbild und so weiter.
Ja, es gibt da noch keine Doppelungen oder so. Man kann das dann alles wunderbar hören. Wir freuen uns, wenn wir uns im Salon sehen und freuen uns ganz besonders, wenn wir uns dann auch live in Frankfurt sehen.
Bis dahin. Ciao, ciao.